Ich hoffe, er tut es.
Lull.
Mal gucken, ob das Telekom-Lag sich jetzt wieder beruhigt hat.
Äh.
What the fuck?
Ich sehe jetzt bei mir nichts.
Läuft es bei euch?
Ich habe in meinem Vorschaufenster gerade eine ganz tolle Fehlermeldung.
In meinem Vorschaufenster habe ich gerade...
Äh.
The Twitch Machine got unplugged.
Try again in a moment.
Error 5000.
Es sollte kein Blackscreen sein.
Hä?
Jetzt geht es.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich finde es...
Alter, was geht mit dem Vogel ab?
The fuck?
Error 5000.
Ich verstehe es nicht.
Was auch immer.
Ich finde die Settings von Twitch immer so geil.
Ich ändere ja an meinem OBS nichts.
Gar nichts.
Nie ändere ich an meinem OBS was.
Und jedes Mal ist es irgendwie anders.
Und ich habe mir gedacht,
ich kann jetzt einfach mal streben.
Weil ich spiele eh den ganzen Tag schon Kingmaker.
Und ich habe mir gedacht,
ja gut, warum soll ich nicht einfach im Stream spielen.
Ich bin aber auch schon ein bisschen weiter.
Vor allem der Anfang ist auch ein bisschen langweilig.
Und für alle, die so klassische RPGs mögen,
ist das Game echt geil.
Kann man wirklich empfehlen.
Zoomt.
Mein Mammut geht mir auf den Sack.
Der macht die ganze Zeit nervige Geräusche.
Mammut, geh mal weg.
Ich muss jetzt nämlich mal ganz kurz skillen.
Das wird auch nicht leiser, wenn man weiter weg geht.
Schau, ich gehe jetzt von meinem Mammut weg.
Wenn ich mit meinem Mammut nichts zu tun habe.
Oh, was ist das?
Give loot.
Loot Blitz.
Wie ist die Lautstärke von mir und zum Game?
Passt auch.
Wie gesagt, ich habe nichts verstellt.
Aber man weiß ja nie so genau.
Also, Säure Aura.
Säure Aura.
Das klingt gut.
Das wäre natürlich noch besser, wenn ich es dem Charakter geben könnte,
der eigentlich vorne steht oder so.
Aber habe ich nicht.
Dann kriegt es mein Clary jetzt.
Das kriegt mein Clary.
Der hat nämlich nichts an.
Snaked sozusagen.
Wo ist es denn?
Sortieren.
Zack.
Easy.
So, jetzt wollen wir mal ganz kurz skillen.
Oh nee, Mammut, bleib weg.
Passt.
Nice.
Sehr schön.
Ich werde ganz kurz skillen.
Dann sage ich was zu meinem...
Also, zu meiner Party hier mal am Start.
Aber ganz schnell eine Runde specken.
Weil auf Level 8 tut es ihnen nicht allzu viel.
Ich habe extra gewartet, bis ich Level abhabe.
Quasi jetzt mal zu einer neuen Quest gehe.
Und da habe ich gedacht, komm, jetzt machst du den.
So, machst du den.
Machst du den.
Einfach mal streben an.
So, was brauchen wir?
Wir brauchen auf jeden Fall mehr Charisma.
Für mehr Zauber-Bash.
Ganz wichtig.
Da, da, da.
Dass wir ordentlich in Dialogen ordentlich was reißen.
Können weiter.
Zack, fertig.
Zauber-Spezialisierung.
Bester Skill überhaupt.
Magic Missile.
Bam.
Fertig.
Ach so, jetzt muss ich auch noch was auswählen.
Was?
Oh, das ist mein erster Level 4 Zauber.
Was taugt denn da was?
Zeig mal her.
Also, für AE habe ich meinen Feuerball schon am Start.
Da brauche ich sonst nichts.
Ich glaube, das ist ziemlich nice.
Da kann man sich teleportieren.
Also, ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich...
Ich habe vom Pathfinder-Regelwerk absolut keine Ahnung.
Ich habe ein bisschen Ahnung von Dungeons & Dragons.
Ich habe eine ganze Kampagne bisher gespielt in 5e
und halt die ganzen ollen Games gespielt, die auf 3.5 basieren.
Und soweit ich weiß, ist Pathfinder ein Dungeons & Dragons 3.5 Fork quasi.
Die haben irgendwie das 3.5 Regelwerk genommen
und ein bisschen, ein bisschen was daran herum gedoktert.
Dementsprechend.
Kennt man sich da eigentlich ganz gut aus.
Teleports, Zauber...
Es ist halt die Frage, ob das gut ist, ne?
Weil man Gegner irgendwie, jetzt sagen wir mal, den Berg runter teleportieren kann, ist das schon nicht schlecht.
Aber nachdem man seine Gruppe auch teleportieren kann,
scheint es nicht übel zu sein.
Das nehmen wir jetzt einfach mal.
Na ja, Stufe 10 Zauber haben wir noch keine.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es überhaupt Stufe 10 Zauber gibt.
Next.
Fertig.
Safe.
Wir spielen übrigens nicht auf schwer, sondern ich spiele hier auf Dings.
Challenge.
Einfach, weil die Monster dann ein bisschen mehr aushalten
und der Schwierigkeitsgrad eher dem ist, wie es irgendwie sein soll.
Und wenn ich mir überlege, wie bei diesem Game rumgeheult wurde auf Steam auch, ne?
Das ist schon richtig krass gewesen.
Habe ich eigentlich Qualitätsoptionen mittlerweile?
Na, wie krass auch bei diesem Game rumgeheult wurde auf Steam, wie schwer das ist, muss man ganz ehrlich sagen.
Weil man ein bisschen aufpasst, was man speckt.
Ein bisschen, das ist ein bisschen taktischer Spiel.
Es ist überhaupt gar kein Ding.
Ich weiß ja nicht, was die Leute alle haben.
So, Valerie kriegt ein Dex mehr.
Dann hat sie 16 Dex und eine Rüstungsklasse mehr.
Und ja, ansonsten braucht die nicht wirklich großartig was.
Brauchen wir alles nicht.
Vielleicht kann sie was kochen später, wenn man Weltwissen...
Oh, wenn das die Feministen sehen, dann geht es wieder ab.
Oh, ja, wenn man kochen will.
Für die Gruppe braucht man hier Wissen auf Welt.
Warum auch immer.
Weil.
So, und dann brauchen wir jetzt noch irgendwas für mehr Rüstung.
Mehr Rüstung ist immer gut.
Schildfokus.
Schildfokus ist nice.
Da kriegen wir bestimmt...
Okay, noch mehr Rüstungsklasse.
Das heißt, wir haben jetzt 35 Rüstungsklasse.
Das ist übertrieben krass.
Schon hyped auf Blackout.
Unglaublich.
Tatsächlich muss ich sagen, von den ganzen Battle Royale Games...
Ich fand das jetzt...
Gar nicht so schlecht.
Ich fand es gar nicht so übel.
Wann kommt denn das eigentlich raus?
Das ist nicht mehr so lang, oder?
Nächste Woche oder so?
Zwölfter.
Kommt das raus?
So, mal Skillzorn.
Barb.
Ja, die kriegt natürlich Stärke, was sonst?
Wobei die sicherlich auch einmal Decks gebrauchen könnte, aber Stärke...
Damage.
Damage muss sein.
Zack, zack.
Zack, und...
Keine Ahnung.
Ich vollkommen egal, was wir hier specken.
Ähm...
Mehr...
Zweites Level davon.
Jawoll.
So, unser Bade.
Brauche auch ein neues Level.
Die dürfte man auf dem Level nicht allzu viel kriegen.
Charisma.
Zack, zack, zack.
So, was nehmen wir für Level 3 Zauber für unseren Bade?
Äh, am 12. kommt glaube ich, ähm, kommt glaube ich, ähm, Black Ops raus, oder?
Ich glaube, am 12. kommt Black Ops raus.
Ich bin ja mal gespannt, ob das wirklich...
Was nehmen wir denn hier?
Lass mal kurz überlegen.
Lindsay ist ja eher so mein CC und, äh, vor allem Buff-Charakter.
Magieband haben wir schon.
Heal brauchen wir nicht.
Da haben wir unseren Clary.
Der heilt genug.
Haste habe ich auf meinem Helm.
Das brauchen wir auch nicht.
Gift habe ich auch auf dem Clary.
Okay.
Das trifft aber auch eigene.
Das ist, das ist blöd.
Puh, das ist auch ein Kack.
Das brauchen wir nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich, ich tendiere ja da, aber noch mehr Haste-Ladung brauche ich eigentlich gar nicht.
Ich habe auf meinem, äh, ich habe auf meinem Hexer, habe ich, äh, Hexenmeister, habe ich Haste.
Das reicht.
Da habe ich 6 Ladungen Haste.
Das reicht zwischen jeder Rast.
Das brauche ich nicht.
Ähm, haben wir hier noch irgendwelche AE-Sachen?
Die nur Feinde treffen?
Das habe ich auch auf meinem Clary.
Das brauche ich alles nicht.
Alle Feinde verlangsamen.
Aber das habe ich auch schon auf meinem Held.
Eigentlich brauche ich die ganzen Zauber nicht.
Verwirren.
Brauchen wir nicht.
Ich nehme jetzt, ich nehme jetzt einfach mal, das habe ich auf meinem Clary schon.
Wir nehmen jetzt einfach mal das hier.
Dass wir uns auch durch schweres Gelände schnell bewegen können.
Die ganze Gruppe.
Ich glaube zwar nicht, dass wir das oft brauchen, aber wenn wir es brauchen, ist es bestimmt gar nicht so übel.
Oh, nice.
Neues.
Neuer Bard-Song.
So, Clary-Specken.
Hast du Overwatch World Cup geguckt?
Ein bisschen habe ich geguckt.
Ich habe geguckt, wie Team Germany auf den Sack gekriegt hat.
Ähm, wie die Schweiz was, glaube ich, auf den Sack gekriegt hat.
Ähm, dass UK und Frankreich ziemlich geowned haben.
Oh, was gibt es denn hier auf Level 8?
Das ist Special-Fähigkeit von der Klasse.
Heilige Lanze auf Stufe 8, kannst du bla bla bla bla bla bla bla.
Ja, was bringt es?
Stufe 8 einmal täglich.
Was macht es?
Ah, okay, Damage-Waffe für irgendeine Nahkampfwaffe.
Das ist schon mal nicht schlecht.
Kann man sich einfach vorm Fall buffen.
Gut ist.
Ähm, ja, bei dem kann ich eigentlich nur Weisheitsbecken.
Das bringt das nächste, nächsten 4 Level oder sowas.
Ähm, zack zack.
Tja, wirklich.
Brauche ich eigentlich alles nicht.
So, jetzt noch mal einen Ranger.
Und dann geht es los.
Äh, Waldläufer Level 8, was gibt es da?
Bevorzugtes Gelände wählen, okay.
Was hat er denn als erstes bevorzugtes Gelände?
Wald.
Was kann man mal gucken, was man da alles auswählen kann.
So, geschickt.
Geschickt, was kriegt der?
Constance Weisheit.
Ja, der kriegt auch mehr Decks für mehr Damage.
Wobei das Alter das nächste Level irgendwie was bringt.
Ähm, ja, irgendwie ist das alles, braucht das alles.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich hier specken kann.
Ja.
Zack.
Ebene erstellt, Hochland, Stadt, Untergrund, Untergrund, Dungeon.
That is not far.
Ach, auf geht's.
So, mit meinem krassen, krassen Mammut-Pet, das immer alle own.
Gegen Frankreich hat Team Germany fast gewonnen.
Okay.
Ähm, das habe ich, das könnte sogar sein, als ich das geguckt habe.
Ich bin mir, ich bin mir gar nicht mehr sicher.
Es könnte sein, als ich geguckt habe, das war dann 3-2 oder so, ne?
Übelst knapp.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wann das überhaupt losgeht.
Ist das wieder auf der Gamescom?
Ne, die Gamescom war ja schon.
Äh, ne, auf der Play, äh, nicht auf der Gamescom.
Was erzähl ich denn?
Auf der Blizzcon.
Haha.
Lol.
Auf der Gamescom.
Ja, fast.
Okay, gucken wir mal.
Also, ähm, nur mal so, für alle, die jetzt einschalten.
Ähm, wie gesagt, ich bin ja Level 8 und ich habe schon eine Weile gespielt.
Ich bin in Akt 2.
Und wir sind hier gerade dabei, wir machen hier das Quest, Verschwundenes Kind.
Und wir suchen...
Irgend...
...ein Kind, was abgehauen ist aus der Hauptstadt.
Weil, ich meine, wir sind zwar, ähm, ich kann, kann ich euch die Map von hier zeigen?
Ne.
Wir sind zwar Baron, ja, und könnten uns eigentlich um, äh, Regierungsaufgaben kümmern.
Aber nein, wir ziehen ja noch selbst los und, äh, erledigen sinnlose Hole-5-Eier-Quests.
Warum?
Weil das so sein muss.
Ja, und dann machen wir Dings hier, ähm.
...die, die, die Quest, wo wir hier gucken, was auf der Insel los ist.
Wow, oh, the fuck.
Wo ist der ganze, da ist ein Gegner am Start, weil, guck, guckst du hier in deinem Quest-Journal und auf einmal, ne.
Okay, alleine sind die Dinger nicht so das Problem.
Die machen übelst, ähm, äh, Elektrizitäts, äh, Damage.
Alleine sind die kein Problem.
Das war richtig MonkaS, äh.
Aber wenn es mehr sind, ist das, machen die übelst Damage.
Zumal die den, den Hang dazu haben, alles, äh, auf meinen Held zu schießen.
Und wenn der Held, ja, er hier, wenn der Held down ist, ist alles down.
Und ich warne euch schon mal vor, nachdem wir auf Schwierig-Spiel, also nicht auf Schwer, sondern auf, auf diesem, also nicht auf Normal, sondern auf, auf Challenge.
Auf Fordernd heißt das, glaube ich, auf Deutsch, dieser, dieser Schwierigkeitsmodus.
Äh, wie heißt das?
Nachdem wir auf, auf relativ Schwierig spielen.
Kann sein, dass wir öfters mal...
Kann sein, dass wir öfters mal neu laden müssen.
Aber das Spiel ist wirklich easy.
Ne, der ist nicht tot.
Der ist nicht, doch, der ist tot.
Ähm, das Spiel ist nicht schwierig.
Also, ne, ihr müsst ja mal bei Steam gucken.
Ich zeige euch das mal kurz, ähm, hallo.
Was habe ich jetzt hier aufgemacht?
Äh, Steam.
Steam.
Ich muss euch das mal zeigen, ey.
Die Leute, das ist total, total beknackt, äh.
Die haben echt, ja, echt den übelsten Dachschaden.
Oh, ja, oh.
Mittlerweile heißt es mostly positive.
Also, bei Release hatte das Spiel mixt Kritiken,
weil die Leute alle krass rumgeheult haben, wie schwer das ist.
Die, die haben, die haben alle so rumgeheult, wie schwer das Game ist, ne.
Und ich dachte mir schon so, boah, ey, endlich mal quasi was mit nem,
na, gut umgesetzten, äh, Pen & Paper Regelwerk und mal gucken, wie das ist.
Und muss man sich bestimmt voll einlesen, dass das klappt, ne.
Game angemacht, ein bisschen Theorie crafted, wie könnte man seinen Held skillen.
Zack, bumm, alles weggebashed.
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was die für Schmerzen haben, ne.
Die, es gab am Anfang so ne Quest, da musste man, also ihr kennt ja so, wenn man, wenn man in RPGs anfängt,
die erste Quest ist immer Ratten killen, Spinnen killen oder sonst was in der Richtung.
Und natürlich gab's hier, im Kingmaker gab's natürlich auch so ne, so ne Quest für, ähm, Töte irgendwie,
gehen in die Spinnenhöhle und bringen alle Spinnen um.
Und das Game hat hier vorher extra, äh, also, ne, es hat hier gesagt, es steht nämlich in dieser Stadt, wo man losgeht,
so ein Alchemist rum und hat gesagt, hier,
nehm Alchemist Feuer mit, weil Spinnen sind anfällig gegen Feuer.
Also hab ich mir gedacht, okay, mach's einfach ein paar Alchemistbomben, skills fast, skills ein bisschen Feuer
und die Spinnen wurden weggebashed ohne Ende, ja.
Und das ist das, diese Stelle, da hab ich irgendwie drei Minuten für gebraucht, war mega easy,
wo ganz Steam rumgeheult hat und so nach dem, oh mein Gott, das Game ist so schwer.
Ich weiß nicht, also, ich hab, manchmal hab ich das Gefühl, wisst ihr, manchmal, manchmal denk ich irgendwie so,
die Leute haben,
verlernt,
Games zu spielen.
Weil, weil quasi jedes Game heute aus Tutorials besteht, die sich über das ganze Game hinziehen, Onscreen-Hinweise.
Du bist ja auch komplett frei, wenn wir hier durch sind, zeige ich euch mal die World Map,
du bist relativ frei, wo du hingehst und das sind die, ich glaube, das sind die Leute nicht mehr gewöhnt.
Oder auch, und was, was, was generell Spieler von heute nicht mögen, hab ich den Eindruck, ist, wenn man
irgendwas nicht schaffen kann,
ähm,
später wiederzukommen, das ist ja halt so.
Hier trifft man öfters mal in irgendeiner Höhle,
trifft man halt, äh, Monster,
die halt, da
hausen und die halt
einfach mal acht Level über dir sind
oder sowas.
Und die kannst du halt einfach nicht bashen.
Steph.
Was willst du machen, ne? Dann gehst du einfach raus und kommst einfach
ein paar Level später wieder
und basht weg. Das ist
kein Ding.
Sag mal, bin ich überladen
oder so?
Ich glaube, ich bin tatsächlich überladen, hm?
Oh, was ich nicht vergessen darf, ha, ich hab ja meinen Clary gespeckt, der kann ja noch, ähm,
da kann er neue Sachen auswählen und, ähm,
ne, ich kann nix mehr auswählen.
Follow my lead.
Äh, wir rasten mal kurz.
Falls man die rasten darf, MonkaS, ich glaube,
darf man die rasten?
Und ich muss sagen, ich find auch, dass das, ähm,
dieses Camping-System hier übelst nice, wie sie das gemacht haben.
Das ist halt, man merkt halt, dass sie sich da schon einigen Pen-and-Paper-Regelwerk orientiert haben,
wo normalerweise Leute um den Tisch zusammensitzen.
Weil das ist halt, auf den ersten Blick sieht's halt überkompliziert aus,
wie man, ähm, quasi rasten kann.
Ich meine, guckt euch das mal an, denkt ihr so, pff,
what the fuck, äh, ähm,
sprich, das Rastsystem ist komplizierter als das Camp-, das Kampfsystem in manchen Games heutzutage.
Aber im Prinzip ist es eigentlich relativ einfach, ne?
Man braucht irgendeiner, der sich gut, äh, auskennt hier in Wissenwelt,
der kann kochen.
Dann brauchst du irgendeinen, der gut stelzen kann, der kann das Lager tarnen.
Dann brauchst du irgendeinen, der gut in Natur ist, der kann Zeug jagen.
Dann Clary kann am Feuer sitzen und alle heilen und der Rest schiebt Wache.
Fertig.
Mehr musst du eigentlich nicht, nicht beachten, ja?
Und wenn du das nämlich verkackst,
und vielleicht sehen wir das jetzt ja auch, das kann schon sein,
wenn ich jetzt hier campe, werde ich nämlich nachts über-,
aber ich wollte gerade sagen,
werde ich nämlich nachts überfallen.
Von...
was auch immer das hier jetzt ist.
Bashen wir einfach.
Au.
Geh weg.
Oh, fuck.
Die stehen voll an meinem Held dran.
Au, au, au, au, au, au, au, au.
Oh, das war keine gute Idee.
Die, die haben ja, die, ey, die haben...
Die haben übelst meinen Held gebasht.
Das ist aber fies, ja.
Jetzt haben wir eine negative Stufe.
Habe ich noch Fluch-, Fluchbrechen ausgewählt mit meinem Clary?
Sonst muss ich jetzt gleich nochmal rasten.
Ähm...
Fluch?
Äh, wo ist denn Fluch?
Nein, den habe ich natürlich nicht ausgerüstet.
Na?
Geil.
Das heißt, ich muss jetzt mein Clary gleich mal ausrüsten mit Fluch-, Fluchbrechen.
Ja?
Weg hier.
Fluchbrechen.
Das ist übrigens verbuggt.
Also man, man kann normalerweise die Domänenzauber in jeden Slot packen,
aber auf den höheren Level geht es nicht mehr.
Ja, das ist irgendwie verbuggt.
Äh, Fluchbrechen, Fluchbrechen, Fluchbrechen und jetzt rasten.
Safe.
Ja, und man sieht jetzt, das war jetzt quasi ein...
Ich, ich wurde quasi nachts überfallen auf dem höheren Schwierigkeitsgrad
und trotzdem ist nichts passiert.
Alter!
Ist ja gut.
The fuck?
Höhöhö.
Der Treibbaum.
Okay, dann brauchen wir erstmal Badensong an.
Ähm, Clary healt einmal.
Ich mach eine Runde Haste auf meine Leute.
Der ballert auf den Baum.
Zack.
Next.
Easy.
Buffs sind alles in dem Game.
So geil.
So, darf ich jetzt vielleicht...
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Nicht, nicht rasten, nicht rasten.
Hat der Clary schon sein Zeugs gereckt?
Hat der Clary schon sein Zeugs vielleicht gereckt?
Stufe 2.
Fluchbrechen.
Nee, hat er noch nicht.
Das ist natürlich blöd.
Also, es ist so.
Ähm, das ist wie, wie in Dungeons & Dragons 3.5.
Ich weiß nicht, ganz aus dem Kopf gar nicht, wie es in 5.5 ist.
Du musst halt als Wizard und als Clary musst du dir halt in dein Buch schreiben, was für
Zauber du gerade verwenden willst.
Und dann musst du einmal rasten.
Sag mal!
Darf ich rasten heute nochmal irgendwann?
Dann muss ich mal rasten.
Dann muss ich mal rasten heute noch mal irgendwann?
the fuck ka...
oder darf ich hier nicht rasten?
Ich geh gleich wieder aus dem Gebiet raus, raste einmal, und gehe wieder in das Gebiet
rein.
Wenn es so weitergeht.
So Mann Mammut, rennt jetzt mal an den Baum da runter?
Du ballerst auf den Baum hier unten drauf.
Barde macht Song an.
Clary macht Segen an.
Und wir essen.
Und dann werden sie gefragt, die Bäume.
Ja, kurz raus oben runter.
Hey Max, holst du dir das neue Anno?
Äh
Ich überlege gerade, was das neue Anno ist
Was war denn das neue Anno?
Eigentlich mag ich nämlich die Serie
Anno 1800, okay
Das habe ich schon voll verdrängt
Irgendwie, dass das in nächster Zeit kommt
Also, wenn es nicht so verkacken
Wie bei SimCity, ich weiß, es hat jetzt mit Warp Mix zu tun
Aber SimCity fand ich auch immer ganz gut
Und das letzte SimCity war halt
Kompletter Reinfall, ne
Sag mal
Ich darf nicht rasten, wollt ihr mich verar...
Was ist das? Alter, MonkaS
Und wieder voll in meinem Held drin
Mein Held ist down
Na geil
So, wisst ihr was, ich lade jetzt und gehe von der Insel runter
Raste einmal und dann gehe ich wieder auf die Insel
Scheiß drauf
Ich raste, ich gehe jetzt von der Insel runter und raste
Kein Bock auf den Scheiß hier
Hallo Sirius, Max
Warum soll ich auf der Insel rasten
Wo mich nichts rasten lässt, wenn ich einfach von der Insel runter gehen kann
Dann rasten
Eigentlich wollte ich nur rasten, dass ich meine Clary-Spells kriege
Und es geht immer weiter bergab, ey
Ah, hier gibt es neue Events
Also, jetzt kann ich euch mal die Weltkarte zeigen an der Stelle
Das ist übelst groß
Hier ist meine Hauptstadt irgendwo
Äh, da ist meine Hauptstadt
Die zweite Stadt, die ich da oben hingebaut habe
Das Game hat so einen Mini
So einen Mini-Wirtschaftszweig
Also so ein ganz kleines, so ein bisschen
Ähm, wo man sich halt sein, sein
Sein, nicht Königreich, sein
Wie nennt man das auf Deutsch?
Seine Baronie kümmern muss
Ja, da muss man irgendwie, ähm
Bürgermeister, äh, nicht Bürgermeister
Irgendwie, ähm
Ja, Leute ernennen, die für spezielle Sachen zuständig sind
Wie Militär und, und, und Kram
Also, der Zweig ist nicht allzu ausgeprägt, ja
Ähm, ja
Und was ich cool finde, dass auch in alten Gebieten, wo man schon war
Öfters mal was Neues kommt, ja
Zum Beispiel hier, Hütte der Sumpfhex
Ist jetzt irgendwie ein neues Ereignis, kann ich hin
Und stell's in Sonne
Ich zeige euch mal die Welt, die Welt, map
Soweit ich, ich weiß nicht, was ich hier mache
Soweit ich das hier überblicken kann
Kann man hier überall hin, bis zum Rand
Das ist übelst groß, ne
In den meisten Gebieten bin ich noch gar nicht gewesen
Ich bin eigentlich hauptsächlich hier, in diesem mittleren Gebiet unterwegs
Gibt's auch viele Punkte, wo man gucken kann
Und hinter jedem dieser Punkte steckt im Endeffekt so ne Map
Wie ich jetzt eben hier grad gewesen bin
Also ist auch ordentlich umfangreich
So, jetzt campen wir mal
In der Hoffnung, dass wir nicht wieder überfallen werden
Sogar, guck mal, sogar das Kochen hat funktioniert
It's as fuck
Äh, Servus
Max, kannst du kurz was zu dem Game sagen?
Bin gerade, dass es neu dazukommt
Ich find, das Game ist wirklich top
Ich find, das ist das Beste
Das Beste, so, so, Classic RPG
Der letzten, in letzter Zeit
Ja, und ich hab fast alles gespielt
Ich hab, ich hab Pillars gespielt
Ich hab, äh, Pillars 2, was gab's da noch?
Äh, Original Sin 1 und 2
Pillars of Eternity 1 und 2
Ähm
Ich, ich hab quasi alles gespielt
Was es so an, an
Klassischen RPGs
Gegeben hat, in letzter Zeit
Und
Ich muss sagen, das gefällt mir
Bisher noch mit am besten
Was, hat das nicht geklappt?
Ach ne, da braucht man Genesung für
Da braucht man gar nicht Fluchbrechen für
Na, das ist ja reudig
Da muss ich dann eh wieder in die Hauptstadt, ey
Das ist ja scheiße
Das ist aber ganz schön kacke
Besser als Ballreisen
Naja, das kann man so nicht sagen
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich
Von Baldur's Gate 1 war ich kein großer Fan
Wow
Oh ne, hab ich nicht gespeichert, ich Kacknoob
Manchmal bin ich echt
Manchmal bin ich echt dumm, äh
Doch, ich hab gespeichert
Ähm, es hat Auto gesaved
Okay, jetzt ist es natürlich ein bisschen doof
Jetzt hat mein Held, ähm, Levelabzüge
Da muss ich erst in die Hauptstadt, um das Ganze heilen zu können
Da sieht man halt auch, dass es ein bisschen
Bisschen schwieriger ist
Ähm, besser, naja, also
Baldur's Gate kann ich dazu sagen
Was wollte ich jetzt machen?
Ich wollte erstmal meinen Clary nochmal
Wieder ordentliche Spells geben
Hat er jetzt eigentlich Genesung mittlerweile?
Clary, Genesung
Hat er Genesung?
Ja, nice, ich kann's heilen
Ich kann's heilen, ist doch gut
Ich kann's heilen, nice
Deswegen braucht man immer einen Clary
Clary, Beste
So, wir wollen ein Gebet haben
Zack, Gebet
Gebet
Ich sag gleich was, was ich zu Baldur's Gate denke
Ähm, Gebet brauchen wir
Und
Bisschen Damage kann im Endeffekt auch nicht
Schaden, den der Clary noch machen kann
Ähm
So, jetzt müssen wir noch einmal rasten
Und dann
Müsste es eigentlich gut passen
Also
Besser als Baldur's Gate
Also, Baldur's Gate vom ersten Teil
Bin ich persönlich überhaupt kein Fan
Baldur's Gate, also vom Baldur's Gate 1
Wohlgemerkt
Das war mir durch die Bank weg zu langsam
Und noch zu wenig ausgereift das ganze
Zumal es in Baldur's Gate 1 ganz viele Klassen gibt
Also in der ursprünglichen Variante
Die halt zacken
So, so, so, so
So wie Wizard die ersten paar Levels
Ist halt Kacke
Baldur's Gate 2 war übelst gut
Für die damalige Zeit
Ich finde es wird ein bisschen zu sehr
Mit, ähm
Ja, Nostalgiebrille draufgeguckt
Baldur's Gate hat auch schon ein paar nervige Sachen
So, beschränktes Inventar und sonst was
Was Baldur's Gate 2 und auch die Erweiterung auf jeden Fall hatte, die, was weit über dem liegt, was die meisten Spiele heutzutage haben, ist, wie es geschrieben ist.
So, mal gucken, ob ich jetzt meine Debuffs loswerde.
Ich speichere mal vorher.
Auf, Clary. Mach hinne.
Ja, okay, passt.
Ich hab doch Genesung zweimal ausgewählt, oder?
Was zum Teufel?
Ich kann das nur einmal ausführen?
Warum?
Ach, weil mir...
Oh Gott, ey.
Ich kann es nur einmal ausführen, weil ich nicht die richtigen Komponenten zum Zaubern dabei habe.
Oh Gott, ich krieg Anfälle, ey.
Egal, wir...
Oh, shit.
Fail.
Na gut, da müssen wir jetzt durch.
Wir müssen eh danach in die Hauptstadt.
Da kaufe ich mir eine Scroll und gut, es...
Gift neutralisieren haben wir schon.
Und noch einen Heal.
So, speichern.
So, und jetzt rasten wir noch einmal und dann geht's los.
Ey, Alter, was?
Was ein Akt, ey.
Besser als Divinity 2, anders.
Divinity 2 fand ich auch nice.
Vor allem, nachdem es...
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es es schon gibt.
Hast du nicht das Komponenten...
Komponentenlos Zauberntalent?
Äh, nein, hab ich nicht.
Bis jetzt hab ich noch keinen einzigen Zauber gesehen, der überhaupt eine Komponente braucht.
Das ist der erste Zauber, wo ich auch gesehen hab, dass man dafür was braucht.
Eine Komponente.
Und...
Ich hab mir auch ehrlich gesagt keine Gedanken zugemacht, dass das notwendig ist.
Weil in, ähm...
In 5e können Claris ja ohne Komponenten zaubern, wenn sie eben ihr...
Ihr Gött...
Ihr Holy Symbol...
Also, sprich, ihr von ihrem jeweiligen Gott halt so einen Anhänger oder sowas dabei haben.
Was anscheinend so nicht ist hier.
Was aber nicht schlimm ist.
Ich mein, ich werd's überleben.
Level-Abzug auf dem...
Auf dem Hexenmeister ist jetzt zwar nicht schön, aber wir kriegen's...
Wir kriegen das schon hin.
Ist das überhaupt ein Level-Abzug oder was gibt's?
Ja, Level-Abzug.
Ja, wir müssen in die Hauptstadt, in die Hauptstadt danach.
Hab jetzt auf YouTube gesehen, dass einige Battlefield-Veteranen Battlefield 5 nicht mal so schlecht finden.
Naja.
Ich muss, ich muss sagen, ähm...
Wenn sie da ein paar Sachen ändern...
Also, das Bash-Potenzial bei Battlefield 5 ist auf jeden Fall da.
Das, das, was mich am meisten an Battlefield 5 genervt hat, ist halt, dass sie an jede Ecke irgendwelche Animationen gepappt haben.
So wie Hochklettern auf, auf den Waggon.
Also, sprich, auf den, bei einem Zug.
Was dann immer nicht funktioniert, wo du fünfmal dahinter springen musst und sowas.
Also, dieses Animationsgedöns ging mir in Battlefield 5 eigentlich am meisten auf den Keks.
Ja, auch noch was zum Thema, besser als Divinity 2.
Kann man, kann man so nicht sagen.
Es ist halt deutlich mehr, merkt man, dass es an...
So, oh, fuck.
So an klassischen Pen & Paper-Sachen orientiert ist.
Wie das mit dem Rastsystem und halt, dass es nicht rundenbasiert ist, sondern...
Wie Baldur's Gate, ähm...
Echtzeit mit Pause.
Ja.
Okay.
Also, wir wissen jetzt, da sind Gegner.
Da können wir uns buffen.
Noch eine Sache zu Baldur's Gate.
Baldur's Gate, äh, ja.
Also, wie gesagt, ich bin der Meinung, wie es geschrieben ist, Baldur's Gate 2, ist das deutlich besser als die meisten anderen Games heutzutage, was Dialoge angeht.
Und halt auch wie, was die, die Charaktere für Hintergründe haben und sowas.
Auch besser als, als Kingmaker.
Da ist Baldur's Gate 2 wirklich richtig gut.
Ähm, vor allem damals haben sie es halt auf den Punkt gebracht, ne.
Da hat ein Charakter nicht eine halbe Stunde geladen.
Und eine halbe Stunde Text von sich gegeben, sondern fünf Dialogfelder und du wusstest Bescheid.
So.
Also, wir wissen jetzt, da sind Gegner.
Wie gehen wir das Ganze jetzt am besten an?
Wir buffen uns erstmal mit, ähm...
Ups.
Nein, nein, Tristan.
Ne, das wollen wir nicht.
Ähm...
Wir wollen Schutz vor Elektrizität.
Das wollen wir auf jeden Fall haben.
Dann wollen wir haben Haste, dass wir schneller bashen können.
Und dann wollen wir auch Bansong haben.
Und dann wird geschreckt.
Auf geht's.
Jetzt kriegen sie aufs Morvel.
So, mein, äh, Mammut geht mal hier hoch.
Dass der beschäftigt ist.
Mammut, kommst du da nicht durch?
Zack.
Da können sie gar nichts mehr.
Buffen ist das halbe...
Guck mal, easy, easy.
Der lebt noch, der lebt noch.
Wenn man gebufft ist, ist das Ganze nicht mehr so einfach.
Man muss nur noch ein bisschen Zeit haben.
Das Ganze nur halb so schwer.
All according to plan.
Und ich glaube, das ist auch das,
warum viele so rumgemerkert haben, dass das Game so schwer ist.
Weil man, weil man,
man kommt halt nicht so wirklich weiter mit
oder es ist ein Gegner, man klickt drauf,
bam, alles kaputt. Das geht mit irgendwelchen
Level 1 Wölfen oder so geht das.
Oh.
Da ist wieder so ein Viech.
Mit irgendwelchen Level 1 Wölfen oder so
geht das, ja, aber mit ein bisschen schwereren
Gegnern ist das halt nicht mehr so drinnen.
Da ist er down.
Haben wir schon gelootet.
Oh guck mal, was gibt es denn hier?
Ist das ein
Naturathletik?
Kommen wir hier hoch?
Bevor wir den Weg ausprobieren,
laufen wir einmal drum herum und gucken uns das Ganze
hier so an, wie es so weitergeht.
Man kann nämlich, deswegen ist es auch
ein bisschen wichtig, also ist es auch wichtig, dass man
ausgewogen
seine
Fertigkeiten
skillt.
Man sieht, mein
Mammut weiß
nicht sonderlich viel.
Mein Mammut ist ziemlich dumm.
Mein Mammut ist übelst dumm.
Intelligenz 2.
Aber eigentlich, was ich eigentlich zeigen wollte, ist,
dass es hier halt sinnvoll ist, wenn man
das Zeug skillt, weil
zum Beispiel hier kann man jetzt halt,
ja, mein Held hat jetzt hier plus 10 auf Wissen Natur.
Das heißt, er könnte jetzt hier einen Check
machen und das ist halt deutlich näher an irgendeiner
Pen & Paper Vorlage dran.
Einen Natur-Check machen, ob man hier nicht drüber kommt.
Oder alternativ könnte hier irgendwie
Amiri oder hier mein
Ranger gucken, ob sie es mit
irgendeinem Athletik-Check schaffen.
Aber wir laufen erstmal drum herum und gucken.
Warum kommen keine YouTube-Videos von mir?
Weil mir,
also zum Haupt, hauptsächlich liegt es
daran, weil mir die Games fehlen.
Valerie,
wie wär's mal mit mitlaufen?
Weil mir, ja,
hauptsächlich weil mir die Games fehlen, die ich geil find.
Und die auf YouTube passen.
Wir machen jetzt
Matrix 17.
Wir werden jetzt mal richtig debaten, die Gegner.
Falls hier ein Gegner ist, mal gucken.
Nope, kein Gegner da.
Hier sind 100 pro Gegner irgendwo.
Uh! Au!
Au! Au! Das war keine so gute Idee,
mit meinem Held vorzulaufen.
Okay, Haste.
Haste.
Give Haste. Give Bardsong.
Give Barbrage.
Truff.
Einer nach dem anderen.
Weg. Weg-Fokus. Leute, lasst doch mal den Wolf durch.
Au! Au! Au! Au! Au!
Clary, einmal healen, bitte.
Clary, heilen.
Okay, nice.
Die haben mich aber echt ganz schön auf den Sack gegeben.
Fehlt mir irgendein Spell hier?
Ja, mir fehlt ein Spell.
Man kann sagen, irgendwie ist es so leer in der Leiste.
Einmal noch healen.
Ich hab ja nicht so viele
Lebenspunkte, das lässt sich ja relativ einfach heilen.
In due time.
Meinst du, das ist kein FTL?
Ja, ja, klar.
Das ist aber auch schon, das ist ja von 2012 oder so.
Das ist das mit dem Raumschiff, wo man
die unterschiedlichen
ähm, tja, so
Abteilungen vom Raumschiff managen muss.
Energie für Türme und
und so Zeug, ja.
Hab ich aber nie lang gespielt.
Ach, deswegen hab ich so ins Maul
auf die Fresse gekriegt gerade.
Die anderen haben alle noch ihren
Elektro Resi Buff.
Und ich hab nix.
Plus Level Abzug.
Naja, das ist natürlich, das ist natürlich nicht so geil.
Und warum sind denn die so langsam?
Die sind doch gar nicht überladen
oder so.
Oh!
Ach gut, es ist nur einer, der kann nix.
Schießen wir mal mit drauf, dass der auch
down geht.
Treffen alle nix.
Mammut.
Das Mammut macht das jetzt.
Aua!
Ey, die Dinger hauen halt echt rein, ne?
Einmal healen.
Nächsten.
Nicht Rage anmachen.
Nächsten Fight Rage anmachen.
Einmal heilen.
Heilen und
einmal AE Heal.
Schatztruhe, zack.
Oh, nice.
1 plus 3, Kriegshammer. Gut, dass
ich keinen Held hab, der das ausrüsten kann.
Ihr sind
100 pro noch mehr, ey.
Wow.
Direkt in mir drin.
Da kommen noch mehr.
Wir machen mal Bardsong an.
Ähm.
Bless vom Clary.
Und drauf
Newton.
Guck das.
Au.
Okay, ich bin down.
Pfadfinder.
Ja, fast.
Au.
Ja, das kann einem auf dem höheren Schwierigkeitsgrad halt mal ganz
gerne passieren, dass man
3 unglückliche Treffer auf den Held
kriegt und man ist down.
Aber, nachdem wir jetzt ja wissen, dass da Gegner
sind, machen
wir jetzt nochmal.
Buffen wir uns.
Machen wir nochmal Bardsong an.
Buffen wir uns weiter.
Und dann
versuchen wir mal
die Gegner zu blenden
und danach
casten wir noch Haste und bashen sie weg.
Versuchen wir den Gegner mal zu blenden.
Hier irgendwo war der, oder?
Oder auch nicht.
Ne.
Kein Gegner da.
Pech gehabt.
Da ist er doch. So.
Kleine Runde. Max, hau mal ab.
Max, geh weg.
Geh weg.
Lass dich nicht bashen. Alter.
So, Clary AE Heal.
Au.
Alter, lass mich in Ruhe, ey.
Der Clary.
Ah, du Scheiß. Okay, ich muss mit meinem
Held weg. Der kriegt übelst auf die Fresse.
Ich will, also
ich könnte einfach wieder Resi Buff,
Elektro Resi Buff machen,
allerdings geht's ja hier noch weiter.
Und nachdem man so schlecht campen kann,
und man muss campen,
dafür, dass man seine Spells wiederkriegt,
will ich mir
dann erstmal aufheben, falls wirklich noch was
Schwieriges kommt.
Okay, buffen wir uns nochmal.
Ach, Lindsay hat ihr Zeug schon an.
So, und jetzt bleibt mein Held mal hinten
und lässt die anderen das machen.
Generell, es bleibt der, der und der.
Die bleiben hinten.
Ne.
Du auch hinter.
Und Tristan auch hinter.
Jetzt kann da eigentlich nichts mehr passieren.
Wisst ihr?
Jetzt kriegen sie noch eine Runde Haste von mir.
Moment, Max,
was machst du wieder da vorne? Alter!
Geh weg!
Mit F, ich dachte, ihr habt mich hintergeschickt.
So, eine Runde Haste
und dann wird gebasht.
Ich bin auch echt, ich bin richtig bescheuert.
Warum habe ich meinen Helden nicht...
Ich dachte, ich habe den hintergeschickt.
Hä?
Richtig dämlich.
So, Max, hinter.
Gut.
Hinter, Haste.
Gut, wäschen.
Geht doch.
Wisst ihr, jetzt ist da überhaupt kein Ding mehr.
Jetzt kriegen sie auf den Sack.
Sven, für was hat man Tanks?
Wir müssen nicht tanken.
So, wisst ihr? Kaum macht man das richtig,
ist doch überhaupt kein Problem mehr.
Okay, hier geht's rauf.
Da liegt was.
Lore braucht das.
Oh, das gehört zur Quest.
Gut zu wissen.
Vielleicht ist hier noch was.
Sollen wir ein bisschen aufpassen.
Nichts mehr da.
Gut, gehen wir hier hoch.
Hexenmeister der Frontliner.
Da hat er eigentlich gar nichts zu suchen.
Weil laut Formation soll er hinten sein.
Und Valerie soll vor.
Irgendwie hat das das Ding...
Irgendwie hat es das ein bisschen umgestellt.
Der soll hinter, der soll hinter.
Die soll ein bisschen in die Mitte für Aura.
Der soll auch ein bisschen in die Mitte für Aura.
Du kannst im Prinzip eigentlich auch vor.
Da hältst du ja ein bisschen was aus.
Der Wolf soll auch vor.
Gar nicht, was das Game
mit meiner Formation angestellt hat.
Formation 0.
Ich würde mal sagen, das Game hat meine Formation 0.
Irgendwie ein bisschen kaputt gemacht, oder?
Ja.
Das ist auch eines der wenigen
Negativpunkte, wo ich sagen kann, die würde ich...
Autsch, Autsch, Autsch.
Die würde ich so unterschreiben bei dem Game.
Ähm...
Das hat ein paar Bugs.
Das ist okay.
Das lasse ich mir gefallen.
Aber ansonsten, was die Leute da so
schreiben, ist vollkommen bescheuert.
So.
Einmal Bar 4.
Barrage an.
Bardsong.
So. Max, du gehst jetzt mal ein bisschen hinter,
dass du nichts abkriegst.
Clary geht auch
ein bisschen hinter.
Wie viel Haste-Ladung haben wir noch?
Drei. Gucken wir, ob wir das
brauchen noch.
Fashion.
Oh, die kriegen aber echt
dicke auf den Sack gerade.
So, mein Clary
geht mal da rein und macht...
Es ruckelt! Warum ruckelt das?
Au!
Alter, die Dinger hauen aber auch rein.
Ich will bloß mein Elektro-Resi-Dings
noch nicht verschwenden.
Fuck, ich habe
Scheiße gespeichert.
Okay, da muss der Clary gleich rein und heilen.
Ja.
Max, mach doch mal Haste, komm.
Haste kann nicht schaden.
Alter, die kriegt aber auf den Sack, ey.
Heilen.
Heilen. Heilen.
Der war nicht in Range zum Heilen. Na, auch geil.
Mein Mammut macht das jetzt.
Mammut-Master-Rage.
Zack, jetzt...
Komm, der hält nicht mehr viel aus.
Der braucht ein paar Spells, dann ist er down.
Clary heilen.
Zack.
Gott sei Dank, er.
Zum Glück hat mein Clary
so viel Heal.
Ich bin froh, wenn ich dieses Negativ-Level weg habe.
Wir können noch einmal hier heilen.
Oh nein, die heilt halt nichts auf, die Tranks.
Okay, was gibt's denn hier oben?
Loot.
Sinnlose Schriftrollen.
Und irgendwelche Koch-Zutaten.
Okay.
Hier geht's wieder runter.
Gehen wir mal gucken, was hier in der Mitte gibt.
Treppe rauf.
Man muss halt sagen, das Spiel fühlt sich wirklich an,
wie, äh,
so die ganzen RPGs, so...
Wann kam Baldur's Gate raus?
2003,
oder irgendwie so?
Oder war das...
noch ein bisschen früher? Ich weiß gar nicht...
98, fuck!
Und das Zweier kam...
2000.
Boah, das ist doch schon so lang her, ja.
Hätt ich jetzt gar nicht gedacht.
So, hier oben geht's anscheinend nicht weiter.
Wirst doch.
Oh.
Eine Plattenrüstung plus 2, das ist nice, das ist besser als das, was ich habe.
Plattenrüstung plus 2, 35 hat sie jetzt und dann hat sie 36 Rüstungsklasse, das ist übelst gut.
Guck mal, da stellst du eine rum.
Wissencheck.
Erfolgreich.
In der Mitte des Raumes befindet sich ein geschlossenes Portal.
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Das hätte ich jetzt ohne einen Wissenscheck natürlich nicht erkannt.
Und ich glaube, ich muss mit dem Typ fighten.
Irgendwie, man muss mit fast allen NPCs kämpfen, die rumstehen, mit denen man Dialogoptionen hat.
Deswegen, wir verteilen schon mal unsere Pets und Tanks so, dass das was bringt.
Der Bade kann schon mal seinen Song anschmeißen.
Der Ranger geht ein Stückchen weg.
Ja, ich muss zu dem Typ hin, weil ich mit ihm reden muss, was für meinen Held nicht gerade gut ist.
Und der Clarence...
Der Clarence macht schon mal einen Buff an.
Okay.
Gut.
Speichern mal.
Und dann reden wir mit dem Typ.
Bla bla bla bla bla.
Wer seid ihr?
Ja.
Wann auch immer.
Ich bin nicht so scharf drauf, das jetzt vorzulesen, weil eigentlich wollte ich ja so weiterspielen, wie ich eh schon den ganzen Tag gespielt habe.
Nämlich, ihr wisst ja, ich spiele solche Games.
Äh, totaler Roleplay-Fan bin, ja.
Ich spiele solche, also, Roleplaying-Games-Fan bin.
Ich spiele sowas immer ohne großartige Geschichte zu lesen.
Das ist, das ist cringe, da hast du recht, Patrick.
Ich, ich mag das auch nicht.
Ich, ich, ich klicke immer so ungefähr durch.
Bla bla bla.
Äh, verzaubertes Heiligtum, jawoll.
Aha, da steht jetzt Ironie davor für die Leute, die sich checken, oder?
Ähm...
Das heißt, diese...
Oh, sorry, oh, sorry.
Irrlichter, was machen die Irrlichter hier?
Bla bla bla, uninteressant.
Das heißt, dieser Ort sei verflucht.
Hm, woran könnte das wohl liegen?
Inschriften...
Ich hab genug Erb...
Ähm...
Na, wir bringen ihn mal nicht gleich um.
Ich meine, er hat ja noch nichts gemacht.
Wo sind die anderen, die hierher kamen?
Aha, alle weg.
Ihr seid nicht bei klarem Verstand, ja, das würde ich auch so sehen.
Oh, dafür gab's sogar XP.
War anscheinend die richtige Antwort.
Eigentlich, es gab XP für, weil ich einen, äh, Religionswissen-Wurf erfolgreich absolviert habe.
Ihr solltet euch reden hören, bla.
Ich hab auf der Insel eine Leiche gefunden.
Ja.
Solltet euch mal selbst hören.
Okay, es gibt XP, XP ist nice.
XP, sag ich nichts dagegen.
Ich werde euch im Kampf gegen das Monster beistehen.
Welches Monster?
Text lesen, FTW.
Egal.
Ich bin, ich, also ich bin, gesinnungsmäßig bin ich ja, äh, gut.
Das heißt natürlich werde ich eben im Kampf gegen das Monster beistehen.
Wir wissen nichts über die Kreatur, die uns auf der...
Gebt mir Zeit, mich...
Ach, Quatsch.
Vorzubereiten.
Wer muss ich vorbereiten?
Das ist ja komplett overrated.
Bashen müssen wir.
So, siehste?
Gut, dass wir pre-buffed haben.
Dann ist das, hoffe ich mal.
Ja.
Kann man speichern?
Nein, kann man nicht.
Dann ist das hoffentlich kein Problem.
Ähm...
So ein Special-Ear-Licht oder sowas.
Man sieht ja nicht viel, weil da mein Mammut den Kopf davor hat.
Also wir greifen nicht das Gehirn von meinem Mammut an, auch wenn es so aussieht.
Äh, das ist ein Gegner.
Ähm.
Der kann sich mal buffen mit...
Quatsch.
Der muss sich nicht buffen.
Mein Held muss auf jeden Fall sich mal hier verpissen.
So viel ist sicher.
Siehste?
Au!
Das ist der Wahnsinn, ey.
Die, die, die, die fokussen alle voll mein Held.
Was soll das?
Die sollen nicht mein Held fokussen, weil...
Dann ist das Spiel vorbei.
Wenn mein Held was abkriegt.
So, Clary heilt.
Guck mal hier, was der für ein Damage macht auf mich.
Zum Glück habe ich ganz gute Resis.
Was der für ein Damage auf meinen Held macht.
Oh, ist er down?
Ich glaube, er ist down.
Haha, er ist down.
Jawoll.
Gibt's in dem Game Lootboxen?
Ja.
Es gibt Lootboxen.
Ganz viele, über die ganze Spielwelt verteilt.
Aber keine Echtgeld-Lootboxen.
So, wir haben ihn gebasht.
Was hat er denn dabei gehabt?
Flöte des Zypressen.
Der Zypressenkönigin.
Ah ja.
Ein Experte für Antiquitäten-Fände ist sicher interessant.
625 Gold.
Nice.
Nehmen wir mit.
So, was machen wir mit dem Dude hier jetzt?
Erstmal voll heilen.
So, safe.
Was können wir mit dem Typ jetzt machen hier?
Seid ihr sicher, dass ihr auf der Insel bleiben wollt?
Ähm, ja.
Bla bla bla.
Könnt ihr dieses Portal verschließen?
Nein, kann er nicht.
Wär ja auch was.
Ähm, die Einheimischen, überhaupt die Insel, seid verflucht.
Ja, das würde ich jetzt auch so sehen.
Ihr seid eine Gefahr für euch selbst, andere.
Ich sollte euch lieber töten.
Macht, was ihr wollt.
Ich weiß nicht.
Also eigentlich gibt es ja keinen Grund, ihn jetzt irgendwie zu killen, ne?
Er hat uns ja sogar jetzt gerade geholfen im Kampf gegen dieses Viech.
Also.
Allerdings, wenn wir ihn killen, dann können wir ihn looten.
Was wollen wir machen?
Wollen wir ihn killen oder wollen wir ihn leben lassen?
Der hat bestimmt kein gescheites Loot dabei.
Der hat bestimmt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, ähm, irgendwie Gürtel plus eins oder irgendwie sowas, was ich, was, was eh schon, was jeder Held von mir anhat.
Macht, was ihr wollt, ich lebe vor.
Was für eine Gesinnung ich spiele, ich bin neutral gut.
Also eigentlich kann ich ihn nicht killen, einfach so.
Wenn es danach geht.
Aber, das ist ja, weil das Game teilweise merkwürdige Dialogoptionen hat, ist das keine Gesinnungsantwort.
Also das zählt nicht.
Auch wenn es bescheuert ist.
Also, eigentlich müsste das hier eine Gesinnungsantwort sein, dass ich halt, äh, über eine Gesinnung verrutscht oder so.
Aber ist es nicht.
Aber ich, ich bringe ihn nicht um.
Warum auch, ne?
Ich könnte ihn immer noch killen, okay.
Ich will ihn aber nicht killen.
Gehen wir mal gucken, was gibt's denn hier sonst noch so?
Gehen wir außen lang.
Da ist ein bisschen mehr Platz, da kann man Held auch weiter hinten stelzen.
Ja, Held soll weg.
Weiter weg.
Okay, war's gut.
Moment, mein Held soll weg und er rennt als erstes.
Au, au.
Wie viele sind denn von dem Kram noch hier?
Das ist ja schlimm.
Haste.
Haste, Bardsong.
Äh, haben wir noch?
Wir müssten doch eigentlich noch nen.
Haben wir noch hier?
Gebet, Action.
So.
Ähm.
Clary darf einfach heilen.
Und er darf Haste casten.
Falls er es nicht schon gemacht hat.
Haste.
Jawoll.
Und jetzt hier weghauen.
Oh, da sind vier Stück.
Was ist das?
Alter, was geht mit dem Wolf ab?
Der macht den 360-Kreisel-Copter.
Okay, mein Ranger macht das, was er kann.
Bogenschießen gut ist.
Der könnte einmal...
Der Clary macht noch einen Buff.
Und ich caste einfach mit drauf.
Und dann ist gut.
So.
So, mach mal Ae Healen.
Ja, das war jetzt nicht so schwierig.
Wissen Check.
Diese Checks sind ganz praktisch, wenn man die macht nicht unbedingt, weil man jetzt
hier die tolle Lore lesen will, sondern einfach, weil es XP gibt.
Danach müssen wir unbedingt in die Hauptstadt.
Ähm.
Wir haben da noch einmal.
Haben wir gar nicht benutzt.
Schutz vor Elektrizität.
Zack.
Schick.
Jetzt können sie nichts mehr.
Jetzt werden sie geschreckt.
Guck mal, ich muss gar nichts machen.
Hände von der Tastatur weg.
Mit Elektroresi haben die überhaupt keine Chance.
Vielleicht sollte ich einfach, wenn die Map noch groß ist hier.
Ich glaube es ja nicht, dass die Map noch so groß ist.
Aber vielleicht sollte ich einfach mehr noch einen dritten Elektroresi-Spell ausrüsten.
Weil dann können die Dinger überhaupt nichts mehr machen.
Essbares Moos.
Da freue ich mich auch schon den ganzen Tag drauf.
Schön veganes Moos.
Das wäre bestimmt auch was für Unge.
Oh weine, das war ja Milch.
Ich habe es ja ganz vergessen.
Schwerer Schild, was haben wir denn hier?
Zwergenschild der Ahnen.
Schwerer Schild plus zwei Gewerksamen-Träger.
Also für einen Clary mit...
Also nicht für ihn als Clary, sondern für den Zwergen-Clary, den ich noch habe.
Das ist ein ziemlich...
Das ist ein ziemlich gutes Schild.
Haben wir hier noch was?
Oh, nice. Loot.
Was ich übrigens toll finde in dem Game, kann auch ein Mammut looten.
Guck, ich zeige es euch mal.
Also wer schon immer mal sehen wollte, wie das aussieht, wenn ein Mammut lootet.
So sieht das aus.
Guck, Mammut lootet jetzt.
Bestes Mammut, feines Mammut.
Ein nices Mammut.
Mammut, oder?
Was sagt ihr?
Das ist schon ein sehr nices Mammut, finde ich.
Ich glaube, die Map ist zu Ende an der Stelle hier.
Aber ihr habt jetzt ja die Map gesehen von der Größe her.
Ungefähr so groß sind alle Maps.
Also alle Gebiete, wo man rein kann.
Es gibt auch welche, die sind kleiner.
Es gibt welche, die sind eine ganze Ecke größer.
Aber im Durchschnitt würde ich sagen, sind die Gebiete ungefähr so groß hier.
Kann man hier hoch?
Ne, da ist nichts mehr.
Und ihr habt die Weltkarte gesehen.
Also man hat extrem viel zu tun.
Man sollte dem neuesten Mammut ein Leckerli geben.
So wie essbares Moos.
Das ist natürlich auch die allseits bekannte natürliche Ernährung von Mammuts.
Was jetzt tatsächlich so war.
Ich weiß halt nicht, ob die Moos gefressen haben.
Aber die haben...
Ja, was weiß ich, Steinzeitmoos oder so.
Ah, Moment.
Das ist die Stelle, wo ich vorher drüber springen konnte, ne?
Ah, wenn ich...
Okay, also wenn ich hier drüber gesprungen wäre, wäre ich hier rausgekommen.
Das heißt, dann probieren wir jetzt mal auf dem Rückweg rüber zu springen.
Hat funktioniert.
Nice.
Und gibt Exp.
Dann müssen wir den anderen auch noch ausprobieren.
Ne, es geht nur einmal.
Nice.
So, Quest finished.
Was wir leider nicht geschafft haben, ist...
Das verschwundene Kind zu finden hier.
Das ist blöd.
So, nachdem wir jetzt eh rasten, können wir mal den restlichen Haste...
Hallo?
Bleibst du hier?
Können wir mal den restlichen Haste-Zauber noch verschwenden.
Dass wir schneller zurückkommen zum Anlegepunkt.
Mammuts haben bis vor 12.000 Jahren in Sibirien gelebt.
Ist das so?
Mein Chat ist so intelligent.
Es ist einfach...
Umwerfend.
Das ist komplett hier...
Big, big brain.
Alter.
Was ist denn mit der los?
Oh, gehen.
Quest fertig.
Next.
Ich bin noch in Akt 2.
Das liegt einfach daran, weil ich die Main-Quest noch nicht weitergemacht habe, sondern erst mal Map erkundet habe.
Und ich habe es euch ja gerade gezeigt.
Die Map ist riesengroß, wie man hier sieht.
Und...
Ich glaube, die Main-Quest geht...
...weiter, wenn man das hier macht.
Eine verdiente Belohnung.
Das sieht für mich so Haupt-Quest aus, weil das gab es bei der Main-Quest einfach.
Deswegen denke ich, dass es halt da weitergeht.
So.
Wir müssen jetzt mal schnell zurück in die Hauptstadt, weil ich muss mein Level heilen.
So, wenn wir in der Hauptstadt waren, dann kann ich euch mal gleich diesen...
Nennen wir es mal Wirtschaftspart des Games zeigen.
Und dann gehen wir in die Hütte der Sumpfhexe und gucken uns das Echsenmenschen-Dorf...
...und dann gucken wir, ob wir irgendwie den Junge finden, der von daheim weggerannt ist.
So, wir gehen natürlich in den Thronsaal, weil woanders können wir nichts machen in der Stadt.
Und gucken mal, was es Neues gibt.
Baron Max muss ja auch mal seine Aufgaben erledigen.
Na, so ein Baron, der muss schade schon was zu tun.
Vor allem untergeben rumkommandieren, das ist ganz wichtig.
So.
Und natürlich sitzt auch mein Mammut.
Auf dem Thron.
Geh weg.
Mein Mammut macht das jetzt.
Mein Mammut wird jetzt das Königreich für mich verwalten.
Weil, das ist absolut ein Big Brain Mammut, haben wir ja gesehen.
Mit zwei Int kann da nichts schief gehen.
Okay, Projekte.
Was ist fertig?
Ist irgendwas fertig?
Straße, Ende der Neuen Tagen.
Ah ja, also, so mal zur Erklärung.
Das ist jetzt so dieser Wirtschaftspart von dem Game.
Es gibt halt irgendwelche auf.
Man hat hier, man hat Ratgeber.
Den kann man auf verschiedene Positionen zuweisen, was weiß er, er ist mal ein General für Militär und sonst was und man kann auch mehrere Ratgeber freischalten und ab und zu kommen halt irgendwelche Ereignisse, wie Spinnen, Plagen und sonst was, die kann ich dann zuordnen, einer der Berater, der das erledigen soll und dann klappt es oder klappt es nicht und da kann ich halt noch weiter mein Königreich ausbauen.
Neue Städte gründen.
Da habe ich meine Hauptstadt hier.
Oben habe ich irgendwie noch ein paar Ressourcen erobert.
Dann habe ich hier noch eine andere Stadt gegründet.
Also, es ist ganz gut gemacht.
Das ist jetzt kein SimCity oder so.
Das ist so für nebenbei, wenn man keinen Bock mehr hat auf Monster klatschen, dann macht man das mal halt ein bisschen.
So, was gibt es denn hier Neues?
Du machst das jetzt.
Kostet 100 Punkte.
Haben wir auch Lösungsdauer.
60 Tage, das dauert ja ewig.
Moment, diese Quest haben wir gerade gelöst, ne?
Vielleicht kann ich die Quest mit dem Jungen ja auch nur lösen.
Wenn ich hier den Kram erforschen lasse.
Da müssen wir mal gucken.
Okay, Handel kann ich mir nicht leisten.
Kostet 1500 Punkte und ich habe bloß 187.
Das ist nix.
Moins, relax.
Also, das taugt nix.
Ähm, forschen.
Ich will halt den Berater nicht ungenutzt lassen.
Das kostet aber auch so viel.
Komm, dann darf der, dann darf der jetzt hier einfach mal dran forschen.
Dann darf der.
Dann darf der jetzt hier einfach mal dran forschen.
Und gut ist, wo war es denn jetzt überhaupt?
Wo ist es denn jetzt?
Sehe ich es jetzt nicht?
Forschen.
Ach hier.
Forsche mal, Kollege.
Und ich hau wieder ab.
Und mach meine Quest weiter.
Weil ich will mich nicht zu sehr um meinen Königreich da wirtschaftssimulationsmäßig kümmern.
Ich will eher Monster, Monster wollen gebasht werden.
Ähm.
Und was ich nicht vergessen darf, ich muss meine, meinen Negativ-Level heilen.
Was muss man bei dem Spiel machen?
Hast du mal Baldur's Gate, Icewind Dale oder, oder äh, äh, Divinity Original Sin gespielt?
Dann muss man hier das gleiche machen.
Monster killen, Quests erledigen und wahrscheinlich, ich, ich weiß noch nicht genau, wohin die Hauptstory geht.
Werden wir gleich noch sehen.
Ähm.
Tja.
Welt retten wahrscheinlich.
Was, Evoli, Evoli, ernsthaft?
Ernsthaft?
Das glaube ich dir nicht.
Du, Evoli, du debatest mich jetzt gerade.
Wo ist denn der Clary, der die Scrolls verkauft hier?
Was?
Trihacks wurde gebannt von Twitch?
Trihacks, das ist der, ernsthaft, warte mal, das glaube ich nicht, das muss ich jetzt nachgucken.
Das ist so eines der Ur-Twitch-Typen schlechthin.
Der wurde wirklich gebannt?
The fuck?
What?
Was?
Warum?
Warte mal, Evoli hat einen Link geschickt.
Trihacks banned on Twitch?
The fuck?
Das ist doch nicht in den Ernst, oder?
Warum?
Was, wie, äh, hä?
Was hat er denn gemacht?
Weil der Fuck gesagt hat?
Hä?
Okay, keine Ahnung, was, was mit Twitch wieder los ist.
Ich weiß nicht.
Aber ich meine, ist das wieder etwas, wo irgendein Bot bannt und kein Mensch draufguckt oder was?
Ich gucke relativ oft die Streams von Trihacks und da ist ja nichts irgendwie anstößig oder ...
Also, hä?
So ...
Schrift, Rolle, Genesung, das brauchen wir.
Da kaufen wir auch gleich mal.
Wie viel kostet ein Kram?
840.
Da kaufen wir mal zwei Stück.
Komm.
Okay, nice.
Mal gucken, ob ich mich selbst heilen darf oder ob das mein Clary machen muss.
Vielleicht darf ich mich auch selbst heilen.
Ach, die macht das für mich. Easy.
Perfekt.
Kommt das Spiel an die Winde, die drei? Ich finde schon.
Es ist halt, es ist vom Kampfsystem her und auch von der Geschwindigkeit her, es ist schon anders.
Man kann das nicht so richtig, so richtig vergleichen.
Es ist beides relativ so klassische RPG-Kost, ja.
Aber das hier kommt deutlich mehr nach halt der Pen & Paper Vorlage.
Wieso hast du einen Mammut?
Weil, weil ich das geskillt habe.
Deswegen habe ich einen Mammut.
Ich bin nämlich ein Schützer, nein, Waldhexenmeister bin ich nämlich.
Und als Waldhexenmeister kriegt man auf Stufe 1 ein Animal Companion.
Und da habe ich den, da habe ich hier Mammut.
Nein, es ist kein Mammut, es ist ein Mastodon.
Da, da muss man schon korrekt sein.
So, wir sind eigentlich fertig, ne, wir können, wir können raus.
Stufe geheilt, Stufe geheilt runter und weiter Quest.
Aber das kann ich mir echt nicht vorstellen.
Also das ist, äh, echt, also Tri-Hacks zu bannen ist, hä?
Das ist so wie wenn du Dance-Gaming bannen würdest.
Das ist quasi somit einer der freundlichsten, allgemein verträglichsten Streams ever.
Bei ihm haben sie ja auch mal wegen einem Emote damals rumgeschrien,
dass er angeblich irgendwie, oh, was haben sie bei ihm erzählt, dass er irgendwie Anti...
An...
Ach, was, ich weiß es gar nicht mehr.
Dass er irgendwie gegen Schwule ist oder so.
Ach, keine Ahnung, ne, weil er einen Emote hatte.
Die Leute, sie übertreiben es heute.
Heute ist es wirklich, heutzutage, bei, an jedem Scheiß ist irgendeiner offendet und stört sich.
Und anstatt, dass man sich dann irgendwann wieder beruhigt,
äh, schreien dann gleich noch 5000 andere mit.
Da werden aus, wirklich aus so vielen Mütten,
aus vielen Elefanten gemacht, heutzutage.
Das ist für mich nicht wirklich nachvollziehbar.
Habt ihr das mitgekriegt, wo wir gerade beim Thema sind?
So, wir gehen jetzt, ähm, runter hier zur Hütte der Sumpfhexe und gucken mal, was da ist.
Weil, warum ist, warum es, warum es da jetzt neue Ereignisse gibt?
Habt ihr das in Russland mitgekriegt?
Mit der einen Feministin, die durch die U-Bahn gegangen ist?
Und die Leute mit Zeug angesprüht hat?
Angeschüttet hat?
Oh, stopp.
Resting would be nice.
Don't you think?
Resting. Resting ist für Noobs.
Kann ich das nicht claimen?
Achso, das befindet sich nicht auf meinem Land.
Das ist natürlich, das ist...
Das erklärt's, ja.
Habt ihr das mitgekriegt?
Ja, komm.
Is gut. Wir rasten.
Habt ihr das mitgekriegt mit der in der U-Bahn?
Auch wieder richtig, richtig hängen geblieben.
Essen verkackt.
Brauchen wir eh nicht. Das, hier gibt's kaum random Encounter.
Und wenn, sind sie einfach.
Naja, also...
Ne, Leute angesprüht, das hab ich falsch ausgedrückt.
Die ist... Ne, gibt's auch auf YouTube, das Video.
Das ist irgendeine russische Feministin gewesen.
Die ist quasi wegen...
Die ist durch die U-Bahn gelaufen, weil ja Männer in der U-Bahn quasi immer mit breiten Beinen da sitzen.
Nicht etwa, weil das...
Ich mein, manche übertreiben's, ja, keine Frage, aber...
Ähm...
Feministen sind ja der Ansicht, Männer sitzen nicht aus anatomischen Gründen mit bisschen breiteren Beinen da,
sondern um quasi männliche Dominanz über die Frau auszustrahlen.
Das nennt sich dann Manspreading.
Dass es dafür schon wieder Worte gibt, das tut...
Das tut allein schon beim Aussprechen wieder weh, ja.
Und deswegen ist sie durch die U-Bahn gelaufen und hat sich gedacht, sie muss jetzt mal...
Oh, der war vorher nicht da.
Sie muss jetzt den Männern mal eine Lektion erteilen,
dass das ja so nicht geht, da überall in der U-Bahn zu Manspreaden.
Dass gerade das geht, das ist ja nicht drin, ne?
Und da hat sie sich irgendwie ein Gemisch in so eine Flasche gefüllt aus...
Ich...
Ich weiß nicht, irgendwas Ätzendes.
Irgendwas Ätzendes hat sie in die Flasche gefüllt, ja?
Jetzt...
Ich...
Also...
Ich weiß nicht, ob's Säure war oder so, irgendwas.
Und da ist sie dann wirklich durch die U-Bahn gelaufen und hat Männern diese Flüssigkeit in den Schritt gekippt.
Und hat Männern diese Flüssigkeit in den Schritt gekippt.
Muss ich mir mal vorstellen.
Und die ist auch noch der Meinung, sie ist absolut im Recht, weil die Männer ja Manspreadet haben.
Also, sie hat da auch anscheinend keine irgendwie jetzt Schuldgefühle oder Unrechtbewusstsein oder so.
Sie ist der Meinung, das gehört denen ja auch nicht besser, wenn sie Manspreaden in der U-Bahn.
Muss ich mir vorstellen.
So weit sind wir im Jahr 2018.
So weit sind wir im Jahr 2018, ja?
Alter...
Was mich wundert ist, dass da keiner eine reingehauen hat.
Weil wenn ich mir anguck, was für Leute bei uns in der U-Bahn sitzen, die sich wegen jedem Scheiß ab und zu mal kloppen, dass da nichts passiert ist, wundert mich echt.
die sich wegen jedem Scheiß ab und zu mal kloppen,
dass da nichts passiert ist,
wundert mich echt.
Ja, es ist einfach hängen geblieben.
Ja, und die fühlt sich halt auch absolut im Recht.
Ich hoffe, die wird jetzt mal zumindest ein bisschen zur...
Ich weiß nicht, was einem da passieren kann,
wenn man sowas macht in Russland, keine Ahnung.
Oder auch hier.
Mann.
Es ist halt schon mal die Frage.
Zumindest mal versuchte Körperverletzung vielleicht oder so.
Aber, das ist jetzt bescheuert, ne?
Aber soweit sind wir schon.
Banditen.
Banditen wollen gebasht werden.
Banditen schüchtern wir nicht ein
und schicken sie weg,
sondern wir bashen die.
Ja.
Die können nix.
Düdü.
Alter.
Guckt euch das mal an.
So 0815 Banditen, wie schnell die umkippen
im Vergleich zu den...
zu den Ehrlich dann auf der Insel.
Die werden ja geshrackt hier.
Ich seh was dabei.
Ja.
Hier unten was dabei.
Bogen 100 Gold.
Armbrust zackt.
Sonst was.
Bogen 50 Gold.
Brauchen wir alles nicht.
Safe.
Ja.
Aber, echt.
Da hab ich auch wieder gedacht,
was ist denn mit der Welt los heutzutage wieder?
Ich mein, man kann's echt übertreiben.
Man kann's wirklich komplett übertreiben.
Und sowas führt ja auch nicht dazu,
dass jetzt irgendwie...
Weiß nicht, die Leute sagen so,
oh ja, hm,
jetzt hab ich den Fehler ja eingesehen.
Ich sollte anders in der U-Bahn da sitzen oder so.
Ähm, das führt eigentlich zu noch mehr
Köpfe einschlagen gegenseitig.
Vinzys Quest will Bücher drucken.
Und irgendwie ist das Zeug für
zum Bücher drucken da in dem Wagen anscheinend.
Was wollt ihr drucken?
Äh, was Schönes drucken.
Genau.
Was Schönes drucken.
Ja, sehr gut.
Next.
All according to...
Wenn wir gerade hier sind,
ich erinnere mich nämlich,
dass hier oben auf der Map
das letzte Mal, wo ich hier war,
waren übel schwere Gegner.
Und mal gucken, ob wir die jetzt schaffen.
Schreckt hab ich schon lange nicht...
Ich sag das eigentlich ganz gerne.
Gerade, weil's irgendwie keiner mehr sagt.
Das ist genauso wie Owned.
Owned sagt auch kaum noch einer was.
Heute sagen's alle Rekt.
Dabei war früher Owned oder Pwned
oder sonst was viel, ähm...
alltäglicher, viel normaler, ja.
Heute sagt das keiner mehr.
Ist komplett oldschool.
Ja.
Was du heute noch sagst.
Wer sagt heute noch Owned, ja?
Ja, außer die Robbe.
Die Robbe sagt das immer noch.
So.
Die Dinger sehen zwar nicht so aus,
allerdings ist der mächtige, wütende Eulenbär,
der auch tatsächlich so aussieht,
ähm,
übelst starker Gegner, ey.
Der hat mich das letzte Mal two-shotted.
Okay, mal gucken, mal gucken,
ob wir die jetzt,
ob wir das jetzt packen.
Ich speicher mal.
Aber ich war das letzte Mal hier mit Level...
Sechs oder so
und ich wurde komplett zerstört.
Das heißt, ich könnte mir vorstellen,
diesen Dinger sind das auch noch ein bisschen zu schwer.
Man, man weiß ja nicht.
Haste.
Gucken wir mal.
Ähm.
Tristan darf mal einen...
Feuerball drauf ballern.
Und ich schieß mal...
Magic Missiles drauf.
Und Lindsay kann mal versuchen,
irgendwie was einzuschläfern, oder so.
Da.
Fuck, es hat nicht...
Oh, die nehmen überhaupt kein Damage.
Alter.
Okay, das wird ein Vibe.
Das wird ein Vibe.
Ich sag's euch.
Alter.
Okay.
Alter, die owen mich komplett.
Die owen mich komplett, die Bären, ey.
Alter.
Hohohoho.
Fuck.
Okay.
Ich glaube, hier muss ich trotzdem später nochmal...
Ja, komm.
Hey, wie geht's eigentlich dem Kabunen?
Was treibt der eigentlich so?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Hab ich schon eine Weile nichts mehr gehört.
Kann ich dir nicht sagen.
Ähm.
Gut.
Was geht...
Was geht eigentlich mit dem Hase ab?
Ist das, äh...
Zweiköpfiger Hase hier?
Ich finde, er ist ein geklitschter Hase.
Oder wie sagt Aporet immer?
Ein kritischer Hase ist das hier.
Gibt's den eigentlich noch?
Ich weiß nicht.
Ewig nichts mehr empfohlen bekommen auf YouTube.
Interessiert mich aber auch nicht.
Ehrlich gesagt so.
Ich bin dein Schild.
So, wie könnten...
Gibt's irgendwie eine Taktik, wie wir die hier angehen könnten?
Ich mein...
So wie ich das hier sehe, sind hier Büsche.
Das heißt, hier kommt eigentlich nichts ran.
Das heißt, ich stell mal meine Helden alle auf Hold Position.
Dann wird gebufft.
Dann haut Amiri ab.
Und Valerie bleibt vorne.
weil er die mir aushält.
Defensivhaltung.
Okay.
Dann buffen wir uns nochmal.
Mal gucken.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das funktioniert.
Barbrage.
Buffen.
Einfach alles buffen.
Alles buffen.
Okay, habe ich noch irgendwas zum buffen?
Erstmal nicht.
Ähm.
Okay.
Tristan, Damage machen.
Hoffentlich, hoffentlich macht das ordentlich
Damage.
Oh, das macht überhaupt keinen Schaden.
Fuck.
Ah, wir hätten auch die Waffe buffen können von Valerie.
Machen wir jetzt noch.
Ähm.
Ja, also wir casten jetzt einfach Magic Missiles drauf,
bis es kaputt geht.
Was?
Amiri, hau ab!
Alter, was machst du da vorne?
Ich habe dich auf Hold Position gestellt.
WTF?
Soll das?
Ja.
Oh.
Haben wir irgendwas, wenn wir dem Ding noch Damage machen können?
Hier, zack.
Zack, da drauf.
Ich glaube aber, das wird nichts.
Die Dinger dürften auch ein bisschen zu stark sein.
Wir könnten die nochmal versuchen zu planten mit Lindsay.
Alter.
Die Dinger machen zu viel Damage.
Das wird nichts.
Ja, wobei, also mit ein bisschen Glück könnte das tatsächlich was werden.
Oh, ist er down?
Nein, fuck.
Ich kann jetzt aber erst sagen, die Kampfmusik ist irgendwie weg, ne?
Die hat keinen Bock mehr.
Overrated, she baited.
Ähm, Valerie könnten wir mal heilen lassen.
Könnten auch mal Feuer Damage drauf machen, klar.
Okay.
Go.
I can't keep this up.
Alter, die machen Damage, diese Kackbären, ey.
Fuck.
Okay, Valerie ist so gut wie down, ey.
Wenn die jetzt noch einmal Damage kriegt, dann ist es vorbei, ey.
Ja, super.
Jetzt ist sie tot.
Okay, die Dinger sind noch ein bisschen...
Alter, wie die Dinger meine Tanks zerlegen.
Das ist ja nicht normal.
Aber, also man könnte es schaffen.
Also von der Taktik her ist es, glaube ich, gar nicht so schlecht.
Ich glaube, wir haben fast...
Komm, einmal probieren wir es noch.
Von der Taktik her war das gar nicht so blöd.
Das Problem war, dass Amiri wieder losgelaufen ist und keinen Bock hatte, hinten zu bleiben.
Leider, ja, den gibt es noch.
Okay, jetzt hätte ich mich auch gewundert, wenn es den nicht mehr gäbe.
Schon mal vier Account-Namen geändert.
Tja.
Gibt ein paar.
Gibt ein paar, die in...
Also habe ich schon öfters in Kommentaren gelesen, die so nach dem Motto dann schreiben,
Max, kennst du noch XY und sonst was?
Das war mein Account von 2011.
Okay, hold position.
Hold position.
Eigentlich ist es so nicht schlecht.
Defensive fight.
Open to your orders.
Okay, wir buffen jetzt noch.
Wir probieren es jetzt noch einmal aus.
Und wenn es nicht funktioniert, dann lassen wir es.
Ähm, haben wir noch irgendwas zu buffen?
Ja, Valerie kriegt noch Rüstungs-Buff.
Ähm, dann haben wir noch irgendwas.
Ja, Valerie, kommen wir noch mehr Rüstungs-Buff?
Äh, Blessing-Buff?
Alles, alles wird alles gebufft jetzt.
Alles, was geht.
Okay, das war es.
Mehr geht, glaube ich, echt nicht.
Und Max sollte mal da vorne weg.
Gibt es jetzt noch Haste?
Fertig.
Und jetzt wird gepullt.
Gepullt mit Magic Missile
und mit Fireball
und mit Bogen.
Wir könnten Valerie noch mal hier...
Max, du sollst stehen bleiben.
Stehen bleiben und casten.
Und nicht so komisch rumrennen hier.
Ähm, das da machen wir jetzt.
Das machen wir jetzt noch.
Du sollst da drauf schießen.
Und du sollst hier nochmal ein Fireball drauf schießen.
Wunderbar.
Und jetzt hoffen wir, dass das irgendwie klappt.
Ah, vielleicht, warte mal.
Vielleicht kann Lindsay noch das Mammut heilen.
Oh nein, das Mammut ist down.
Fuck.
Die Dinger machen zu viel Damage.
Das geht nicht.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Hier nochmal Damage.
Aber Lindsay könnte den...
Okay, Lindsay könnte den Wolf heilen.
Lindsay, heil mal den Wolf.
Lindsay, scheiß auf den Wolf.
Mach...
Heil mal Valerie.
Haben wir noch irgendwas?
Die Kampfmusik haut immer ab.
Warum?
Okay, der Clary heilt.
Das ist schon mal sehr, sehr nice.
Der erste Bär ist down.
Sehr schön.
Erster Bär ist down.
Nächster da drauf.
Lindsay darf jetzt...
Kann ja eh nix casten.
Kann weiter angreifen.
Der greift den auch an.
Valerie bleibt hier stehen und haut zurück.
Amiri macht nix, weil die stirbt sonst instant.
Die hat viel zu wenig Leben.
Der Wolf könnte da drauf.
Guck mal, der Kreiselbär ist am Start.
Nice, nice, nice.
Das könnte echt was werden.
Oh nee.
Ah, Amiri.
Amiri.
Geh weg.
Piss dich, Alter.
Guck mal hier.
Ein Treffer, fast down.
Die hat überhaupt keine Ausdauer.
Nein, nein, Amiri.
Du sollst hinten bleiben.
Okay, das wird was.
Das wird was.
Call Peter, ja.
Nice.
Gebäscht.
Rekt.
Siehste, Leute.
Mit der ordentlichen Taktik und den ordentlichen Buffs funktioniert das alles.
Und die Gegner haben jetzt wirklich reingehauen, wie sonst was.
Hatte ich nicht noch kritische Wunden heilen?
Mal so.
Hatte ich.
Warum habe ich das nicht auf der Leiste?
Kack-Noob.
Sehr schön.
So.
Heute.
Oh, jetzt müssen wir wirklich Peter anrufen.
Mammut-Ripp.
Wolf hat's überlebt.
Und der Hase hat sich entbackt.
Das ist doch schön.
All according to plan.
Oh.
Nichts Gescheites.
Der Mammut ist tot, weil ich ihm das essbare Moos gegeben habe, ja.
Ein Duellschwert.
Ich habe keinen, der das tragen kann.
Auch toll.
Ein plus zwei.
Behändiges Duellschwert plus zwei.
Ich habe keinen Charakter, der das gebrauchen kann.
Aber die Bären haben, glaube ich mal, ziemlich ordentlich XP gegeben, oder?
Ja, 240 ist sehr, sehr ordentlich.
Ja.
Das ist sehr ordentlich.
So, jetzt haben wir hier alles gemacht.
Jetzt können wir wieder zurück.
Und damit wir schneller zurück sind, werde ich mal wieder einen Haze-Ball raushauen.
Codestream, wenn es rauskommt.
Weil ich echt noch am überlegen bin, wegen Black Ops 4, ob ich es hole.
Weil prinzipiell finde ich Black Ops nicht schön.
Schlecht.
Ich habe aber so meine Bedenken, wie gut das auf dem PC sein wird.
Gar nicht mal so sehr, dass es nicht läuft oder so.
Ich meine, also man muss ja sagen, zu Black Ops sah auf dem PC für ein Game in 2018 ziemlich kacke aus.
Das muss man einfach jetzt mal sehen und auch irgendwie akzeptieren.
Die Optik alleine macht es zwar nicht aus.
Wenn es dann wenigstens mit 300 FPS läuft, wie Overwatch, okay.
Ähm.
Aber ich bin generell skeptisch, wie das läuft auf dem PC mit Cod.
Weil, ähm, die sind ja bekannt dafür, dass, ähm, sie ihre Games keinen sonderlich guten Anti-Cheat einbauen auf dem PC.
Ich weiß noch, wie sie sich damals darüber beschwert haben, dass sie, ähm, ja keinen Anti-Cheat machen können.
Das war zu, zu MW3 oder so.
Da haben sie sich darüber beschwert, wir können ja gar keinen Anti-Cheat machen.
Weil Steam unterstützt ja bloß, ähm, 32-Bit-Anti-Cheat.
Und.
Wir sind so modern und unser Game ist viel besser.
Und deswegen bräuchten wir einen 64-Bit-Anti-Cheat.
Und deswegen können wir leider keinen Anti-Cheat machen.
Das ist eine bescheuerte Ausrede, ja.
Ähm.
Und deswegen weiß ich nicht, wie gut das laufen wird auf dem PC, ehrlich gesagt.
Ja.
Das ist so meine, meine Bedenken, die ich hab bei, bei Black Ops.
So, haben wir unsere Quest jetzt fertig?
Das verschwundene Kind haben wir immer noch nicht gefunden.
Okay, ähm.
Abgeschiedene Hütte.
Dann gehen wir jetzt, gehen wir jetzt zur abgeschiedenen Hütte oder gehen wir jetzt zum Dorf des Echsenvolks?
Ich würde sagen, wir gehen zum Dorf des Echsenvolks, weil da könnte es durchaus sein, dass wir den Jungen aus der Stadt finden, den wir suchen.
Aber ich denke auch mal, dass ich, also ich gehe mal davon aus, dass ich mir Black Ops 4 holen werde.
Lol, ein Echsenmensch.
Bla, bla, bla.
Es gibt XP, das ist schon mal schön.
Ah, guck mal.
Ja, ich suche ein verschwundenes Kind.
Aha, anscheinend kann man hier wirklich die Quest weitermachen.
Ähm, dein Stamm ist mir ehrlich gesagt vollkommen wurscht.
Äh, im Dorf, noch am Leben.
Sehr schön.
Ja, dann klicken wir mal die, die anderen Optionen durch, weil man ja keine Gesprächsmöglichkeiten verpassen will.
Geh weiter, zack.
Ja, das ist halt der Weg, wie ich RPGs spiele.
Ich lese relativ wenig durch.
Vor allem, weil mir halt die meisten Texte so übelst langartig vorkommen.
Ähm, so, wo geht's denn hier weiter?
Okay, da unten ist das Dorf.
Checken wir erstmal ab, ob es hier irgendwie Loot gibt oben.
Siehste, da ist schon was.
Wir müssen auch mal, hätten wir eigentlich in der Hauptstadt machen können, hätten wir was sellen können.
Ich hab so viel Trash-Loot, was ich verkaufen kann.
Ja, aber nächste Woche, oder wann ist denn...
Oh, fuck.
Ein mächtiger Waran, lol.
Okay, können bestimmt nix.
Almiri, Rage-Mode an und bashen.
Äh, Moment, Max, Max, Max, langsam.
Du sollst das nicht als, sollst das hier als Auto-Angriff verwenden.
Ähm, die können alle nix.
Werden alle gebasht, muss man nix casten.
Heute einsammeln, Peter anrufen.
Next.
Kann man hier rum?
Okay, es geht anscheinend weiter hier.
Aber,
aber,
nicht an der Stelle.
Warte mal her.
Wir checken jetzt erstmal die Umgebung ab, bevor wir ins Dorf gehen.
Übrigens, dieses automatische Wegfindesystem in dem Game ist teilweise ein bisschen verbuggt.
Ich hatte das schon mal, da hab ich hier irgendwie oben auf die Map geklickt.
Und auf einmal sind meine Helden quasi out of Map gelaufen, hier außen rum zu dem Punkt.
Ich hab auch gedacht, äh, das ist bestimmt so nicht gedacht.
Mehr Loot.
Zeug, was Geld bringt.
Auch gut.
Ah, kann man hier runter?
Naja, kann man nicht.
Kann man auch nicht lang.
Das ist ja blöd.
Aber hier geht's gar nicht weiter.
Oh.
Jetzt geht's hier oben lang.
Man sieht nicht wirklich was.
Man sieht, es ist gedacht, dass ich zuerst ins Dorf gehe, bevor ich hier oben rankl, äh, äh, hier oben rumlaufe.
Hallo?
Ich seh nix.
Ich seh nix, Game.
Please.
Okay, hier geht's nicht weiter.
Ein Gift Hodak.
Ein unsichtbarer Gift Hodak.
Ich muss übrigens rasten, dass ich meinen Mammut wieder kriege.
Räschen.
Oh, boah.
Ähm, ja.
Und vielleicht sollte ich dem Clary mal abgewöhnen, automatisch Heals zu casten.
Das verbraucht ein bisschen viel Ladung.
Also, mein Mammut ist nicht tot, mein Mammut muss, ähm, ich muss rasten, dass mein Mammut wiederkommt.
Ach, das war gelockt.
Was haben wir hier auch?
Schattenmantel.
Gewährt den Ver...
Oh, das ist nice.
Das können wir Lindsay geben.
Oder wir geben's ihm.
Aber ich geb's mal Lindsay.
Lindsay ist so mein Stelz-Charakter.
Moment, ich hab jetzt nicht geguckt.
Hat es, hat der Rüst, der Umhang?
Ne, brauchst du nicht.
Dann kriegt sie den Schattenumhang.
Dann kriegt sie den Schattenumhang an.
Ja, weil so nen richtigen Rogue hab ich nicht.
As it should be.
Ich hab, ähm...
So nen, so nen, so nen...
Mage-Rogue-Hybrid-Ding in, in der Hauptstadt.
Das ist auch ganz nice.
Aber man braucht das in Pathfinder, äh, Pathfinder anscheinend gar nicht.
Weil man kann mit jedem Charakter quasi die Sachen für Fallen, also Fallen finden und Fallen entschärfen kann man mit jedem...
...Charakter quasi...
specken, das heißt, man braucht gar kein Rogue.
Man braucht keine Rouge.
Wir haben einen, so geil,
wir haben einen auf der Arbeit,
der war auch steif und fester Meinung,
dass der Film, das ist Rouge One
heißt der Film.
Und da hat sie nicht davon überzeugen lassen, dass das nicht so ist.
Was?
Der Echsenvolk Berserker.
Alles wegbashen.
Freund oder Feind, Krieg oder Frieden,
also, wir sind diplomatisch.
Wir sind auf jeden Fall diplomatisch, weil wir haben
plus 19 Diplomatie, was heißt,
wir können diesen Check eigentlich gar nicht failen.
Ich glaube, außer wenn wir 0 würfeln dann,
aber das ist recht unwahrscheinlich.
So, und einen Schüchtern müssen wir den auch nicht.
Wir sind diplomatisch.
Und Rationen bieten wir ihm auch nicht an,
weil ich nicht so viele Rationen dabei habe.
Wir sind diplomatisch.
Easy, so einfach ist das.
Der Echsenvolk König, was will er denn?
Ein kräftiger Echsenmensch.
Er ist mit dem Kopf größer als der Rest des Stamms.
Wahrnehmungswurf.
Es gibt ja, ich weiß nicht,
Easy XP, Easy Life,
ist ja umsonst.
Was los, Warmblut?
Dein Stamm hält ein Menschenkind gefangen.
Ich bin gekommen, um das Kind mitzunehmen.
Jawohl.
Fragen will ich dich eigentlich nicht.
Ich will das Kind wieder haben.
Diplomatie.
Okay, also, wenn wir diesen Diplomatie-Wurf jetzt failen,
dann ist Zeit zum Uninstall.
Wir brauchen Diplomatie,
20,
und ich habe Diplomatie plus 19.
Das bedeutet,
wir müssen,
wir müssen eine 0 oder eine 1 würfeln von 20,
dass wir
diesen Check failen.
Das geht eigentlich gar nicht.
Jawoll, okay, hat geklappt.
Lass du selbst sprechen mit großem Stammvater.
Machen wir.
Äh, wer bist du?
Erzähl mir von dem Stamm.
Warum ist das?
Ist mir vollkommen egal.
Danke für die Antworten.
Angreifen.
Nein, wir greifen nicht an.
Wir gehen zur Hütte und sprechen mit dem großen Stammvater.
Jawoll.
Das machen wir.
Ich, ich, ich speicher mal.
Ich will mal testen, wie stark diese Viecher sind.
Ich speicher mal.
Ich greif den jetzt an.
Ich, ich will den nicht wirklich an.
Ich will einfach mal gucken, wie viele Dinger aushalten.
Angreifen.
Äh, gegen die ist Feuerball bestimmt ganz toll.
Oh, Max, du stehst direkt vor dem Typ.
Das ist, äh, keine gute Idee.
Au, au, au.
Die können ja gar nix.
Können wir auch angreifen.
Aber das machen wir nicht.
Das machen wir nicht.
Wir greifen die nicht an, weil...
Oh, da kommen noch mehr.
Ähm, aber zumindest können die nix.
Ich greif die nicht an, weil, eigentlich, ja, eigentlich bin ich ja, äh, gut.
Ich wollte bloß testen, was die Gegner können.
Okay, dann gehen wir jetzt den großen Stammvater an.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja,
ja.
Okay, dann gehen wir jetzt den großen...
Stamm...
Stammesvater in der Geisterhütte besuchen.
Ich gebe zu, klingt nach ziemlich genericer RPG-Quest.
Ist es wahrscheinlich auch, aber macht trotzdem Bock.
Wie sollen wir da rö...
Röumen rein, römen rein, römen rein?
Und wiründen ourselves da r起來.
Oh, der espera so...
Wie sollen wir da reinkommen?
Kann das sein, dass die Quest nicht aktualisiert hat?
Ich glaube, ich gehe da nochmal rein und frage den Anführer nochmal.
Nicht, dass die Quest verbuggt ist oder so.
Ne, doch, die Quest hat aktualisiert.
Steht bloß neben dem Questlog.
Auch gut.
Who cares?
So, gibt es hier irgendeinen Händler?
Bisschen Zeug kaufen.
Ah, wir können looten.
A nice loot.
Wir können, wir können, vor allem auch ganz wichtig, wir können den Sack, können wir häuten.
Looten.
Da, ganz viel Loot.
Da schläft einer.
Können wir bashen.
Wir heilen, wir heilen ihn mal.
Da kriegen wir bestimmt irgendwas für.
Wer bist du?
Was ist passiert?
Wie hast du mich genannt?
Neutral, gut.
Wir heilen den nächsten Mensch.
Gibt XP.
Da ist er wieder am Start.
Nice.
Dafür können wir jetzt auch deine Hütte looten, oder?
Wir haben dich geheilt, dafür looten wir die Hütte.
Das ist doch fairer Austausch, würde ich sagen.
Haben wir hier noch was?
Diplomatie, du scheinst Angst zu haben.
Was ist hier los?
Diplomatie ist gut.
Diplomatie habe ich viel geskillt.
Erfolgreich, jawohl.
Lebt das Kind noch?
Moment, kann ich den Typ jetzt überreden, mir das Kind zu geben?
Kann ich den Typ jetzt überreden, mir das Kind zu geben?
Äh.
Ne, ich glaube nicht, oder?
Ich glaube, das war einfach nur sinnloses Gelaber.
Ja.
So, haben die irgendeinen Händler in ihrem...
in ihrem Dorf?
Ich würde nämlich mal gerne gucken, was der so hat.
Das Spiel sieht interessant aus, kostet bei Steam aber ziemlich so viel.
Ähm, dann holt sie doch bei GOG.
Da kostet es nicht mehr.
mehr, aber, äh, da kostet es auch nicht weniger.
Aber es hat kein Steam-DHM
oder so Zeugs drauf.
Und ich bilde mir an, es gab sogar
letztens bei Gokk irgendeine Aktion für
essbares Moos.
Mhh, endlich wieder.
Und was haben wir hier?
Gemüse. Ja.
Das ist ja für mich
als omnivorer, weißer
Mann, ist das ganz schlimm, dass hier
Gemüse, was haben wir hier?
Was wollt ihr?
Worüber streitet ihr? Das ist mir,
äh, also eigentlich ist es mir egal,
aber ich muss die Dialog-Option machen.
Ähm,
zum heilen fallen Pflanzen, grüne Kräuter,
falsch, bla bla, Stammvater, ja,
zu dem wollen wir ja, zum großen Stammvater.
Chaotisch gut.
Chaotisch gut,
ich bin, ja,
was auch immer, gut, jawoll, easy.
XP.
Okay, die reden jetzt nicht mehr mit mir.
Ach gut. So, haben wir gelootet.
Erstmal den Gemüsegarten
plündern. Ja, es ist
eh geil, ne? In, in so vielen RPGs
kannst du in jede Hütte reinlaufen, einfach
jeden Schrank aufmachen, jedes Zeugs mitnehmen
und die Einwohner von dieser Hütte
denken so, hopp, ist mir egal.
Da läuft irgendein Typ in
Ritterrüstung und Schild und läuft durch
mein Wohnzimmer und nimmt Zeug
mit, aber das ist egal, das, das juckt
mich nicht, das ist, das ist egal.
Was gibt's hier zu looten?
Einen Aal gibt's zu looten.
Oh, Knüppel.
Knüppel.
Knüppel plus zwei.
Ich müsste echt mal
meinem Clary beibringen, mit Knüppel
zu kämpfen, weil ich hab so viele
nice Knüppel schon und Streitkolben,
die keiner richtig verwenden kann.
Ja, in Witcher 3
war's auch so.
Oh ja, jetzt geht's mir was aufgeploppt gerade.
Wo, wo ist was?
Ach, der Hinter, ach, hier war der Hintereingang.
Ich hätt mich hier einfach reinschleichen können.
Ah. Ja, hätt ich das
mal gewusst.
Hätten wir die wahrscheinlich alle bashen können,
um gut weit gewesen.
Aber, wir sind ja gut, wir bashen keine
Echsenmenschen, sondern
wir gehen jetzt zum
Das kann man
bestimmt looten, das Ding, falls ich's noch nicht hab.
Wir gehen jetzt zum Stammesvater
in der Geisterhütte und
bashen wir den halt.
Oh, hab ich schon gelootet. Oder war gar nicht zu looten.
Ach, zur Geisterhütte.
Moment, da müssten wir hin.
Moment, seh ich das richtig?
Die haben quasi eine Hütte,
mit nem Kranken drinnen, die Häuptlingshütte
und die Schamanenhütte.
Mehr brauchen wir nicht, oder was?
Das ist...
Der Rest ist outdated.
Das ist das Kind,
ja, das ist das Kind, was ich retten soll.
Komm mit.
Kleiner Junge steht in der Mitte der Hütte.
Blablabla.
Was?
Das ist das Stammesvater. Aha.
Okay, das muss ja irgendwie
Illusions-Fake-mäßig sein.
Da ist sofort das Kind frei.
Keiner.
Angst.
Wertvolles als Gegenleistung.
Du kannst froh sein, wenn ich dich nicht bashe, ey.
Wissen, Arcanum.
Oh, da hab ich auch gut geskillt drinnen.
Erfolgreich. Nice.
Ich tendiere ja dazu,
aber ich bin ja guter Gesinnung.
Ich mach sowas ja nicht.
Ich tendiere aber trotzdem dazu.
Was machst du hier?
Was willst du mit dem Kind?
Was willst du vom Klapperer?
Vielleicht kommen wir zu einer anderen
Überraschung.
Eine Ereignis?
Oder eine Ausgabe?
Keine Angst, wir holen dich hier raus.
Deine Mutter liebt dich und wartet auf deine Rückkehr.
Okay, ich hab anscheinend gar keine andere Option,
wie den Typ zu bashen.
Ach so.
Nee, nee.
Ich soll irgendwie dieses komische andere Viech
an ihn ausliefern.
Äh.
Was jetzt?
Eigentlich wollte ich ihn bashen, ne?
Jetzt sind aber so viele echten Menschen drin.
Okay, wisst ihr was?
Warum sollte ich hier großartig
mit Echsenmenschen. Erstmal looten.
Erstmal looten. Warum soll ich hier groß
mit Echsenmenschen verhandeln? Wir können uns einfach
buffen und alles
bashen.
Aced.
Ich will einfach nur mal gucken, ob die was können.
Und Max, du gehst mal weg.
Fireball. Ne, da.
Fireball. Voll rein.
In die Echsenmenschen. Die fressen
bestimmt übelst Damage dadurch.
Oder auch nicht.
Die finden das witzig, wie die
Kampfmusik kaputt geht.
Au.
Clary heilen, heilen,
heilen, Clary, Clary heilen.
Valerie heilen.
Essen. Acht.
Zack. Gebasht.
Wo ist das Kind jetzt?
Wir haben den Jungen aus
den Fängen dieser bösen Geister befreit.
Äh. Ach, da ist er.
Ich dachte, der war nur verhandelt.
Okay, was gibt's denn zu looten?
Ich weiß
jetzt nicht so wirklich, ob wir die Quest
auf die Art und Weise gelöst haben,
wie das gedacht ist.
Aber ich hab als Baron dieser Ländereien
ehrlich gesagt keine Lust
da mit Echsenmenschen irgendwie
Geschäften
zu machen.
Aber Echsenmenschen ist ja auch
so ein heikles Thema für alle
Verschwörungstheoretiker.
Es gibt ja Leute, die
vermuten, dass
der Leibwächter von Obama auch
ein Echsenmensch war.
Wenn du Rüstung plus 1 sagt.
Amulett der natürlichen Rüstung
plus 1 haben wir auch schon.
Ich glaube, wenn ich jetzt hier rausgehe.
Ja, Shadow Ghost.
Tatsächlich.
Rüstung.
Du musst da mal
auf YouTube nachsuchen.
Das ist wirklich bescheuert.
Also wenn ihr mal was Lustiges sehen wollt,
da müsst ihr euch angucken
den
Echsenmensch Bodyguard
von Obama
und ihr müsst euch angucken
Obama Shapeshifter.
Also wer noch nicht genug
Verschwörungstheorien hat,
der...
Ich muss jetzt sagen,
Obama Shapeshifter ist ja
meine Lieblings-Verschwörungstheorie.
Ich meine,
es ist ja auch eh schon geil, ne?
Wenn man sich überlegt,
wie viele
quasi in der heutigen Zeit
tatsächlich den ganzen Krämpfel glauben,
ne?
Man weiß nicht so genau.
Oh, wow.
Damit hätte ich jetzt eigentlich rechnen können,
dass die jetzt erstmal alles voller Echsen,
Menschen ist, draußen.
Zack.
An.
Rage.
Wir haben jetzt einfach nur mal nebenbei
das komplette Echsenmenschen-Dorf ausgerottet.
Und das als eigentlich guter Charakter.
Aber ich bin Baron
und ich will mit Echsenmenschen nicht verhandeln.
Ich kann das ja sogar RPG-technisch begründen.
Und da kommen aber ganz schön viele jetzt.
Ähm, da müssen wir doch nochmal
einen Feuerball reinhauen, würde ich sagen.
Ja, na gut, so viel Damage macht der Feuerball jetzt nicht.
Oh, Amiri kriegt übelst offen.
Zack.
Da hätte ich mich ein bisschen besser
auf den Fight vorbereiten müssen.
Äh, Trista, Trista macht heil.
Und der Max, der Max macht Feuerdamage
auf die Kollegen hier unten.
Auf den hier.
Den macht der Feuerdamage.
Äh, Valerie muss den da bashen.
Alter, Amiri kriegt der echt offen.
Zack.
Die tankt auch gerade alleine.
Das ist ziemlich mies.
Das sollte ich eigentlich gar nicht machen.
Aber Tristan heilt.
Und, äh, der hier oben ist da.
Valerie tankt die.
Und der Max castet noch ein paar Feuerbälle hier rein.
Komm, Tristan, hau einfach deinen kompletten Heal raus.
Oder Magic Missile.
Was haben wir sonst noch für...
Haste.
Haste brauchen wir ganz vergessen.
Mit Haste geht gleich alles viel einfacher.
Tristan, du sollst heilen.
Ja, mit Haste wird durchgeschnitzelt.
Haha, Gigabit Internet für Deutschland 2020.
Ja.
Das ist tatsächlich eine sehr gewagte Verschwörungstheorie, muss ich sagen.
Okay.
Ich glaube, wir haben das rein aus XP-Sicht ziemlich gut gelöst.
Wir haben quasi die komplette XP abgegriffen von der Quest-Chain im Dorf.
Und danach alles gekillt.
Das ist, denke ich, ziemlich optimal.
So, und die Knüppel können wir alle verkaufen.
Die Meisterabteilung.
Die Meisterarbeitknüppel können wir alle verkaufen.
Jetzt haben wir sozusagen min-maxed die Quest.
Ich höre da von rechts noch Dinger.
Ist allerdings mal da.
Ja, ach so, ja, zum Thema Internetausbau finde ich auch wieder geil, ne?
Ich poste ja das immer mal auf Twitter, diese Geschichte.
Oh, da ist noch was.
Um daran zu erinnern, was da öfters mal für eine Scheiße erzählt wird.
Weil es hat ja Anfang des Jahres, ja, der Regierung,
Sprecher gepostet, so nach dem Motto
Ja, also 2018
bis Ende 2018, 50 MBit
Easy Mode, überhaupt kein Ding, alles
kein Thema
Obwohl eigentlich ja
bekannt ist, dass wir die letzten Jahre auch
schon jegliches Breitbandziel immer verkackt
haben
Und
da hatte dann sogar noch die Telekom drauf geantwortet
Wir haben das alle so getan, als wäre das jetzt
auf einmal so
Deswegen retweete ich das
alle paar Monate mal wieder
um dran zu erinnern, wie
beknackt das eigentlich ist, weil
das wird natürlich nicht erreicht
Das war aber auch schon vorher klar
Übrigens den Sack können wir auch häuten
Warum auch immer man
diesen Sack häuten kann
Man weiß nicht
Aber da sieht man, dass da einfach wieder Dinger rausgehauen
werden, obwohl man
weiß, dass es kompletter Schwachsinn ist
Einfach so nach dem Motto, ah, die Leute
sind da nicht damit zufrieden, dann hauen wir doch
jetzt einfach mal raus, 50 MBit
für jeden bis Ende 2018
Gar kein Problem, easy, kein Ding
Und dann irgendwie kurz vor Ende 2018
Also jetzt sagt man so, ah, Leute
Hm, das
funktioniert doch nicht
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Naja, und das Beste an diesem
Post war ja, dass sie geschrieben
haben, flächendeckend
quasi 50 MBit
für jeden bis Ende 2018
Und dann haben sie
noch dabei geschrieben, aber
heutzutage müssen wir ja schon in Gigabit
denken
Wo ich mir auch gedacht hab, also in welchem
Land, hallo?
Äh
Ja
Gut, dann gehen wir halt
durch das Haupttor raus
Was willst du machen?
Ähm, da hab ich auch, in welchem
Wo leben die eigentlich in ihrem Kopf, dass
man wirklich davon ausgeht, dass man
Ja, ist ja gut
Hallo, Tür öffnen, Tür öffnen
Also sprich, wo lebt
man im Kopf, dass man quasi weiß, man hat es
die letzten Jahre nicht einmal geschafft
ein Ziel zu erreichen und jetzt
äh, auf einmal
ist Gigabit am Start, oder wie?
Oder was? Hä?
Wie soll das gehen?
Man weiß es nicht genau
Aber ich mein, man kann ja sowas auch einfach
mal erzählen
Zweihändige Keule, plus eins
Sackt, brauchen wir nicht
Knüppel, nice
Ja, aber das ist wirklich lächerlich in Deutschland, wie es gerade
geschrieben hat im Chat
Das ist, äh
total beknackt
Okay, hier kann man nicht lang
Das ist der Einzige, das überlebt hat hier
Der Typ, den ich eigentlich dem Anführer bringen sollte
Gucken, was der dazu sagt jetzt, dass ich sein ganzes Dorf niedergemetzelt hab
Oh, der mag mich auch noch
Dafür, dass ich sein komplettes Dorf gebasht habe
Nice
In due time
So
Gehen
Gut, die Quest ist fertig
Es bleibt jetzt, soweit ich das gesehen hab
eigentlich nur noch die Main Quest weiter zu machen
Ich hab jetzt nichts mehr offen
Ich hab alles erledigt
Verschwundenes Kind, genau, ich muss in die Hauptstadt
So
Hauptstadt mit der Mutter reden, fertig
Und dann Main Quest weitermachen
Alles klar, machen wir
Wir können auch hier kurz vorbei gehen
Mal schauen, was es da so gibt
Aber vorher, Leute
Ich muss mal kurz aufs Klo
Ich bin gleich wieder am Start
Zwei Minuten
So, wieder am Start
Ich bin gleich wieder am Start
Guckt ihr eigentlich noch Let's Plays auf YouTube?
War so eine Frage an euch jetzt
An den Chat
An den Platt Chat
Guckt noch jemand Let's Plays auf YouTube?
Und wenn ja, wen guckt ihr da so?
Weil ich hab so den Eindruck
Dass Let's Plays nicht mehr so das Ding auf YouTube sind
Also klar, ich mein
Channels wie Gronkh haben immer zu viel
Aber ich hab so den Eindruck
Dass Let's Plays nicht mehr so das Ding auf YouTube sind
Also klar, ich mein
Channels wie Gronkh haben immer Zuschauer
Da müssen wir nicht drüber reden
Ähm
Aber
Ich hab den Eindruck, es ist nicht mehr so angesagt
Und ich glaube
Das liegt vor allem daran, dass viele Leute mittlerweile Streams gucken
Und ich muss ehrlich sagen
Ich find so einen Stream
Für nen Let's Play
Viel unterhaltsamer und viel angenehmer zu gucken
Als so nen, nennen wir es mal statisches Let's Play auf YouTube
Also mit statisch Let's Play
Mein ich halt, weil es
Nicht interaktiv ist
Und halt auch nicht, man halt einfach nicht so live dabei ist
Klar, man kann Kommentare schreiben und sowas
Aber es ist viel lustiger
Wenn man auf Twitch nen Stream guckt
Und dann nen Chat dabei hat
Und irgendwie sind Let's Plays auf YouTube
Find ich nicht mehr so das Ding
Wie es noch früher gewesen sind
Da! Marmot is back!
Da ist es!
Ja, ich mach wieder Videos, sobald es neue Games gibt, die mir Bock machen
Okay
33 Erfahrungspunkte
Das ist jetzt typische RPG Logik
Bevor wir jetzt mit dem Besitzer des Hauses reden
Laufen wir einmal durchs ganze Haus
Und
Plündern das
Weil, das interessiert ja keinen
Zack
Weil RGB
RPG Logik
RGB Logik
War was anderes
Ganze Zutaten grabben
Ein Schleuderstab
Was macht man denn mit einem Schleuderstab?
Jetzt sagt nicht schleudern
Weil wir laufen erstmal ganz
Das merkt ja auch keiner
Wir gehen einfach mal durchs Haus durch
Wir plündern alle Truhen
Die steht am Tresen und die juckt das überhaupt nicht
Vielleicht sollten wir doch mal mit ihr reden vorher
Eine stämmige Zwergin
Ein nices Grill
Ihr seid zum ersten mal hier
Was ist das hier?
Wie lange lebst du schon hier?
Abgelegen
Jägerhütte
Genug von deiner Hütte
Ich würde gerne die Nacht hier verbringen
Ich will deine Waren sehen
Okay
Was hat sie denn?
Äh
Langweilig
Ich würde gerne eine Nacht hier verbringen
Sieben Goldstücke
Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass sieben Goldstücke viel wären für mich
Aber
Wir können ja mal versuchen diplomatisch zu sein
Ich bin Herrscher dieser Gefilde
Zack
Diplomatie habe ich halt viele Punkte drauf
Hier ist euer Schlüssel
Okay das Mammut ist noch ein bisschen debufft
Weil es eben einmal verreckt ist
Also wieviel Lebenspunkte hat eigentlich mein Mammut?
81 und wieviel hat der Hund?
Warum hat der Hund
Warum hat der Hund mehr Lebenspunkte als das Mammut?
Also
Mal ganz unabhängig
Wenn ihr euch jetzt überlegen müsstet
Welches Pet hat wohl mehr Trefferpunkte?
Das da?
Oder das da?
Was würdet ihr denken?
Und welches Pet macht mehr Damage?
Also normalerweise würde man aus dem Bauch aus sagen
Das hier ist DPS Pet
Und das ist Tank Pet
So rein von der Optik
Aber nicht so in diesem Game
Okay gehen wir mal gucken was es hier oben gibt
Weil wir haben ja den Schlüssel aus dem Hinterzimmer geklaut
Oh fuck
Ich hätte speichern sollen wenn ich oben bin
Weil eine fragwürdige Designentscheidung
Die die Entwickler hier von diesem Game getroffen haben
Man kann Schlösser nur einmal pro Held probieren
Was heißt ich habe nur Lindsay dabei die das ordentlich kann
Und wenn Lindsay Failed bei dem Schloss
Wie schwer ist denn das Schloss?
Alter
Ich habe jetzt zweimal gefailt mit plus
Mit plus 14
Weil ich eine 1 gewürfelt habe oder was?
Oh man
So und das ist halt nur eine fragwürdige Entscheidung weil letztendlich führt es nicht weiter
Alter come on Lindsay
Du kriegst das doch hin
Das ist halt total dumm
Sollen sie halt sagen man braucht einen festgelegten Wert für eine Tür
Und nicht diese Lade
Aber wenn wir das Haus plündern dann plündern wir es schon richtig
Aha was ist da drin?
Resistenzumhang plus 2
Sehr nice
Ich glaube könnte man sogar
Unserem Ranger anziehen
Wir könnten
Ich glaube die braucht das hier gar nicht mehr
Ne weil die hat schon den Ring
Rüstungsarm Schienen plus 3
Die braucht das hier auch nicht
Die haben das alles schon
Aber Rüstungsklasse 36 ist halt richtig krass
Rüstungsklasse 36 ist halt richtig krass
Massive
Huge Rüstungsklasse ist das
Der kann den anziehen
The Rangers
Massive Rüstungsklasse
Komm Lindsay Türe knacken
Auf ich hab kein Bock zu reloaden
Haha
Oooh
Sehr sehr nice
2000 Goldstücke
Einfach mal das komplette Haus geplündert
Nice jetzt läuft das Schlösser knacken aber
Oh ne reload
Haha
Ja das ist wirklich ne bescheuerte Entscheidung gewesen
Dass man jedes mal reloaden muss
Dass man das nochmal ausprobieren kann
Ich muss kurz was gucken
Was sagt ihr eigentlich zur Mini Playstation
Sollte ein Baron eigentlich seine Leute beschützen und nicht bestehlen
Ja das ist äh dehnbar
Ich beschütze die Leute
Alter, Lindsay.
und dafür kriege ich natürlich auch was.
Moin, der Apfel.
Komm, Lindsay, Tür knacken.
Aha.
Moment, kann ich jetzt pennen?
Ich kann die Tür knacken, um mich dann
in das Bett zu legen, ja, ist klar.
Oh.
Dieses Looten.
Wahrscheinlich brauche ich
noch nicht mal, was da drin ist.
Aber ich sehe es nicht ein,
dass ich
nicht...
Was braucht man denn? Schwierigkeitsgrad 27.
Wurf 1. Ernsthaft.
1. Ich habe eine Plus 14
auf Schlösser.
Haha, hat funktioniert.
Gehe nochmal speichern.
Sehr schön.
Ah, was haben wir denn hier?
Rüstungsklasse 3 Verbesserung.
Das kann Lindsay anziehen.
Wo ist es denn?
Macht das sonst noch irgendwas?
Ne.
Das ist alles RNG.
Ja, das ist schon klar, dass das RNG ist.
Die Sache ist die,
ich finde, das ist eine Mechanik,
die sich nicht gut auf Computerspiele überträgt.
Es spricht nichts dagegen,
dass man so einen Schwellenwert macht,
ab wann man einen Schlösser knacken kann.
Dann sollte man einfach sagen,
okay, du bist über dem Schwellenwert drunter,
besonders im Schwellenwert drunter.
Pech gehabt.
Weil ansonsten führt das einfach nur dazu,
dass die Leute beliebig lang probieren,
wenn sie eine Chance draufhaben.
Und es ist nervig.
Deswegen sollte man es einfach nicht machen.
So.
Wir haben jetzt eigentlich hier alles durch, ne?
Dann müssen wir jetzt in die Hauptstadt
und danach Main Quest weitermachen.
Ja, PS1.
Ich wollte irgendwas zur PS1 sagen,
deswegen hatte ich gefragt.
Ich habe es aber voll verdrängt, was ich wollte.
Tja, vielleicht fällt mir es wieder ein.
Hauptstadt.
Was wollte ich denn?
Was wollte ich denn mit der PS1?
PS1 Classic.
Hm, ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Ja, okay, also,
Cache, das kann schon sein, dass...
Wow.
Oh!
Das Ding basht bestimmt ordentlich, ordentlich rein.
Ähm, Cache, das kann schon sein,
aber dann sollte man es vielleicht als Option machen oder so.
Aber defaultmäßig finde ich es blöd, weil...
Ich könnte wetten, dazu gibt es sogar irgendwelche Untersuchungen,
dass die meisten Spieler sobald sie eine Chance darauf haben,
es einfach mit Reload, und Reload möglich ist,
einfach so oft reloaden, bis es funktioniert.
Das könnten wir als Option machen.
Man könnte sogar sagen, ich spiele es ja auffordernd,
wenn man es da standardmäßig einschaltet, meinetwegen.
Aber es ist halt überall so.
Oh, das Ding frisst gut.
Okay, Feuerbälle müssen wir da logischerweise...
oder wahrscheinlich nicht draufschießen.
Buffen wir mal das Mammut.
Ja, wir schießen da jetzt einfach Missiles drauf,
das ist doch okay.
Wieso hat Tristan bei dir so viel Heal?
Ähm...
Weil ich das geskillt hab.
Also, ich hab...
Kann ich dir...
Warte mal, ich zeig's dir.
Ich hab Dings geskillt, ein paar Mal.
Zusätzliches Fokussieren hab ich drei Mal...
gespeckt.
Und es gibt...
äh...
gibt zwei Mal zusätzlich.
Plus, was man nicht vergessen darf,
er hat bei mir auch...
ähm...
nen...
Armreif an.
Ne, nee, kein Armreif,
nen Stirnreif an,
der...
Weisheit bringt.
Und Weisheit...
ist wichtig für Clary Spells.
Und ich könnte mir vorstellen,
dass die...
Wie gesagt, so sehr kenne ich mich im Pathfinder-Regelwerk nicht aus,
ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass die Anzahl der Ladungen
auch was mit meinem Attributwert zu tun hat.
Wie viel Clary Spells man kriegt,
äh...
anscheinend ja wirklich.
Oh, Armreif.
Easy.
Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich gedacht, es wird viel schwieriger.
Und es...
gibt es nichts zu looten?
Das ist ja...
enttäuschend.
Ich weiß, ich glaub,
Int bringt Clary Snakes.
Hast du damals eigentlich
Life is Strange gespielt?
Nein.
Nope.
Hab ich nicht.
Gibt eh so ein paar Games,
die ich noch spielen...
muss,
wenn's danach geht,
was die letzten Jahre so rausgekommen ist.
Aber...
ich krieg das irgendwie nicht hin.
Also alles, was man noch spielen müsste,
zu spielen,
kommt da nicht...
hinterher.
Moment.
Warum wurde dieses Dorf hier jetzt gerade frei...
freigegeben bei mir?
Ich mein,
es ist nicht so, dass ich's von hier sehen könnte,
oder so?
Gut.
Okay.
Aber wir gehen...
erstmal in die Hauptstadt.
Und gucken mal,
was es Neues gibt.
Muss dann noch wenig arbeiten.
Hab ich mir tatsächlich überlegt...
Hab ich mir tatsächlich überlegt,
ob ich nicht noch einen Tag
weniger arbeiten gehen sollte.
Ich bin letztens erst wieder überlegt.
Oh, es gibt neue Ereignisse.
Oh.
Der hat's verkackt,
seinen Auftrag.
Tristan hat's,
äh...
verkackt,
seinen Auftrag.
Tristan hat's,
äh...
verkackt,
seinen Auftrag.
Tristan hat's,
äh...
verkackt,
seinen Auftrag.
Tristan hat's,
äh...
gut gemacht.
Okay, die anderen sind noch beschäftigt.
Drei Tage Straßen bauen,
54 Tage das hier.
Wichtige Veröffentlichung.
Okay, ich muss den Thronsaal einmal.
Ich muss...
mehr Jungfrauen bashen.
Ein echtes Meisterwerk.
Mach das einfach mal.
Äh...
Um die Flussjungfrau kümmert sich Tristan.
Oh, in den Thronsaal muss ich eh.
Ja, sie baut noch.
jahrelang
Amazon Links
gespammt und die
bringen irgendwie egal, ob man
was macht, ob man aktiv ist, was hoch
oder nix macht, die bringen immer Kohle.
Amazon Reflinks ist eigentlich das Beste,
was man machen kann.
Aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass das übertrieben viel wäre.
Das steht
und fällt alles damit, wie aktiv
man Videos macht. Und aktuell mache ich ja
quasi nichts.
Eine äußerst ungewöhnliche
Nachricht. Ich habe unangenehme Nachrichten erst gelesen.
Ja, und was ist es denn?
Ja, stimmt, der Typ wollte ein Buch
über mich schreiben. Dann,
wenn er das
gerne machen will,
muss ich die jetzt bekommen.
Das ist mir eigentlich wurscht.
So.
Achso, ja, ja, sie bauen.
Also, wenn es danach geht,
ich habe da
eigentlich keine Sorgen irgendwie.
So.
Jetzt müssen wir
mal gucken.
Was müssen wir denn jetzt machen?
Eigentlich
Ja, Valerie,
soll man mal sagen, wie es hier
läuft?
Ich könnte auch mit Valerie
flirten in dem Game, aber irgendwie, ich weiß nicht.
Habe ich
auf irgendwelche
NPC-Romance-Geschichten
keinen Bock?
Man kann in dem Game, weil es die Leute
immer wissen wollen, wenn es sowas gibt.
Also, in dem Game gibt es, glaube ich,
vier oder
fünf, ich glaube, vier
NPC-Romance-Optionen.
Einmal Valerie
gibt es, dann gibt es, ähm,
Valerie steht nur auf Männer.
Dann gibt es, ähm,
einen Halb-Org,
der auf Männer und Frauen steht.
Also quasi
richtig Kappa-Pride.
Dann gibt es irgendwie noch
eine Halb-Elfin, die auch auf Männer und Frauen steht.
Und es gibt Tristan, der, glaube ich,
auch auf Männer und Frauen steht. Irgendwie so.
Also, in dem Game hier kann man sich
komplett austoben, wie man will, wenn man denn
NPC-Romances will.
Also, ich bin irgendwie,
in keinem der Games großartiger Fan von
irgendwie NPC-Romance, weil die meisten
Dialogoptionen sind immer so übelst
cringe, dass, äh,
das wäre eigentlich zu blöd.
Wer läuft da eigentlich rum?
Ach, die Wache.
Okay.
Ähm, tja.
Ja, also, das hier oben ist die
Das da ist die Elfin,
mit die man romancen kann.
Das hier ist der Halb-Org.
Und Valerie steht hier oben irgendwo rum.
Warum ich auch immer ihr so einen Hut aufgezogen hab.
So, wir müssen
anscheinend jetzt Main-Quest machen.
Oh!
Es gibt eine Zwischensequenz,
die ich jetzt komplett, äh, übersehen hätte.
Wenn es mich nicht automatisch hinscrollen würde.
Welche Ehre,
euch heute zu treffen.
Den sie möchte mir jemand vorstellen.
Okay.
Buchhändlerin.
Was man als Baron nicht alles machen muss, oder?
Man muss sich wirklich
um jeden Scheiß kümmern.
Wo kommt ihr her? Wie seid ihr, den sie begegnet?
Was hat euch hergeführt?
Bleibt ihr?
Ich könnte noch ein paar, ähm,
ähm,
Helfer brauchen.
Für, für
Aufgaben hier in der Baronie.
Das wär nicht schlecht.
Wie steht es? Gibt es Nachrichten? Was ist da los?
Hat sich jemand
über mein Land erkundigt?
Danke, das reicht.
Lebt wohl.
Ja.
Ein nicer Dialog.
Weiter Main-Quest.
Äh, wir können mal gucken, ob
meine Händler mittlerweile mehr haben.
Äh, wartet mal.
Wie lange hab ich eigentlich noch Zeit für die Quest?
87 Tage, ja.
Dann machen wir die Main-Quest vorher weiter.
Der alte Mann verneigt sich.
Blablabla. Zeigt mir, was ihr anzubieten habt.
Nur
Crap.
Was ist denn das? Ring des Reichhaltigen gewährt
plus 1 auf Schadenswürfe mit Bogen und
einen Glücksbonus.
Schadenswürfe
mit Bogen kann
eindeutig
unser Ranger gebrauchen.
Der hatte noch nix in der Richtung.
Tiergefährten erhalten einen Verbesserungs-
Oh!
Aha!
Den brauch ich.
Da basht mein Mammut noch
mehr. Da hat mein Mammut
plus 2 Stärke und plus 2 Geschick.
So muss das sein.
Äh, unser Ranger kriegt mehr
Bogendamage.
Erhöht die Rettungswürfe des Tieres um 1.
Brauch ich jetzt nicht. Was haben wir denn sonst
hier noch? Duellhandschuhe.
Entwaffnen.
Stirnreif, den hab ich schon.
Rüstung.
Das wär was für Amiri, oder?
Wobei, ne, die hat nen
Halskette der Ewigen.
Halskette gewährt Angriffsbonus von 2 und
einen Schadensbonus von plus 4 gegen Tiere
und magische Besten. Das wär wirklich was für
unseren Barb.
Und ich sollte eigentlich auch genug Kohle haben.
Ja, ich muss hier, ich hab hier nämlich noch
massig Zeug zu verkaufen.
Zack.
Zack, zack, zack, zack, zack.
Zack, zack, zack, zack.
Erstmal alles nicht magische
verkaufen.
So.
Schaust du eigentlich Serien? Und wenn ja, welche empfiehlst du?
In letzter Zeit hab ich wenig geguckt.
Ähm, was war denn, jetzt muss ich mal überlegen, was war denn
die letzte Serie, die
ich geguckt hab? Ich hab die
dritte Staffel von Preacher geguckt.
Ich hab, äh,
hab ich denn
geguckt? In letzter Zeit
hab ich da eh, ich hab nicht viel, muss ich sagen.
Also, was ich wirklich ganz gut
finde, oder ganz gut fand, Moment,
ich muss erst mal gucken, dass ich, ähm,
mir das Zeug leisten kann
hier. Selber.
Gibt's hier noch irgendwas, was
ich brauch? Kurzbogen plus 1.
Kann ich verkaufen, brauch kein Mensch mehr.
Sai plus 1
kann ich verkaufen, hab ich überhaupt keine Klasse,
die ich jetzt verwenden kann. Und wenn ich mal eine hab
und die verwenden will, kann ich mir das Zeug
kaufen. Ähm,
Bail plus 1
auch kann der das
verwenden kann. Streitkolben
hab ich ein. Scharfes Langschwert brauch ich
nicht. Hab ich bessere.
Das verkaufen wir
bestimmt nicht.
Äh, Kriegshammer auch nicht.
Das auch nicht. Also alle
Named Items verkaufen wir nicht. Zweihändige
Keule plus 1 brauch ich nicht, hab ich
auch was besseres.
Schleuderstab, den behalten wir mal.
Weiß nicht, wofür der da ist.
Eisstreitachse plus 1
könnt man mal behalten.
Streitkolben plus 1 brauch ich eigentlich
auch nicht.
Kurzschwert plus 1 brauch ich auch nicht.
Bastardschwert plus 1 brauch ich auch nicht.
Hab ich auch schon besser das.
Tja. Eats.
Ja, ähm, Serien stimmt.
Also eine Sache, die ich echt cool fand,
hab ich auch schon mal im Stream gezeigt,
die irgendwie gar nicht so bekannt ist,
aber die fand ich echt gut, ist das hier.
Ähm,
fand ich
echt nicht übel. Guck mal mal auf,
ja.
Loki vs. Dr. House.
Ähm,
das ist aber nach irgendeinem Buch, das heißt
die Story ist in der Regel schon mal,
kann schon mal nicht ganz so beknackt sein.
Die meisten Buchverfilmungen haben zumindest was
Story anbelangt immer halbwegs Hand und Fuß.
So, also jetzt
was rüsten wir aus? Amiri kriegt
die Halskette.
Was? Warum stackt das?
Hä?
Amiri verwirrt mich.
The fuck?
Hä? Moment,
ist Rüstungs...
Ist Rüstungsbonus was anderes
als Rüstungsklasse?
Anscheinend.
Ähm,
ja, dann werde ich jetzt Amiri doch nicht anziehen, dann heben wir das auf.
Weil Amiri kriegt eh schon so
auf die Fresse, die noch
weniger Rüstungsklasse
will ich der nicht zumuten.
Aber wir können der den Schutzumhang
anziehen. Dann hat's wieder
22. Hä?
Okay, das check ich
jetzt nicht. Na gut, dann
behält die das erstmal an.
Unser Ranger
kriegt...
Ne, das krieg ich.
Wo is er?
Das kriegt der Max. Der Max kriegt
für seinen Mammut
Mammut
Dexpunkte
und das da kriegt unser
Bogey.
Wo is er? Da.
Okay, climate damage. Da, Marke.
Sag mal, kann das sein, dass
das hier verpackt ist und überhaupt nichts macht?
Seht ihr, irgendwie sich die
Stats verändern?
Ich glaub, kann das sein, dass das verpackt ist,
dieses Item?
Oder ist Rüstungsbonus was
anderes, wie
das hier gibt?
Das könnte auch, das könnte schon sein.
Ja gut, dann, ähm...
Müssen wir gucken.
Wieso bist du mit deinem Hexenmeister so stark
auf Charisma gegangen?
Weil ich ein, ähm...
Waldhexenmeister bin
und ein Waldhexenmeister
hat als Cast-Attribut Charisma.
Normaler Hexenmeister
glaub ich Weisheit.
Und als Waldhexenmeister kriegt man ein Pet
und ein paar andere
Naturspell
mit Level Up, aber das Pet ist das
Wichtigste eigentlich.
So, hab ich irgendwie ne Möglichkeit,
Aniri dieses komische Ammo anzuziehen?
Mein cool wär das schon.
Ich muss gleich nochmal zum Händler verkaufen.
Kann man das
irgendwie hier sortieren?
Sortieren nach, äh...
Ich glaube
diese Armschienen sind verbuggt.
Ja, äh, Cashey
ich weiß, das steht da, aber guck mal
ähm, die
beim Amulett funktioniert's.
Guck.
Wart mal.
Beim Amulett
geht's.
Bei der Armschiene geht's nicht.
Deswegen hab ich mir das andere Amulett
ja auch erst nur gekauft, weil ich gedacht hab,
äh, ich hab eh schon plus 3 hiervon,
dann brauch ich das nicht mehr. Ich, ich würd einfach mal
sagen, das ist entweder ein anderer Bonus,
weil's hier explizit um Rüstungsklasse
geht, um hier ein Rüstungsbonus,
was auch immer der Unterschied ist,
ähm,
jo. Achso, ach,
Bonus ist quasi, was sich hier drauf auswirkt,
oder was?
Okay, was auch immer.
Da hört's bei mir mit
Pathfinder-Kenntnissen auf.
Ja, das ist was unterschiedliches,
dachte ich mir schon, aber was, was
ist Rüstungsbonus?
Aber ich könnte Amiri den Schutzring
geben, ne?
Ich könnte Amiri den Schutzring plus 2 geben,
und dann kann ich das hier
ausziehen.
Ne, das wirkt auch, das wirkt
zusätzlich.
Rüstungsklasse des Trägers
steigert nicht, und hier ist
die Rüstungsklasse des
Nutzer steigt um 2.
Stacked nicht.
Uh.
Also entweder ist die deutsche Übersetzung total
bescheuert, oder es ergibt keinen Sinn.
Hier steht es plus 2, Rüstungsklasse stackt nicht.
Kann ich aber auch mitleben,
da hat Amiri jetzt wenigstens
plus 24 Rüstungsklasse, ist auch okay.
Ich glaube,
das ist, glaube ich, so ein bisschen das Problem, ähm,
ich, ich gehe mal davon aus, dass diese allen,
diese ganzen drei Werte, dass das drei unterschiedliche
Werte sind, und wenn man
das wahrscheinlich, ähm, auf Englisch
lesen würde, dann wird's wahrscheinlich auch
ein bisschen klarer.
Äh, raus,
rauskristallisieren, was wie ist.
Naja, lassen wir das erstmal so, Amiri braucht
auf jeden Fall Rüstungsklasse,
weil die ist immer so schnell down.
Und da wird's wenigstens ein bisschen schlechter
getroffen.
So, verkaufen wir nochmal die ganzen
Mists, die ich hier hab.
Handeln, zack.
Gut, weiter geht's.
Main
Quest.
Eine verdiente Belohnung.
Achso, das verschwundene Kind, wir müssen noch zur
Mutter gehen. Wir müssen noch zur Mutter,
die natürlich, wo soll's sonst sein,
in der Taverne steht.
Ja. Wenn das die Feministen
wieder mitkriegen, ja.
Also, Cashie und
Rosil, ich glaube euch das,
ja, ich glaube euch das. Ist ja auch, sieht man
ja auch ingame. Ähm, ich find's so ein bisschen
unglücklich geschrieben.
Dass das, äh,
nicht so klar wird, was was ist. Ich mein,
es ist cool bei nem,
bei ner Pen & Paper Variante,
wenn du da quasi so ein Item hast und dann
kannst du dann, hast du so einen schönen, so
Flavortext quasi so dazu.
Ähm,
bei, in Games
fänd ich's halt schön, wenn man einfach
ein paar Item-Statistiken
hinschreibt. Weißt du?
Hier, Tabelle, plus, plus, plus, plus,
stackt nicht.
Kommt da einfach ein bisschen klarer raus, wie, wie was
zusammen funktioniert. So, wo
steht denn die Mutter hier rum da?
Ach, Quest beendet. Wann kriegen
wir denn schon wieder ein Level-Up? Oh, das dauert noch.
Es wird viel in dem Spiel nicht erklärt.
Ja, ja, tatsächlich. Wobei ich das eigentlich
eigentlich ganz cool finde.
Das ist,
also nein, das stimmt nicht. Ich find nicht cool, dass vieles
nicht erklärt wird. Ich find ganz cool, dass es relativ
komplex ist. Das Mammut in der Tabelle.
Das Mammut läuft mir überall nach.
Das Mammut kennt da nix.
Ich find cool, dass es komplex ist und auch,
dass die Vorlage wohl ganz gut, äh,
übernimmt.
Das, das find ich schon nice.
Man hätte manche Sachen doch schon ein bisschen besser
an irgendein PC-Spiel anpassen können.
Aber an sich bin ich echt
zufrieden mit dem Game. Das ist eines der besten
Classic-
RPGs, die es so in den letzten Jahren
gegeben hat.
Was ich halt richtig geil finde, ist, dass man so
viele Freiheiten hat. Man kann eigentlich machen, was man will.
Okay, so. Jetzt gehen wir Main-Quest
machen.
So, unsere Main-Quest sagt nämlich,
ich soll die Nymphe
in ihren grünen Gemächern
treffen.
Ja.
Sind wir da wohl?
Dann gleich sehen wir
eine in den grünen Gemächern.
Was stand da noch?
Wäre ich der Baron, würde ich mich
mit Unsichtbarkeitsdrängen
und anderen Mitteln eindecken,
um Ärger zu vermeiden.
Okay.
Dann gehe ich mal nicht davon aus,
dass es gleich mit der Nymphe hier übelst abgehen wird,
sondern,
dass ich versucht werde zu bashen.
Gucken wir, äh, versucht wird mich
zu killen.
Gucken wir mal, ob ich Unsichtbarkeitsdränge dabei habe,
aber müsste ich eigentlich haben.
Was zum Teufel ist hier
Unsichtbarkeitsdränge?
Verschwinden.
Es könnte sogar sein, dass ich Scrolls habe mit
verschwinden und
vielleicht habe ich auch
Unsichtbarkeit habe ich nicht als Spell.
Das wäre jetzt natürlich auch
zu schön gewesen.
Was?
Was mit schleichen? Das kann gut sein, dass gleich
geschlichen wird.
Und dafür brauche ich auf jeden Fall Unsichtbarkeitsdränge,
wenn ich schleichen soll, weil, ähm,
Moment.
Mein Held
kann nicht schleichen.
Der ist unglaublich schlecht im Schleichen.
So, Main Quest.
Ja, wir nehmen
eine altbekannte Truppe mit.
Den Zwergen-Clarry
wollte ich auch mal aus Becken ausrüsten.
Weil,
ich spiele ja selbst Zwergen-Clarry.
Wenn wir denn spielen.
Allerdings 5e.
Was gibt es denn für neue Sachen?
Wobei ich mir mit meinem Zwergen-Clarry
teilweise so richtig als Heal-Bot
vorkomme, ne?
Im Schloss wartet was auf
ne, das habe ich doch schon gelesen. Passt.
Projekte. Forschung.
Ich habe keinen, der forschen kann.
Du hast vergessen, dass du allein dahin sollst.
Nein, das habe ich nicht vergessen.
Aber ich kann einfach am Gebietseingang
meine
Gruppe ändern.
Wenn ich auf
der Weltkarte bin.
Deswegen nehme ich die Leute mal mit.
Weil es können immer noch Zufallskämpfe auf dem Weg
dahin kommen und
da habe ich keinen Bock alleine.
Ich glaube ohne, ohne, ja.
Ohne Rasten
schaffe ich es nicht.
Keine Ration verwenden. Ich kann jagen.
Wir wollen auch
nichts spezielles kochen.
Ja.
Weiter.
Eine Sache, die mir bei dem Spiel auch
ein bisschen auf den Keks geht, ist, dass man
einen Ticken zu viele Ladezeiten
hat.
Sowohl
sowohl beim Map wechseln,
beim hier, beim in Zufallskämpfe gehen überall.
Du hast den Thron,
wenn du in den Thronsaal
willst, um dein
Königreich zu verwalten, brauchst du irgendwie
zwei Ladezeiten und zwei Ladezeiten zurück.
So, das ist ein bisschen blöd.
Wow.
Was ist das?
Eine Hydra.
Tja, ist die Frage.
Kann das Ding was?
Oder kann das Ding nichts?
Amiri macht das jetzt.
Barb Rage, sonst brauchen wir nichts.
Komm, Bardsong können wir noch anmachen.
Da haben wir eh genug.
Bam, bashen.
Kann nichts.
Kann überhaupt nichts.
Und das
ist schon schwierig, ein Schwierigkeitsgrad.
Wie man sich
da beschweren kann, dass das Game zu schwer ist, ich weiß
nicht. Es wäre die erste
Hydra, die nichts kann. Da siehst du mal.
Du hast, hier hast du es zuerst
gesehen. Die erste Hydra, die nichts kann.
Mir wurde mal sowas von geschreckt
gerade.
Kein Kinder gibt es in dem Game nicht.
Ich glaube, ich bin auch ein bisschen zu
zu overleveln für Akt 2.
Ich bin schon
Level 8.
Ich habe halt alles an Quests gemacht, bevor ich die Mainquest gemacht habe.
Und ich könnte mir
vorstellen, dass diese Encounter
quasi auf dem Weg jetzt zur
Mainquest
sogar gescriptet sind für
Solo-Held, für welche, die ihre
Gruppe halt nicht mitnehmen, weil da steht,
man soll alleine gehen.
Ich gehe da jetzt aber trotzdem mit
meiner Gruppe rein, weil
ich habe jetzt eigentlich gar nicht
vor, die Nymphe zu bangen,
sondern, äh,
gucken, was da so abgeht.
Ich gehe da erst mal
mit der Gruppe reingucken.
Und sollte es halt gar nicht gehen,
dann lasse ich
meine Gruppe am Eingang stehen
und gehe dann alleine hin.
Das ist
wie ein Schneesturm, nur heiß.
Kein Spaß
mit der Nymphe.
Naja, nachdem in der Quest-Beschreibung drinnen steht, ich soll
Unsichtbarkeitstränke mitnehmen,
gehe ich mal nicht davon aus, dass es dazu kommen wird.
Ich gehe eher davon aus,
dass die Nymphe mich bashen will.
Spielst du noch Overwatch?
Nein.
Aktuell nicht. Und ich glaube auch in nächster Zeit nicht.
Sag mal, kann das sein, dass ich irgendwie
einen Host oder so übersehen habe vorhin?
Oh, nice.
Mein Mammut läuft da oben drauf.
Wieso nicht? Ähm,
also,
da lasse ich mich am Endeffekt jeden Stream
einmal drüber aus, was mit Overwatch ist.
Ähm,
also, zum einen mal,
weil ich finde, dass das Ranking-System
immer noch unter aller Sau ist.
Ich finde es nicht gut,
wie Blizzard die Competitive-Szene handelt,
außer der Overwatch-League.
Und die Overwatch-League ist
ja nur unbestreitbar relativ erfolgreich,
aber das war halt auch so ein Ding,
das war schon zu groß, um zu failen,
im Endeffekt.
Also egal, wie viel Geld man da reinstecken muss.
Also ich soll mich mal angucken, wie das mit
2 und Nachwuchs-Geschichten aussieht.
Overwatch ist halt auch nix.
Ähm,
ja, aber zum Spiel selbst muss ich sagen,
der Rank-Modus gefällt mir immer noch nicht.
Ich finde die, ähm,
Spielmodi
sowas wie 2CP ist immer noch
eklig.
Die Helden fokussieren sich teilweise
immer noch nicht
so sehr, wie ich mir das wünschen würde,
auf eben Mechanics, sondern auf
Timing,
Gimmicks und
ja, der Glück
kann man nicht wirklich sagen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie man, wie soll man das beschreiben
in Overwatch? Also, sagen wir mal so,
so ein Held wie Brigitte zum Beispiel,
oder wie Reinhardt.
Die sind jetzt ja beide nicht die
wahnsinns,
ähm,
Mechanic-mäßig, also du musst jetzt da
nicht das God-Aim haben,
oder, ähm,
du brauchst dafür eigentlich nur
ein Glück im
Matchmaking, dass das gut funktioniert mit Reinhardt.
Und halt, äh, Timing,
und du musst
halt den gegnerischen Reinhardt outplayen, so.
Es ist, es ist schwierig zu erklären, irgendwie,
wie...
Wow, da ist Zeug.
Also, es kann mir halt keiner sagen, dass
man beispielsweise für Mercy
so viel Skill bräuchte, wie in, sagen wir mal, CS.
Oder sowas.
Ich, ich will jetzt nicht sagen,
dass...
Kann man hier rumklettern?
Kommt man da überhaupt hin, wenn man hier langklettert?
I shall end this suffering.
Ja, genau, der Jawsender
sagt das. Das, so sehe ich das auch.
Also Helden, die kein Skill brauchen, das
trifft's im Endeffekt. Weil, es ist
nicht so, dass man für Mercy, oder
für Reinhardt oder so, Mercy ist für mich das negative
Beispiel, schlechthin.
Dass man dafür nix, also so
gar nix können muss, trifft es nicht.
Aber, es ist halt nichts, was
wie es sein sollte, aus
meiner Sicht halt.
Na, also ich finde, es sollte
ein gewisses Outplay-
Potential da sein,
bei den meisten Helden, einfach
wenn man sie gut beherrscht.
Und das ist halt bei vielen Sachen nicht so.
Bei vielen Helden ist es halt im Prinzip
egal, wie gut du spielst, weil's
relativ schnell vom Level her vorbei ist,
wo du halt was besser
reißen kannst als der Gegner.
Und es hängt einfach nur noch komplett davon ab,
wie du im Matchmaking
Okay, ich muss doch alleine rein.
Wie du im Matchmaking zusammengewürfelt wirst.
Und dann
du hast halt auch so krassen Unterschied.
Was ich halt auch übelst, übelst fail
finde, ähm
dass du,
dass du so'n, so'n, so'n
riesen
Differenz hast in Overwatch. Also du hast
beispielsweise Leute, die, nennen wir mal Genji,
weil da Joseon grad am Start ist, ja,
oder nehmen wir Tracer, oder zum Teil
noch irgendwas, hast du noch irgendwie
die Sombra zum Teil ja auch noch, oder
was sind, was sind denn noch so die
Hanzo zum Treffen, das ist halt, ja du hast
also sowas wie Tracer zum Beispiel, oder Genji, das sind halt
Helden, die schwierig zu spielen sind,
die auch hohen Impact haben, und du hast halt
sowas dann gepaart mit Mercy.
Also du hast auf der einen Seite so den, so den
One-Button-Heal-Char,
der aber teilweise über lange
Strecken in Overwatch komplett unverzichtbar ist,
ähm, du hast sowas hier
wie Brigitte, die dich Nahkampf-Stunt einfach
mal so mit einer Taste, und
dazu hast du dann quasi sowas wie
High-Skill-Tracer. Das passt irgendwie
nicht zusammen, und das ist das, was mir auch so ein bisschen
gepaart mit dem Matchmaking, dass du überhaupt
nichts mit, ähm,
dem zu tun hat, wie Overwatch eigentlich gespielt
werden sollte, nämlich
im Team, ähm, gefällt's mir einfach
nicht. Ich, ich, ich, ich hab ja ehrlich
gesagt Blizzard zugetraut,
das zu verbessern, aber irgendwie tut's statt.
Deswegen...
Warum dauert das Wechsel meiner Gruppe
drei Tage? Kann ich nicht einfach
sagen, Jungs, hier Valerie, Amiri,
Lindsay, bleibt mal kurz
stehen, ich geh jetzt kurz die, kurz die
Nymphe bangen und komm wieder zurück?
Das geht nicht. Nein, ich muss die Gruppe
wechseln, drei Tage lang.
WTF.
So.
Wir haben jetzt drei Tage gewartet.
Nice, so muss das sein.
Aber mein Mammut kommt mit, oder?
Mein Mammut
darf bestimmt mit. Ja, nice,
mein Mammut ist dabei. So, so
mag ich das. So, wir
speichern jetzt erstmal hier, wer weiß, was da jetzt gleich
kommt. Vor der Mainquest kann man immer mal
speichern. Ich lass
meinen Mammut mal vorlaufen, falls
da Fallen sind oder so.
Ne. Vielleicht hätte ich mal
reingehen sollen.
Okay, ähm, wir laden
nochmal neu und gehen erstmal,
wir gehen, wir gehen nochmal rein in die Festung.
Erstmal gucken, was da drin ist,
bevor ich da mit meinem, bevor ich da mit meinem
Held rumstelze.
Was ist denn deiner Meinung nach der
größte OP-Hero eins und eins,
Brigitte? Also
von, so von Skill zu
äh, Passion ist Brigitte.
Brigitta
heißt sie ja, glaube ich.
Das ist auch der dümmste Held überhaupt.
Drücke Knopf für
Instance-Stun.
Achso, ach, meinst du, meinst du One-on-One,
ähm, ach, du meinst diesen
One-on-One-Modus. Boah, hab ich
nie gespielt.
Ähm, ich vermute mal sowas
wie Roadhog ist übelst geil, weil er sich
heilen kann in diesem One-on-One-Modus.
Ich rate jetzt einfach mal, ne, hab ich nie gespielt.
Also alles mit Self-Heal dürfte
da wahrscheinlich übertrieben geil sein, also sowas
wie Soldier
oder, oder halt eben Roadhog.
Roadhog vor allem auch noch wegen dem Burst-Potential.
Wobei, ich hab gelesen, Roadhog wurde genervt,
da, da killt jetzt nichts mehr im Endeffekt.
Der beste Held
in der Offensive, ähm,
Tracer.
Würde ich sagen.
Beste Held in der Offensive, wenn man jetzt nicht
grade Goats oder sowas spielt, ähm,
würd
ich sagen Tracer, äh, Tracer
und Genji aus dem Grund,
weil man da sehr viel
reißen kann durch
gutes Spielen.
Wow!
Oh, ich glaub, das kann ich auch nicht entschärfen, oder?
Gut, Leute, ich hätte hier nicht mit meinem Team
wieder reingehen müssen.
Da gibt's nämlich nix drin.
Dann machen wir jetzt die Mainquest
mit der Nymphe. Mal gucken, was da so abgeht.
Am besten find ich das Torb
reworked. Was haben sie denn reworked?
Hab ich nicht geguckt.
Ich wusste gar nicht, wie gesagt,
ich hab mich ewig nicht mehr so wirklich mit Overwatch beschäftigt,
seitdem ich kein Interesse mehr hab, das selbst irgendwie zu spielen.
Was haben sie denn reworked?
So, Nymphe.
Was geht?
Wo ist die Nymphe?
In den Gemüchern
der Nymphe ist niemand. Vielleicht zeigt
sie sich, wenn der Baron, so wie vereinbart,
alleine betritt. Ja.
Wo ist die Nymphe?
Muss ich vielleicht meinen Mammut
auch noch wegschicken?
Ach nee, die kommt bestimmt,
wenn ich den Baum untersuche.
Sonst wär da nicht umsonst ne Lupe am Baum.
Mammut, komm runter.
Level 2 Turret default.
Kein Level 3 Turret mehr.
Ist das schon live, der rework?
Weil ich hab vorhin da frangeguckt
und da haben wir
noch Torb mit
Hammer
angesagt.
Turret kann er werfen?
Fuck. Blizzard, please.
Come on, brah.
Okay, Nymphe.
Aber Mammut hat das jetzt ausgelöst.
Ach gut.
Wow.
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Ich wurde reingelegt.
Damit hätte man ja gar nicht rechnen können.
Voice Acting.
Wir haben Voice Acting.
Was leider viel zu
wenige Dialoge in dem Spiel haben.
Ich habe euch geholfen.
Es liegt keine Ehre in einem Angriff auf mich.
Genau. Ehrenlose Nymphe.
So sehe ich das auch.
Don't blame me. Blame the Coronet
Hast du Hammond gespielt, ne?
Yes, have I seen countries
and kingdoms arise from the dust.
Only to fall into dust
once more.
Thus will it be with your barony.
For what is a barony
without its baron?
This is how it must be.
The stolen lands will remain
no ones, die all run.
There is nothing you can change.
Doch, ich kann nicht bashen.
Wow.
Ah, das ist ja noch eine junge Hydra.
Das ist ja...
Ich kann ja gar nichts.
Alle beide, das ist schlecht.
Tiefschlaf.
Au.
The fuck.
Reload.
Ich stehe scheiße.
Ich muss weiter oben stehen.
Ich wollte gerade sagen,
hat sich meine Quest gerade auf grün
geschaltet durchs Reload.
Okay.
Da oben passiert mir nichts.
Mein Mammut geht auch mal hier hoch.
So.
Und mein Mammut redet mit der Nymphe wieder.
Oh, you did come. Don't blame him.
Blablabla.
Okay.
Oh, es attackiert
mich direkt.
Mammut, druff.
Bam.
Die können ja gar nichts.
Die können ja gar nichts, die Viecher.
Gebashed.
Was haben wir hier unten? Hier unten war doch auch irgendwas.
Ich stell's
mich da mal kurz hin.
Gucken, was da unten
war. Übrigens, in dem Game
kann man keine Kamera... Oh, ein Bär.
Kann man keine Kamera drehen,
weil die Hintergründe statisch sind. Ein Bär.
Ein Eulenbär.
Das waren die Dinger, wo wir
vorher mit der kompletten Party gegen drei
Gegner Probleme hatten.
Den lasse ich mal
in Ruhe.
Fortnite beste.
Spielst du Fortnite Chosen? Aha.
Was sagst du zu Blackout?
So. Machen wir das Viech hier nochmal kaputt.
Gucken, ob das ein bisschen mehr kann.
Wir haben so viele
Zauber. Das ist kompletter Easy Mode
hier. Da habe ich
gerade meinen Mammut gebashed.
Wie viel Leben hat mein Mammut
noch? 55. Easy.
Weiß nicht,
wie die Nymphe sich das gedacht hat,
aber so einfach wird Baron Max
nicht gebashed.
Heute.
Die Gruppe leidet unter schwerer Belastung.
Ist das so?
Jetzt läuft er nicht mehr, der Max.
Der Max muss irgendwas ablegen.
Irgendeine Rüstung, die ich
nicht mehr brauche.
Irgendwas schweres.
Kann ich ja nachher
wieder aufsammeln.
Lederrüstung ablegen.
Ich habe gerade genug.
So, gucken wir mal, ob wir den Bär noch gebashed kriegen.
Das machen wir jetzt aber
anders. Wir
blenden den Bär.
Nice. Der Bär ist geblendet.
Jetzt schicken wir das
Mammut auf den Bär.
Und dann sprayen.
Dann sprayen wir noch
den Bär an.
So.
Angesprayt.
Jetzt wird er umgenugt, der Bär.
Der Bär ist
übrigens geblendet.
Fuck.
Ich muss nochmal laden.
Das hat nicht so gut funktioniert.
Was ist denn der beste
Held, um hart zu bashen?
Ja, was spielst du denn am liebsten? Support? DPS?
Off-Tank? Tank?
Was ist so
deine Lieblings
Rolle?
Also den pauschalen Held
zum am besten bashen
kann man jetzt so nicht sagen. Vor allem, wenn man neu in dem Game ist.
Mein Mammut hat immer noch einen Debuff drauf.
Und man sieht ja nicht, welchen Debuff.
Das ist natürlich...
ziemlich kacke.
Irgendeinen Debuff hat mein Mammut noch drauf.
Also, ich meine, ich kann
den... ich kann den Bär blenden...
äh, erplinden lassen.
Ich meine, da kann er doch eigentlich gar nichts mehr treffen. Großartig.
So.
Fuck.
Der hat übertriebenes Damage.
Das ist der OP-Bär, ja.
Es kann natürlich auch sein, dass ich überhaupt nicht
lang muss, sondern hier oben.
Ich meine, wir sind ja vorhin hier oben lang gelaufen, ne.
Da hat man ja gesehen, man kann hier
neben runter irgendwo.
Das probieren wir mal.
Ich probiere den Bär noch einmal zu bashen.
Ob das funktioniert.
Ich hab leider nicht so viele Self-Buffs.
Weil ich dafür mein...
Weil ich dafür mein Bade hab, eigentlich.
So, wir sammeln dir Brigitte und bashen ihn.
Das wär natürlich nice, wenn das funktioniert.
Oh, ich habe eine Idee.
Ich habe doch den Teleport-Zauber.
Ja, nice. Ich teleportiere mich einfach weg.
Lull.
Natürlich workt der like that.
Du musst einfach draufschießen.
Ich hätte Haze zuerst casten müssen.
Oh Mann, nicht stumm.
Sag mal.
The fuck?
Scheiß Bär.
OP-Bär.
Ich teleportiere den Bär jetzt einfach weg.
Kann ich den Bär teleportieren?
Äh.
So war das nicht gedacht.
Ich wollte mich nicht in das Face vom Bär teleportieren,
sondern ich wollte den Bär teleportieren.
War nicht in Ordnung.
Ich bin bereit.
Für diesen Kackbär bashen.
Ja.
Fokus auf das Ziel.
Wir rennen jetzt erstmal weg von dem Viech.
Okay, mein Mammut will da unbedingt hinrennen.
Vergiss es.
Der Bär ist nicht zu bashen.
Das war nicht so.
Ne, vergess, der Bär geht nicht.
Kannst du nicht noch was sammeln?
Nein, ich hab nix.
Ich hab nix zum Beschwören.
Das ist, da ist meine Klasse nicht für gedacht.
Oh, da oben stellst du was.
Ich glaube, ich muss hier oben lang.
Ich glaube, ich muss, also ich vermute mal, wir haben uns das Gebiet ja vorhin angeguckt.
Ich denke einfach mal, dass ich hier oben lang muss und dann hier runter muss.
Das geht ja.
Die Gegner hier oben sind bestimmt einfacher zu bashen.
Wahrscheinlich soll ich den Bär gar nicht bashen.
Oh, da oben kommt noch mehr.
Fax, caste!
Ich dachte, es rennt jetzt weg, wenn ich da vier drauf caste.
Ah, piss dich!
Piss dich!
OKS.
Nice.
Mammut OP.
Was denkst du, wie wird es jetzt?
Wird sich der Battlefield-5-Battle-Royale-Modus gegen Blackout ausschlagen?
Gar nicht.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass der Battlefield-5-Battle-Royale-Modus der übelste Reinfall wird,
weil das Ding in einer Nichtwahl mit Release erscheint.
Es hat, es hat auf jeden Fall richtig viel Potenzial,
einfach weil Battle Royale angesagt ist und Battlefield ein gutes Game ist im Kern immer,
aber ich glaube, das werden sie so verkacken wie in Curse.
Alter, wie er jetzt langschleicht.
Informatik studieren mit einer 4 in Mathe.
Warum denn nicht?
Aber auf was war das, war das die Antwort?
Wer hat was geschrieben?
Weil, ich kann nur sagen,
ähm,
oder auch Mathe studieren oder sowas.
Oder auch, weil ich von Leuten höre, die Mathe studieren.
Ähm,
das, was man in der Schule gemacht hat,
ist nicht wirklich relevant.
Das macht man im ersten Halm.
Ja, oder so, dann noch mal.
Und erst ein paar Wochen.
Das ist aber kein Mammut.
Richtig, das ist ein Mastodon.
Wo ich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht wusste, dass es da Unterschiede gibt.
Was?
Rotkäppchen, geh weg.
Lass mich in Ruhe!
Boah, boah.
Hypermonker, er ist, äh,
das war knapp.
Kann man den Bär von hier oben,
von hier oben,
von hier oben bashen?
Aha, ein Mastodon kam vor allem in Nordamerika vor
und ist kleiner als ein Mammut.
Okay.
Tja, aber irgendwie geht mir Mammut einfacher von den Lippen
als ein Mastodon.
Äh, wo rennst du hin?
Max, wo rennst du hin?
Hä?
Egal.
Ich weiß nicht, woran er hinrennt.
Wir hüpfen jetzt hier runter.
Wir hüpfen jetzt hier runter und gehen aus dem Gebiet raus.
Dann holen wir unsere Party und bashen diesen Kackbeet.
Der Bär weg.
Der Bär wird dis-destroyed.
Ich hab kaum Beweglichkeit, ne?
Schön auf die Fresse geflogen erst mal.
Ich mein, es ist ja auch kein Wunder, ne?
Wenn man sich hier mal meine Attribute anguckt.
Beweglichkeit minus eins.
Zack.
Was hab ich denn, was hab ich denn gewürfelt?
Na, immerhin.
Wenn ich dann keine 17 geworfen hätte,
wäre ich wahrscheinlich gar nicht runtergekommen.
Ready for anything?
Alter, nix wie weg.
So, raus hier.
Weg.
Die Nymphe hat mich debatet.
So, und jetzt wird, jetzt, Leute,
jetzt wird Party eingepackt, sag ich euch.
Und dann werden die so weggeklatscht,
dieser komische Bär.
Party.
So, komm her.
Valerie rein.
Lindsay rein.
Tristan rein.
Amiri rein.
Lindsay rein.
Tristan rein.
Ranger rein.
Wie heißt der eigentlich nochmal?
Ich hab mir die Namen von allen, außer vom Ranger, gemerkt, irgendwie.
Erstmal speichern.
Campen.
Wir campen ne Runde.
Hoffen, dass das Essen funktioniert.
Haha.
Jetzt haben wir Essen-Bonus.
Und da wird gebasht.
Ich hab kaum...
Äh, egal.
Also mit vollem Team werden wir diesen komischen Bär jetzt noch erstmal wegkriegen, oder?
Your face, Bär.
Der Bär.
Der Bär wird weggeklatscht.
Wo?
Was ist das?
Äh...
Okay, erstmal meine ganzen Stoffis weg.
Okay, es war nie gedacht hier rauszugehen.
Weil hier wär der Ausgang gewesen.
Das heißt, selbst, wenn ich den Bär gebasht hätte, wär ich hier nie alleine dran vorbei gekommen.
Nie.
Valerie ist drauf.
Amiri ist auch drauf.
Gut.
Die, äh, mit versammelter Mannschaft kriegen wir die wahrscheinlich.
Haste.
Haste auf die Tanks.
Schreckt!
So.
Als nächstes kommt der Bär.
Der Bär kommt noch mit laufendem Haste.
Wird er gebasht?
Jetzt geht der aufs Maul, der Bär.
Mann.
Also die Kamera ist schon ein bisschen beknackt.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Kamera!
Please!
Aha.
Was macht man eigentlich, wenn man jetzt kein, äh, Widescreen, also kein Monitor hat,
wenn man so was auf dem Bildschirm hat?
Dann ist das schon ein bisschen...
Das ist ein bisschen...
Wenn man also kein Äh, Widescreen, also kein Monitor hat der eine Auflösung, eine hohe
Auflösung hat, dann wird das hier mit Anklicken nix.
So.
Weggeklatscht haben wir also.
Was lernen wir daraus?
Man besucht keine Nymphen alleine.
So sieht's aus.
Zwar ich mein, allein schon wie die Quest geschrieben war, äh war klar dass, dass da
jetzt irgendwie Hinterhalten angesagt ist.
Übrigens witzigerweise in der Quest-Beschreibung stand ja, man soll unbedingt Unsichtbarkeitstränke
mitnehmen. Ich hatte meinen Mammut
dabei. Ich brauche keinen Unsicherkeitsdrang.
Äh.
Wo geht denn die Mainquest jetzt weiter?
Ich habe keine Quests
mehr. Okay, wir gucken
jetzt nochmal kurz in den Tempel rein, ob das da jetzt ein bisschen
anders aussieht drinnen.
Ob man da jetzt was machen kann.
Es ist schon 17.30 Uhr. Ich habe Hunger.
Uptime.
Wie lange bin ich denn online?
3 Stunden 26 Minuten.
So, schicken wir mal
das Mammut vor.
What?
Ich stehe am Arsch der Welt.
WTF?
Was ist das?
Da reicht 0.3D nicht.
Da brauchen wir 0.4D.
Debated.
The fuck?
Vor allem Level up zu
minus 3. Das ist übertrieben.
Minus 5. Das ist übertrieben.
Krass.
Verschlossen.
Habe ich da irgendwie
einen Schlüssel drinnen gefunden?
Fuck.
Okay, das bringt überhaupt
0 hier rein zu gehen. Das bringt gar nichts.
Komplett
debated. Gut, dann
gehen wir jetzt hier raus und gehen in die Hauptstadt.
Weil ich denke mal, dass es da mit der Quest weiter geht.
Weil ich habe nichts mehr.
Das hier sind die Verwaltungsquests.
Die haben mit der normalen Story nichts zu tun.
Also, ne, diese Quest, die ich in der Hauptstadt machen kann, mit meinen Untertanen da, das hat mit der Mainquest nichts zu tun.
Übrigens, bei der Gelegenheit, müssen wir mal sagen, das Spiel sieht echt gut aus.
Das hat schöne Zaubereffekte, schöne Beleuchtung, es ist ein schönes Wettersystem, also das Spiel sieht wirklich hübsch aus.
Ist übrigens ein Unity-Game, weil da gerne auf Unity rumgeflamed wird.
Also, das Spiel sieht wirklich hübsch aus. Ist übrigens ein Unity-Game, weil da gerne auf Unity rumgeflamed wird.
Was gibt's hier denn?
Wir können jetzt einfach mal weitergehen und hier
gucken, was es da gibt.
Weil es gibt hier auch nirgendswo neue Quests.
Es gibt gar nix.
Oder wir sollen echt da hin.
Wir gehen jetzt erstmal rüber.
Wir gehen jetzt erstmal hier weiter und gucken uns das an.
Aber vorher campen wir noch eine Runde.
Du hast mitbekommen, dass beim neuen iPhone das
Hasst du mitbekommen, dass beim neuen iPhone das
bei manchen geräten nicht funktionieren aber ich meine wenn schon das laden
nicht funktioniert also quasi eines der besten sachen was was ist eigentlich
kack wort basic also eines der grundlegendsten sachen
smartphone weiß ich auch nicht ich kann hier nicht direkt hinlaufen warum nicht
das ist schon schwach also das ist laden bei einem handy nicht funktioniert ist
schon ja biegt sich dann wenigstens das hat er schon tradition
okay wird den bogey hier oben müssen wir beschäftigen darf der hund machen oder
drüben sind auch welche dann darf das mein mammut machen
man auf der mammut über trampe jetzt schatz da guckt euch an dass der
charts mammut achtung
und
die werden geschnetzelt die wurden geschn latent schreckt messen tract
übrigens man kann bevor beim gebiet verlässt auch luthen be cohren deswegen
muss man nicht von den gegnern hin rennen
da kann man alles tun ja was apple das macht ich ganz ehrlich
gesagt auch nur zum teil nachvollziehen warum man sich den neues iphone kauft ich
hab selbst ein iphone naja
Wenn es um Tablets geht, muss ich sagen, kommt Android noch nicht mal close an iOS.
Ich habe, nicht, dass ich jetzt Mist erzähle, ich habe hier mittlerweile, ich glaube, 5 Tablets,
einen Nvidia Shield, so ein IBM Ding, einen Asus Android Ding,
einen iPad und einen Tegra 7 und noch einen Shield.
So, eigentlich 6 Tablets, WTF, warum eigentlich, Max? Ich weiß es auch selbst nicht.
Und ich muss sagen, im Tablet-Bereich not even close, iOS-Beste.
Im Smartphone-Bereich, muss ich sagen, würde ich der Sache prinzipiell auch zustimmen.
Ach ja, übrigens bei Tablets, sobald man was...
was basteln will, ja, was automatisieren will oder ein bisschen was Technischeres machen will,
ist auch, da ist umgedreht, not even close für iOS, da ist Android eindeutig das Beste.
Allerdings, die Preispolitik, was Smartphones angeht, von Apple,
ist mittlerweile komplett jenseits irgendwie der Vorstellungskraft von vor ein paar Jahren.
Plus, dass sie so ganz merkwürdige Design-Entscheidungen treffen,
wie,
kein Kopfhörerausgang mehr.
Oder wenn man sich bei den neuen MacBooks diese komische LED-Leiste oben anguckt,
die sie anstatt von Funktionstasten reingemacht haben und sowas,
da habe ich oftmals das Gefühl, die stehen sich selbst im Weg
und machen es quasi durch ihren Design-Wahn, es quasi möglichst innovativ designen zu wollen,
schlechter benutzbar.
Und vom Preis muss man gar nicht reden, ich sehe es nicht ein,
ein Drittel, ein halbes, bei manchen Leuten ein ganzes Monatsgehalt für ein High-End-Smartphone auszugeben.
Ganz ehrlich, das sehe ich nicht ein.
Hallo, ich will eigentlich dahin, ne?
Ich will zum Sonnenbuckel.
Windows Phone, FD.
Windows Phone ist tot.
Sagt sogar Microsoft.
Windows Phone ist hinüber.
Geschichte.
Vorbei.
Matsch.
Oh.
Ich dachte erst, es ist ein Drache.
Oh, da kommen noch mehr.
Äh, du gehst...
Du gehst dahin, du gehst dahin, du machst Bardsong.
Amiri, du machst Rage.
Du bist immerhin ein Barb.
Und der Clary macht mal ne Bless.
Sag mal, hat Amiri gerade Levelabzug gekriegt?
Kann das sein?
Na gut, man muss ja einfach rasten, dann geht das wieder weg.
Oh, die Dinger machen Damage.
Oh, die Dinger machen krass Damage.
Ich glaube, dieses Gebiet sollte ich nur nicht.
Kann das sein?
Alter.
Okay, so viel Damage machen die gar nicht.
Ich hätte vielleicht zaubern sollen.
Okay, das nächste Mal mache ich das anders.
Falls ich jetzt verrecke, machen wir das anders.
Wenn man die Magiedamage nimmt, die nehme ich ordentlich, wie es aussieht.
Ähm.
Ja, ich sag mal...
Oh, Moment, Moment.
Gift?
Ach, die hat Gift.
Äh, Clary?
Wo bist du?
Clary?
Äh.
Ich werde überleben.
Ich werde immer überleben.
So, jetzt müssen wir warten, bis das Gift abgelaufen ist.
Und dann müssen wir nochmal rasten.
Und wir müssen mal irgendwann mal Mammut heilen wieder.
iPhone 6s.
Ich habe auch ein iPhone 6s.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind, weil ich es nicht eingesehen habe die letzten Jahre über auch.
Was, äh, was selbst zu kaufen, ein neueres.
Okay, nice.
Dann würde ich sagen, campen wir mal ne Runde.
Oh, Story Mode.
Blablabla.
Der Voice Actor von Tristan, der spricht schon so erhaben immer.
Sind wir gehealt?
Wir sind gehealt.
Okay, Amiri muss noch, muss noch ne Runde, ne Runde ausruhen.
Alter, die ist gest...
Ich will einfach nur ruhen.
Ich brauche keine Story.
Einlagen gerade.
Blablabla.
Ist immer noch nicht.
Ja, egal.
Das können wir da im Zweifelsfall in der Hauptstadt wieder heilen.
Ich frage mich viel mehr, was für einen Debuff mein Mammut hat.
Das, ähm...
Und der hat auch übelste Debuffs.
Die Pets müssen wir dann mal, mal healen lassen in der Hauptstadt, würde ich sagen.
Es wäre halt schön, wenn man bei den Pets sehen würde, was sie für Debuffs drauf haben.
Weil ich meine, bei meinen Charakteren sehe ich sie.
Ja, genau.
Da sehe ich es, ja.
Aber bei den Pets sehe ich es halt nicht.
Minus zwei andere.
Keine Ahnung.
Man weiß es nicht, ne?
Wie sieht es eigentlich mit Level Up aus?
Och, das dauert noch ein bisschen.
Jetzt darf ich da rein.
So.
Nachdem das quasi highlightet wurde bei der Main Quest, vielleicht geht es ja da weiter.
Ansonsten, wenn es bei der...
Wenn es da jetzt nicht weitergeht mit der Main Quest...
Dann...
Gehen wir zurück in...
Was ist das?
The fuck?
Ah, reden wir mal mit dem Pferd.
Will nicht.
Okay, die Map ist auch nicht allzu groß.
Ein Händler ruft um Hilfe.
Moment, wir müssen erstmal Loot checken.
Danach komme ich zur Hilfe.
Erstmal Loot checken.
Okay, ist nix.
Soll so sein.
Das soll sein.
Oh!
Okay, Händler, was gibt's?
Ein beleibter Mann mittleren Halters.
Und jetzt fühle ich mich aber offendet.
Wer seid ihr?
Was ist hier passiert?
Äh, was haben wir so zur Auswahl?
Haltet durch, ich helfe euch.
Wir sind ja gut.
Äh, Athletik...
Athletik haben wir Amiri am Start.
Die kann diesen Felsen nicht lassen.
Die kann diesen Fail eigentlich kaum.
Das ist ein unglaublich dummer Bluff.
Ja, neutral gut.
Amiri, du machst das.
Wenn wir eine 0 oder eine 1 würfeln, verkacken wir es.
Aber wir können es, eigentlich statistisch gesehen, können wir es nicht verkacken.
Okay.
Amiri hat einen runtergeholt.
Es hilft mir von euch.
Was genau, das habe ich doch schon alles gefragt.
Moin, Gimpling.
Wie nannten sie diesen Turm gleich nochmal?
Ich habe euch geholt.
Wo ist meine Belohnung?
Wo finde ich das Fehlwesen, das euch das angetan hat?
Oh.
Ist das das Pferd oder was?
Ne.
Oh, was ist das?
Das sieht aus, als muss man das bashen und es ist...
Oh, zwei Stück.
Äh, scheint mir...
Drei Stück.
Scheint mir gefährlich zu sein.
Okay.
Okay, ähm...
Erstes Mal drehen wir uns um.
So, danach...
Blast vom Clary.
Bardsong an.
Haste von Azorg.
Amiri macht Rage an.
Valerie macht Defensivkämpfen aus.
Die kann ruhig ein bisschen Damage machen.
Der Hund geht da drauf, weil irgendwo brauchen wir ein bisschen was.
Valerie kann das ja tanken.
Und der Max, der castet und macht kaputt.
Ja.
Amiri, du kannst hier mit draufhauen.
Tristan hat Feuerdamage, das ist bestimmt ganz gut dafür.
Okay.
Ach, die können nix.
Jetzt schreckt.
Easy.
Easy Clap.
Easiest Clap.
Eine winzige Frau mit dunklem Haar und einer blassen...
Ja.
Story.
Hallo, der Chef, HB.
Der Chief, HB.
Ähm...
Bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla.
Warum?
Einschüchtern 35...
Oh, oh, oh.
Das, ähm...
Diesen Check werden wir wahrscheinlich verlieren.
Ich meine, ich hab Einschüchtern plus 19.
Na, wobei...
Ähm, wir müssten...
Wir müssten halt 16...
Wir müssten halt 16 würfeln, was relativ unwahrscheinlich ist.
Ich probier's mal.
Ah, fuck.
Oh.
So viel zu Dialogoptionen.
Wonka S.
Das war, glaube ich, keine so gute Idee, diesen Check jetzt zu fällen.
Ich brauch einen Tank.
Tank, Valerie.
Alter, ich brauch irgendwas, der meine Stoffe...
Die ist hier verteidigt.
Tristan zaubert mal Segen.
Oh, fuck.
Max, weg.
Scheiße, das sind zu viele.
Max, wo rennst du hin?
Weg.
Tristan, weg.
Scheiße.
Ah, das wird nix.
Die kam ja wirklich von allen Seiten.
Das ist lame.
Okay, Valerie, du kannst hier...
Du kannst...
Du kannst uns...
Du kannst unserem Ranger helfen.
Der Clary kann mal heilen, ne Runde.
58 hat er jetzt.
Krass.
58 Channels bekommt er das her.
Das wird ja immer mehr.
58?
Warum hat er auf einmal 58 Channels?
Hab ich...
Ist das verbuggt oder was?
Vorhin hatte er noch 38 oder so.
Ich mein, ich will nix sagen, ja.
Das ist schon in Ordnung.
58 mal Channeln?
Das kann nicht stimmen, oder?
Vielleicht weil er...
...inspiriert ist durch den Bart-Song?
Fuck, der Ranger ist down.
Sonst hätte ich's geschafft.
Oh!
Äh...
Ich glaube, das geht in die Hose.
Ich hätte direkt auf den draufschicken sollen.
Das Mammut...
Mammut geht ab, Alter!
Das Beschworene killen wir nicht.
Wir killen den Beschwörer.
Das ist viel besser.
Amiri, kill den Beschwörer.
Ich glaube, ich habe noch eine Schriftrolle für Totenbeleben dabei.
Magst du, dann machst du mal wieder YouTube-Videos.
Sobald es Games gibt, die mir gefallen.
Wartet mal kurz.
So.
Ähm.
Ich hoffe, ich habe noch die Schriftrolle zum Wiederbeleben dabei.
Kann mein Clary auf Range irgendwas machen, außer Feuerball?
Nice, die kriegt die Frist-Damage.
Und Amiri basht die jetzt weg.
Oh, Rippen-Mammut.
Lindsay, du wolltest Bardsong spielen.
Warum machst du das nicht?
Nice.
Da geht er down.
Okay.
Ich hoffe, ich habe noch eine Wiederbelebungsrolle dabei.
Weil sonst...
Äh...
Ist schlecht.
Sonst muss ich den Scheiß nochmal machen.
Sieht nicht so aus, oder?
Doch!
Nice.
Ich speichere mal, weil nicht, dass mein Clary das jetzt verkackt.
Da ist er wieder.
It's...
Oh, Looten.
Federrüstung.
Da-da.
Sonst was.
Nächster.
Das da.
So.
Ähm.
Looten.
Wo ist der Zwerg eigentlich hin?
Da ist er.
Rippen-Mammut.
Schon wieder.
Hallo?
Looten?
Lüten?
Also wirklich was dabei hat die jetzt nicht zum Looten.
Okay, hab ich irgendwas vergessen zu Looten?
Nicht wirklich.
Das hat aber dick...
...dick XP gegeben, das Ganze.
Ja.
Das Ding hat dick XP gegeben.
Massive.
Huge XP Boost.
Huge.
Massively huge.
Das heilt ja mal gar nichts.
Ich kann einfach meine...
...56 Channels verwenden.
Das ist doch ein Bug, oder?
Warum hab ich 56 Channels?
Das stimmt doch net.
I'm listening.
56?
Vorher hatte ich 30 oder so.
Wie gesagt, ich will mich da nicht beschweren.
Aber das ist schon ganz schön viel.
Will mir der Händler nicht was anbieten zum Handeln.
Mein Tristan auf Stufe 5 hat 8.
Ich hatte...
Ja, ich hatte am Anfang auch...
...nicht so viel, deswegen hab ich 200...
...ich hab ja dreimal...
...ich hab ja dreimal zusätzlich Fokussieren genommen.
Das gibt insgesamt nochmal 6 Stück.
Dann hab ich nen Ring, der...
...zwei, acht.
So, und dann pro Level...
...also sagen wir mal so 30 oder so.
Ey, lass ich mir ja irgendwie noch gefallen.
Ah, 53?
Da stimmt doch irgendwas nicht, oder?
Ach ja, und ich hab noch, ähm...
...Weisheitsbonus.
Der macht natürlich auch ein bisschen...
...aber, hä?
Ich weiß auch...keine Ahnung.
OP, Tristan.
Ich weiß nicht, warum der so viel hat.
So, wir lagern mal ne Runde.
Mal gucken, wie viel er dann hat, ob sich das wieder reset hat.
Ähm...
Wie viel Uhr haben wir jetzt? 18 Uhr?
Also, ich bin jetzt 4 Stunden on.
Ich glaub, ich werd demnächst auch aufgehen, weil ich hab übelst Hunger.
Es sei denn...
...wir müssen wieder ASMR-Eating-Stream machen.
Hallo, Comstar.
Okay, alles erfolgreich.
Next.
58?
Ich hatte nicht mal Level Up dazwischen.
Hab wirklich keine Ahnung. Ich glaub, das ist ein Bug.
Ich glaub, das ist ein Bug.
58.
Einfach mal ein Bug zu meinen Gunsten, ne?
Wir sind auch immer noch auf...
...immer noch auf schwer?
Also, keine Ahnung...
...was das ist.
Ich mein, mein 58...
...58, äh, mal heilen...
...channeln bedeutet ja im Endeffekt...
...ich muss eigentlich kaum noch rasten irgendwo, ja?
Vlog im Schnee.
Oh ja, das ist...
...das ist ja schon ewig, ja.
Wie sieht's eigentlich mit den...
Oh, ein...
...ein Mammut.
Ein Mammut hat so...
...so viele Minussachen.
Also, ich kann mir ganz gut merken,
wann das Vlog im Schnee war.
Das müsste irgendwie so 2013 gewesen sein.
Weil, das hab ich im Garten gemacht.
Hier im Haus, wo wir noch nicht hier gewohnt haben.
Ein Streamer hatte...
...ein Bug Lizzy36Karisma.
WTF?
Wir können ja mal gucken.
Mal gucken, was passiert, wenn ich den Ring ausziehe.
Äh.
Sollte ich jetzt nicht eigentlich weniger haben, wenn ich den Ring ausziehe?
Okay, wir lagern nochmal.
Mal gucken, wie's nächsten Tag aussieht.
Max Grill in Ehe.
Er ist immer sehr diplomatisch.
So, jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt, wie viel wir haben.
56!
Okay, also der Ring macht tatsächlich, was er soll.
Unbestreitbar macht der Ring, was er soll.
Er channelt zweimal mehr.
Ey, ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ey, ich hab wirklich keine Ahnung, was da los ist.
Das müssen wir mal googeln danach.
Das ist ein Bug.
Äh. Aha.
Ne.
Wie viele Channels kriegt man eigentlich laut Pathfinder?
Hier, da sieht man es doch.
Channel.
Geh weg.
Also.
Ich bin Level 8.
Sagen wir mal, ich wäre Level 9.
Das ist jetzt einfacher zu rechnen.
Channel Energy.
Ist das pro Tag, oder was?
Das sind ja maximal 30.
Ich könnte maximal 30 kriegen.
Maximal.
Und ich hab 58.
Also 30 hatte ich ja vorher, ne?
Ich glaub das ist verbuggt, anders kann ich mir das nicht erklären.
Tja.
Gut.
Da muss ich wohl mit leben, dass mein Clary jetzt massiv OP ist.
Du hattest 38.
Ja, das passt mit 38.
38 passt.
Guck mal.
Mal angenommen, ich hätte hier 30.
Ich habe einen Ring, der 2 gibt und 3 Talente, die jeweils 2 geben.
38 wäre okay.
Aber what the fuck?
56?
Das ist irgendein merkwürdiger Bug.
Ich starte mal neu.
Vielleicht bringt das was.
Ich will jetzt auch gar nicht so sehr Bug usen, weil ich meine,
man muss schon sagen,
58 mal AE Heal
ist schon massiv OP.
Ich hab so viel wie mit Stufe 19.
Da stimmt irgendwas nicht.
Also das ist wirklich übelst OP, wenn man sich überlegt.
Das Ding, ich hab ja auch noch viel
Caster Attribut.
Also sprich,
ich heil ja auch irgendwie 15 oder so
pro Heal.
Ja, Steam?
Wie sieht's aus?
Steam, please.
Selbst der mächtige
Gabenblick hat nichts gebracht.
Ach jetzt geht's.
Einfach so.
Es ist halt, also es ist
jetzt schon irgendwie unfair, ne?
Ich mach dann quasi 58 AE Heals.
Ich kann quasi meine Gruppe irgendwie
7 mal oder so komplett voll heilen.
Die ganze Gruppe, bevor ich rasten muss.
Das ist halt schon ein bisschen
übertrieben.
Ich muss ja auch sagen, ich find die
die Hexenmeister Spells schon
ziemlich OP.
Ich mein, das sind halt die ganz normalen
diese ganz normalen Arcane Spell
Geschichten, die es halt so gibt in den Game.
Aber wenn ich mir überleg, dass ich teilweise irgendwie
7 mal oder so
Haste casten kann, das ist auch
was mit der besten Spell
eigentlich ist, wenn man viele Mele Damage Typen
hat. Plus Pets.
Also Haste ist massiv OP
in der Partyzusammensetzung.
Ich mein,
ich hab 2 Mele Typen, 2 Pets
und die mit Haste, die gehen ab.
Wieso hast du eigentlich etwa 30
Videos gelöscht von deinem 100 Video Special?
Es sind nur 70.
Ich hab keine Ahnung. Wahrscheinlich ist es
irgendeine YouTube Geschichte.
Ich hab letztens gesehen, muss ich euch grad mal zeigen.
Ähm...
Wart mal, welches
Video war das?
Das könnte sogar das gewesen
sein. Ne, das ist das nicht.
Welches Video war das?
Das hat YouTube komplett verbuggt.
Ah ja, Noobs.
Ähm...
Wo sind die Noobs hin?
Wie hieß denn das Video? Irgendwie sowas. Wo sind alle Noobs?
Äh...
Eine Goethe.
Da, wo sind die Noobs hin?
Genau, guckt mal.
Das Video ist angeblich 7 Minuten 40.
Hä?
Jetzt ist es wieder 7 Minuten 40?
Gestern war das Video nur noch 1 Minuten 50.
Gestern war das Video 1 Minuten 50.
Und es hat auch gestern hier irgend...
Also, ich vermute echt langsam Verschwörungen
auf YouTube, ne?
Es hat auch gestern hier einer einen Kommentar gepostet.
Warum ist dieses Video nur noch
ähm...
1 Minute 50 lang?
Das ist weg. Hä?
Ach nee, das war ein anderes Video.
Wart mal, wart mal, wart mal.
Das war mal ein Windows 10 Video war das.
Das da. Guckt, das Video... Habt ihr es gesehen?
Das Video sollte eigentlich...
Das Video sollte eigentlich
9 Minuten 5 sein.
Und jetzt ist... Bei 1 Minuten 50 hat es YouTube kaputt gemacht.
Also quasi ein Video
was 6 Jahre alt ist.
Und mich würde nicht wundern,
wenn YouTube auch irgendwelche Videos
entfernt hätte. Einfach mal so, weil es verbuggt ist.
YouTube ist eh der größte
Backscheißhaufen überhaupt.
Der unsicherste.
Also mit unsicher meine ich nicht,
dass es Security mäßig ist, sondern
ähm...
für seine Zuschauer
und Content Creator.
Du hast keine Ahnung, auf welchen Grund
YouTube irgendwas entscheidet.
Naja.
Aber ein Video, was 6 Jahre alt ist
zu kürzen auf 1.50?
Da ist wahrscheinlich beim Encoden
was schief gegangen. Also ich könnte mir vorstellen,
die wollten wahrscheinlich alte Videos
nach WebM und
VP9 oder wie das Zeug heißt encoden.
Und dabei ist irgendwas kaputt gegangen.
So, Tristan. 56.
Ich kann mich nicht
dagegen wehren. Mein Clary ist verbuggt
und hat Channels wie ein Level 19 Clary.
Gut. Okay.
Alles klar, Tristan. Gutes.
Hallo Captain Paule.
Das ist aber komisch, oder? Zumal mein Clary
jetzt massiv OP ist.
Und hätte ich das gewusst,
dann hätte ich auch nicht
mal Channeltalente verschwendet,
sondern hätte einfach irgendwas anderes
gespeckt. Keine Ahnung.
Ach, was weiß ich. Okay.
Ähm.
Also wir wissen,
dass es hier mit der Mainquest nicht
weitergeht. Das heißt,
wir gehen jetzt
in die Hauptstadt zurück
und hoffen, dass wir dort irgendwie
eine Mainquest wieder kriegen.
Oder mein verbuggter Clary
äußerst optimal ist der Weg.
hat meine Mainquest verbuggt.
Machst du auch mal wieder was auf YouTube? Ja, mach ich.
Sobald es wieder Games gibt,
die ich geil finde.
Die sich auch für YouTube eignen.
Auf der Straße ist jemand.
Ich bin immer bereit.
So als Pfadfinder ist man das.
Gucken, was
jetzt hier kommt. Äh.
Trolle.
Moment, die hauen ab vor mir.
So geht's ja nicht.
Person halten.
Trolle.
Da fuck.
So. Wenigstens eingeschreckt.
Ja, die Trolle haben
Schiss vor mir, seitdem ich den Anführer gekillt hab.
Beschweren sich alle bei diesen
Spielen mit einem Schwierigkeitsgrad. Ja.
Ey. Kompletter
Witz, ne? Man sieht mal,
wie die Gegner hier weggeklatscht werden.
Und das ist schon oft schwieriger als
normal. Ist trotzdem Easy Mode.
Jaja, wir können gleich
resten.
Ach was, YOLO, wir resten nicht.
Resten.
Resten ist komplett.
Oh fuck.
Jetzt mit komplett ausgepowerter Truppe.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob die noch laufen können.
Weil ab einem gewissen
Ermüdungsgrad.
Ab einem gewissen Ermüdungsgrad können die nicht
mehr laufen.
Aber da sieht man wieder, wie viele
Noobs auf Steam Bewertungen
bleiben. Und auf Amazon ist genauso.
Bei Amazon hat dem Spiel
einer 1 von
5 gegeben, weil
es am Anfang ein Zeitlimit gibt.
Aber man muss sagen, das Zeitlimit
ähm
Das ist eigentlich nur dafür
gedacht, dass du irgendwie
bei der Sache bleibst. Das ist nicht wirklich zeitkritisch.
Also, es gibt am Anfang in dem Game
ein Zeitlimit von 90 Tagen, wo man seine
Mainquest erledigen muss.
Also am Anfang vom
Spiel ist das Gebiet, was man
das Gebieten, das man rein kann,
das ist ungefähr so
hier, das hier. Also man kann da nicht allzu
weit am Anfang.
Und
dafür hat man 90 Tage Zeit,
die Mainquest zu erledigen.
Und in der Regel, also wenn man
Ich hab mir jedes einzelne Gebiet
angeguckt. Alle Quests gemacht.
In diesem
Zeitlimit.
Und ich hab noch 35 Tage übrig von 90.
Und ich hab alles gemacht.
Du kannst gar nicht mehr machen.
Und ich hab's auch noch auf schwer gespielt.
Also, äh, vorne.
Das ist kein wirkliches Zeitlimit.
Das ist einfach nur, dass man jetzt halt
nicht ganz, nicht komplett unnötige
Dinger macht, weil sie wollen ja später, wenn
sich die Karte öffnet, dass du dann
quasi dort erst
so richtig das Gefühl
hast, jetzt in die Spielwelt rauszugehen.
Dass du am Anfang halt noch so denkst, so
ich muss mich jetzt auf meine Quests konzentrieren.
Und das hat
deswegen hat wirklich
ein Spiel eins von fünf gegeben.
Oh. Tristan hat die
Flussjungfrau geschreckt.
Die Straße
ist fertig.
Der baut immer noch
rum. Thronsaal.
Gerüchte
zufolge ist in der Region ein unbekannter, selbst
geschulter Meister.
Aha.
Jaja. Mehr Händler
sind immer gut. Das sollte am besten Tristan
machen. Der kann Leute gut überzeugen.
Ähm.
Sonst noch irgendwas, was ich...
Zehn Prozent reduzierte...
Oh, ne.
Tristan, geh weg.
Abbrechen.
Das muss Tristan machen.
Tristan
muss Gebäude um zehn Prozent reduzieren lassen.
Das ist viel wichtiger.
So.
Der kann das machen und den Handwerker
kann auch Valerie überreden.
Wunderbar.
So. Easy.
So regiert man ein Königreich.
Ganz einfach. Einfach ein paar Karten anklicken,
Leute zuweisen.
Easy money.
Thronsaal.
Woanders können wir nicht hin.
Da geht Quest weiter.
Ja. Rise ist
echt so. Ich hab das Gefühl, die Leute haben
verlernt, Spiele zu spielen, wo man
mal ein bisschen sich Gedanken machen muss.
Ich find's nice, dass man Mammut den
Kopf durchs Banner stecken hat.
Er hat meinen Untertanen Angst gemacht.
Das ist ja unerhört.
Die Götter verschmäht.
Oh nein, das geht ja
gar nicht.
Ihr müsst euch um den Wahnsinnigen kümmern.
So.
Ähm.
Wir sind uns schon einmal begegnet
vor Olegs Handels...
Sind wir das?
Weiß ich nicht. Ja.
Es liegt an euch.
Schicksal ist hier...
Reden wir über die Prophezeiung.
Blah.
Woher wisst ihr das? Blah.
Erzählt mir von dieser Göttin. Blah.
Diplomatie.
Ich hab gute Chancen, das zu packen.
Erfolgreich.
Ja. Nice.
So wird regiert.
So geht das.
Okay, wir pennen jetzt eine Runde.
Und dann hoffe ich, dass ich irgendwann meine
Main Quest weitermachen kann.
Hat man Mammut immer
noch minus Stats?
Mammut, komm her.
Ich kann meinen Mammut nicht
mehr auswählen.
Bei Hund
wurde ein Konstitutionsschaden
erneuert. Okay, da pennen wir nochmal
eine Runde und gucken, ob wieder was erneuert wird.
Nope.
Vielleicht ist das Mammut
jetzt ja auch geheilt.
Das ist ein Minecraft
Turnier. Da habe ich nichts wirklich mit am Hut.
Ich war ja nie der große Minecraft-Spieler.
Auch wenn ich mal einen
Minecraft-Server hatte.
Was Stats-Bugs kommen am häufigsten bei beschworenen
Tieren vor? Okay, das ist toll, weil ich
habe zwei beschworene Tiere am Start.
Beziehungsweise Animal Companions
bin ich nämlich wirklich beschworen.
Ob das den Spielerunterschied macht.
Mein Mammut hat 50
Stärke. Nein, leider hat mein Mammut
minus Stats und ich weiß nicht genau, warum.
Vielleicht müsste ich da auch mal
eine Genesungsschriftrolle draufhauen oder so.
Warte, hatte ich hier nicht eine?
Ich hatte doch eine Genesungsschriftrolle.
Sortiert nach Datum.
Gucken wir mal.
Ob ich die verwenden kann.
Natürlich
nicht.
Keine Genesungsschriftrolle.
Mal kurz hier gucken, ob was passiert ist.
Minecraft
hat immer noch mehr Spieler als Fortnite.
Wo kommt diese Statistik her? Aber ganz davon
abgesehen, dass es ja auch
haben wir mal ein bisschen weit hergeholt.
Wenn man mal vergleicht ist.
In so einem Spiel, wo quasi jeder
Server installieren kann.
Sau viel Community drum herum ist schon über Jahre.
Wobei es mich
echt interessiert, wie die Statistik ist.
Wenn Fortnite verkauft ist ja wirklich blöd.
Es gibt eh viele Spieler, die noch viel mehr
gespielt werden, als man denkt.
Zum Beispiel Warcraft 3 ist im russischen Raum
übelst beliebt. Ist im chinesischen und russischen Raum
übelst beliebt. Immer noch.
15 Jahre oder so, nachdem es rausgekommen ist.
Und
auch wieder im westlichen Raum wird das
tatsächlich mehr.
Was soll ich mir vorstellen? Blizzard macht anscheinend
keine neuen, gescheiten Games mehr.
Weil die Leute schon wieder Warcraft 3 auspacken müssen.
Ähm
Ja, es gibt sogar Patches für Warcraft 3.
Balance Patches, jetzt bei den 50er Jahren.
Also da kann man wirklich Blizzard
nichts vorwerfen, das nicht zu supporten.
Ja, ich muss das andere Gebiet
noch erweitern, aber irgendwie
verdiene ich zu wenig Kohle.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Ja, es würde mich interessieren, was das
für eine Statistik ist, wo die herkommt.
Wie man das ermittelt hat, dass
Minecraft mehr Spiele hat.
So, Quests.
Ich habe keine Quests mehr.
Schluck auf in 2k18.
Ja, ich weiß.
Warcraft 3 kriegt Patches.
Okay, Valerie, was gibt es Neues?
Sag mir, wo ich meine Quests kriege.
Ihr habt gewiss viele Fähre.
Ihr seid eine wirklich schöne Frau.
Okay, das müssen wir uns
jetzt mal angucken, wie die das ermittelt haben,
dass Minecraft mehr aktive Spiele hat.
Ich kann mir das schon vorstellen. Also,
Minecraft hat noch immer mehr aktive Spiele als
Fortnite.
Microsoft hat neue Zahlen zu Minecraft veröffentlicht.
Laut diesem Spiel liegt das Spiel
auf 90 Millionen aktiven Spielen.
Ja, Moment, wie misst das Microsoft denn?
Das ist bestimmt
wie in WoW, wo
die angeblich 12 Millionen
in Anführungsstrichen aktive Spiele
hatten. Dabei hatten sie 12 Millionen
Abos.
Das kann ich mir aber gut vorstellen.
Minecraft hat ja da auch gute Voraussetzungen.
Es gibt jahrelang aufgebaute Community,
jahrelang aufgebaute Server. Server zum selbst installieren.
Ähm, Mods
in Massen.
Leider in Java.
Aber, halt.
Dann doch, ne?
Alter, ich wollte es nicht auf...
Ich wollte es auf
meinem Mammut anwenden.
Alter.
Jetzt muss ich noch eine neue Schriftrolle kaufen.
Ah.
Okay. Ja.
Ich habe echt meine Probleme, wo meine
Mainquest ist.
Vielleicht muss ich einfach...
Ich gehe jetzt in den Thronraum
und mache einfach noch ein paar
sinnlose Verwaltungsquests.
Und dann kriege ich bestimmt meine neue
Mainquest.
Was haben alle gegen Java?
Ah, schwierig zu sagen.
Ja, nichts Wirksames.
Ne, also Java an sich...
Eigentlich ist Java nicht schlecht.
Java ist...
Hat so ein paar
nichtwürdige Dinge. Außerdem ist es mittlerweile
Oracle. Und Oracle ist halt Oracle.
Und mit Oracle will eigentlich kaum einer, der nicht unbedingt
muss, was zu tun haben.
Also, man kann Sachen durchaus
in Java machen. Das ist...
Ja, aber wenn ich nicht
unbedingt muss, würde ich es nicht
machen. Okay, machen wir mal
sinnlose Quests.
Also, Regionen, Ereignisse...
Ach, Moment. Ich weiß, welche Quest
noch aussteht.
Die...
Ja, ja. Die Quest in 120 Tagen.
Die mit dem Hügel steht ja noch
aus.
Unterstützt das Vorhaben.
Okay, was können wir noch alles
unterstützen? Forschung, Forschung, Forschung
unterstützt...
Okay, ich muss erstmal warten, bis die Projekte abgeschlossen
sind.
14 Tage... 14 Tage...
36...
Was genau macht
eigentlich mein Camera
gerade?
Wo ist der dran?
Ein echtes Meisterwerk
macht der. Das da.
In 3 Tagen, okay.
1...
2...
3... Nice.
Erfolg.
Easy.
Ja, das können wir gleich machen.
Jetzt helfen wir erstmal...
Jetzt
verbessern wir erstmal die Wirtschaft.
Ich glaube, ich weiß nämlich, wann's
mit der Mainquest weitergeht.
Wenn ich diese komische Hügelquest fertig hab.
Wenn ich die Hügelquest fertig hab...
Ich hab ja nur eine Hügelquest. Wenn ich die gemacht hab,
dann ist gut. Und die ist erst in 100 Tagen
fertig, deswegen klicken wir jetzt mal
sinnlose 14 Tage Projekte durch.
Wat?
Ach, Valerie...
Haha!
Wir können ja neu laden.
Also die Handelsstraße sollte schon gebaut werden.
Zum Glück wird das
Schalter nicht am Anfang, sondern
am Ende gewürfelt.
Siehste? Bam.
Cheat. Hack.
Okay.
Ereignisse.
Kamera bedarf meiner Aufmerksamkeit. Im Schloss
wartet ein Besucher. Jedes hilft
ein bisschen. Das darfst du machen.
Ergebnis starten.
Projekte.
Loyalität.
Äh.
Wat? Warum hab ich jetzt Minus
geklickt?
Weil ich den Typen nicht empfangen hab, oder was?
Alter, das muss einem das Game doch auch mal
sagen, dass das nicht wartet.
Fuck ey.
Game lull.
Das hat das...
Wusste ich überhaupt nicht, dass man die Typen auch empfangen
muss, dass sie nicht einfach warten, bis man
Zeit für sie hat. Wo sind wir denn hier?
Ich bin der krasse Baron.
Ich bin beschäftigt.
Ich kann jetzt nicht in Thronsaal.
Gut.
Nice.
Gut. Speichern. Dann gehen wir wieder in Thronsaal
und dann geht's hoffentlich
weiter. Ein neuer Besucher
im Schloss. Da kann man wieder laufen.
Okay. Kann man sonst irgendwas bauen?
Wir gehen jetzt erstmal
in Thronsaal und lassen uns die Ohren
abkauen.
Wann kommt mal wieder ein neues Video von dir?
Sobald es Games gibt, die mir gefallen.
Und die sich für YouTube eignen.
Oder ich Kohle brauch.
Lull sellout.
Mammut.
Ist am Start.
Ein untersetzter Mann um die 30 kommt auf dich zu.
Die Kriminalität
nimmt zu. Hallo, ich hab Militär plus
55 oder so.
Ich bitte euch, finde diese
Schurken und hol mir meinen
Schatz zurück. Ich bezahle euch eine hübsche
Summe. Wenn ihr...
Stimmt, ich war da.
Warum ist das neutral
gut, wenn ich sag,
der Fluch existiert, obwohl wir vorhin
in der Quest rausgefunden haben,
dass es keinen Fluch gibt?
Die Dialogoptionen sind teilweise schon
ganz schön beknackt.
Aber gut, wenn sich die Einheimischen davon
forthalten sollen, ist gar nicht so schlecht.
Was arbeitest du, wenn ich fragen darf?
Ich, ähm,
kümmere mich um unsere
Software,
unsere Source Code
Verwaltung.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich das jetzt
erklären soll, weil man nicht...
Wie erklärt man das am besten?
Stell dir vor,
jemand will
eine neue Software
Version rausbringen und hat also
ne neue Version von der Software, die er schon
schon mal veröffentlicht hat, also Version 2
oder sowas. Und
du musst ja irgendwie gucken, wie kriegst
du da alle Features rein,
wie kommen sich die Entwickler untereinander nicht ins
Gehege, was passiert,
wenn der eine was macht, was dem anderen
wieder was kaputt macht und sowas in der Richtung.
Und das pflegt man alles
halt in einem
Code Management Source Code
Verwaltungssystem. Und irgendeiner
muss sich drum kümmern, dass da sich nix
ins Gehege kommt. Gucken, dass die neue
Version rechtzeitig fertig
wird und dass man das dann
auch alles rechtzeitig ausgerollt kriegt
und sowas in der Richtung. Und das mach ich.
Ich hoffe mal, das hat...
Das konnte man jetzt verstehen.
Falls nicht, kann ich dir das noch ein bisschen genauer erklären.
Also gelernt hab ich mal Fachinformatiker
Systemintegration vor einigen...
Naja, ich wollte jetzt grad sagen
Jahrzehnten, aber
Jahrzehnte, also Jahrzehnt ist es
schon her, aber Jahrzehnte noch nicht.
Ähm...
Und...
Danach hab ich ziemlich viel
mit Linux an sich, Netzwerk,
Hochverfügbarkeit,
Rechenzentrum, Betrieb und solche
Dinger gemacht.
Wir müssen über Steuern reden.
Ich will an eurer Stelle
die Steuermoderate erhöhen...
Moment, kann ich nicht sagen, dass ich die Steuer
nicht erhöhen will? Ich bin der Baron,
wenn ich sag, ich will meine Steuer nicht erhöhen.
Dann will ich meine Steuer nicht erhöhen.
Ah, mach einfach mal.
So.
Hab ich...
Wie lang dauert denn jetzt der Quest?
52 Tage.
Okay, wir müssen noch ein 14-Tage-Projekt machen,
dann können wir die Quest beenden.
Und dann geht's hoffentlich mit der Mainquest weiter.
Quest.
Spielwerte.
Beziehungen, aber nicht so geil.
Loyalität ist schon auf Stufe 2.
Okay, Testern.
Projekt starten.
Resident Sleeper.
Gut.
Ereignisse.
275 hab ich nicht.
400 hab ich auch nicht.
Der kann nicht.
Der kann.
Der ist beschäftigt.
Okay.
Wie viel Zeit haben wir denn
jetzt noch?
Das ist also das...
Stück die Verwaltung ist wirklich
Resident Sleeper pur.
So, wie lang dauert's jetzt noch bis der...
Ja, ich würd den Rat gerne
erweisen, aber ich find ja keine Leute, die da mitmachen wollen.
Uralter Fluchteil 2.
38 Tage. Okay.
Noch ein 14-Tage-Projekt. Man kann ab
30 Tagen kann man hin zum Berg und Monster bashen.
Und dann gucken wir mal, ob die
Mainquest weitergeht.
Wähle einen Berater für diese
Stellung. Okay, der ist grad
beschäftigt mit magischer Wind.
Magischer Wind. Dauert...
Ach du Scheiße, 21 Tage im ETF.
25 Tage!
Okay, da
klicken wir jetzt einfach achtmal.
Eins, vier,
fünf...
Ereignisse...
Der hohe Priester sucht meinen Rat.
Tristan, du kannst
was machen.
Du kannst das auch machen.
Und dann besuch ich
jetzt noch den Thronsaal.
Dann haben wir's, glaub ich.
Hyper Resident Sleeper ist es. Da reicht das,
aber der normale schon nicht mehr.
Leute, ich hab Hunger.
Ich muss demnächst mal Schluss machen.
Oder ich futter jetzt was hier dabei.
Ich bringe schlechte Nachrichten.
Es ist mir
vollkommen wurscht, ehrlich gesagt.
Was bin ich für ein Baron, ha?
Ach, drei Tage noch.
So, der hohe Priester.
Okay, ich hab glaub ich
nix übrig.
Eins, zwei,
drei,
vier,
jetzt kann ich die Quest machen.
Hoffe ich.
Entschuldige die Störung.
Gäste aus dem Nachbarland. Ja, machen wir alles.
Moin, cheesy bro.
Hä?
Was genau
wollen sie? Will er jetzt eins von mir?
Lade die Gäste ein.
Alles gut.
Okay.
Ich glaub es geht weiter mit der Quest.
Nice.
Quest Wars.
Oder wird das erst 14 Tage
davor aktiv?
Moin, Alphadir.
Ja, das ist auch die
neue Main Quest. Ah, Gott sei Dank, wir haben es geschafft.
Main Quest Wars.
Ähm.
Gibt's heute Abend,
weiß das jemand? Gibt's heute Abend irgendwelche
E-Sport Veranstaltungen
oder sonstige Sachen, die man
gucken kann
auf Twitch?
Weil ich sag mal, so alt zu alt werde ich wahrscheinlich nicht mehr.
Irgendwie schon fast 5 Stunden oder so
am Start. Wie lange sind wir am Start? Ähm.
4.40.
Ja, das ist schon ein bisschen.
Ich geh jetzt zur Jagdhütte und
dann
jagen wir zünftig
mit unseren Nachbarn.
Oh.
Und wahrscheinlich müssen wir dabei
500 Monster bashen.
Morgen früh um 6 Uhr gibt's LOL Worlds.
Ähm.
Ich guck ja kein LOL.
Das ist das Problem. Ich.
Ich bin mit MOBAs
zum Gucken auch nie warm geworden.
Also zum Selbstspielen gar nicht.
Zum Gucken auch nicht.
Wohingegen ich Hearthstone gucke.
Ich weiß auch nicht warum. Ähm.
Hearthstone gucke, Starcraft gucke.
Also auch Sachen, die ich nicht spiele.
Ich hab mir letztens
sogar ein PUBG Turnier angeguckt.
Leute, habt ihr schon mal. Jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Habt ihr schon mal ein PUBG E-Sport Turnier geguckt?
Ein PUBG Competitive
Turnier.
Jetzt nicht, wo ähm.
Quasi Streamer spielen.
In irgendeinem Turnier.
Sondern, wo wirklich sagen wir mal so die
die Pros spielen.
Das ist
ultra langweilig.
Das ist ultra langweilig.
Also ähm.
Jaja.
Ich weiß nicht ob ich den Typ im Thronraum empfangen hab.
Das ist. Ich hab geguckt.
Irgendein koreanisches Turnier. Ähm.
PUBG. Weil.
Das hab ich rausgekriegt. Weil ich hab ja noch von Overwatch hier
OGM. Damals. Das sind die, die Apex
und so gemacht haben.
Hatte ich ja noch abonniert. Und irgendwie
stand dann auf einmal da. Ja, ist jetzt
online und
es läuft irgendein PUBG Turnier.
Hab ich angemacht. Das war dann irgendwie
ein 4 vs 4 vs 4 vs
4 vs 4.
Ihr versteht's. Ja.
Das war so langweilig. Die haben alle
im Busch gelegen. Die haben den kompletten
die komplette Runde
gefühlt im Busch gelegen. Oder hinterm Fenster.
Hälsen gesessen. Oder irgendwie
in der Rinne gelegen.
Das war. Das war grausam. Das hat wirklich
Das hat weh getan beim zugucken.
Also das hat
geschmerzt beim zugucken.
Dies ist keine gewöhnliche Jagd. Unsere Beute sind keine
Hasen oder Nägel. Sondern Eulen,
Bären, Hydren.
Moment. Sind Hydren die Mehrzahl
von Hydra? Ich dachte man darf
man darf Hydras sagen.
Genauso wie man Pizzas sagen darf.
Hydren.
Ist das. Muss ich jetzt nachgucken.
Das hört sich eher
so nach Hydrant oder so an.
Hydren. Mehrzahl
Hydra.
Ja.
Die Hydra. Der Hydra. Der Hydra.
Die Hydra.
Die Hydren.
Der Hydren. Den Hydren.
Ok. Die haben Recht.
Es heißt tatsächlich Hydren.
Haben wir da was gelernt.
Rechtschreibung in 2k18
sag ich dazu nur.
Das ist aber Hyperlull.
Wer hätte das gedacht.
So. Weiter.
Fortfahren.
Was sollen wir eigentlich genau machen.
Ok. Wir müssen
Gegner bashen und Trophäen zurückbringen.
Und dann sind wir geil.
Gäste untersuchen. Gäste untersuchen.
Aha. Der Star Bart.
Sozusagen.
Was ist in der Truhe.
Ich bin bereit. Klar.
Google Rechtschreibprüfung.
Ne. Ne. Das ist nicht von Google gewesen.
Das ist von
Wikijunary.
Das ist dann schon mal gleich viel geiler.
Ok. Hat man ne.
Ok.
Das verstehe ich bei dem Game nicht.
Man hat bei Quests, wo es nicht
wirklich notwendig ist. Teilweise ein Zeitlimit.
Und bei einer Quest, die quasi
im Questtext schon
sagt, es gibt ein Zeitlimit. Hat man
kein Zeitlimit. Warum?
Omega loyal.
Muss man nicht verstehen.
Oh. Hoho.
Erstmal.
Erstmal schön
das Gasthaus ausblünden.
Ach Lindsay.
Come on.
Wir knacken jetzt einfach die Kiste und machen bei dieser komischen
Ach Lindsay. Komm.
Was würfelst du denn?
Schwierigkeit 24.
Du hast plus 14.
Du kannst das eigentlich.
Du kannst einfach ne 6 und mehr werfen.
Dass die Truhe geknackt wird.
Da ist ja nicht mal was drinne.
Das ist mein Berater, oder?
Was macht der da?
Es wird immer interessanter. Hm.
Blablabla. Wie läuft
die Jagd? Ich sollte gehen.
So. Dann gehen wir mal
auf die Jagd und bashen ein paar Monster.
Oder auch nicht. Ich hab immer noch
wahnsinnig Hunger.
Jagdreviere.
Mindestens 2 der 3
magischen Bestien töten.
Okay, solange man kein Zeitlimit da hat
und angezeigt wird, muss man sich nicht
beeilen. Aber wir safen mal.
Und nachdem
wir ja einen tollen
Hexenmeister dabei haben, machen wir
jetzt einfach mal Speed an.
Und düsen
los.
Es hält leider nicht so lang.
Looten können wir nachher.
Moment, dafür muss Zeit sein.
Moment, die Map ist ganz schön
groß, ne?
Wie läuft die Jagd? Ah.
Ja, warum soll ich
die jetzt killen, WTF? Das ist natürlich
für die Beziehung zum Nachbarland bestimmt besonders gut,
wenn ich ihre Gesandten einfach mal kille.
Die können nix. Das sind die Billigwölfe.
Die Level 3 Wölfe sind das.
Die können gar nix.
Oder...
Ach ne, die sind gebufft. Das ist die gebuffte
Version von den Wölfen.
Hier geht's nicht weiter.
Was haben wir denn hier oben?
Essbares Moos.
Wieder was für das Mammut.
Oh.
Hey, Amiri kriegt so viel Schaden.
Und ihr Self-Heal
ist auch grottenschlecht.
Verschlossen.
Das können alle nix,
die Monster. Wohlgemerkt.
Das ist das Game, wo sie alle heulen, dass da Schwierigkeit
grad so hoch ist. Verschlossen?
Ja, Lindsay,
mach. Lindsay, mach.
Uff. Oh.
Und die hat schon
irgendwie sonst was geskillt, ne?
Zum Schlösser knacken.
Ah, wir haben so um
1 Hammer gefehlt.
Oh, Mann.
Fragwürdiges Design, ey.
Dieses Neuladen.
Schwerer Hammer.
Der Kniespalter ist am Start.
Schwerer Verderben Streithammer
Riesen Plus 2.
Das ist ja fast ein Diablo 2 Item-Name.
Schwerer Verderben Streithammer
Riesen Plus 2.
So könnte den Gegner in Diablo 2
heißen.
In Diablo 2 hatten ja die Gegner ganz abgedrehte Namen,
falls das überhaupt noch irgendjemand kennt.
Das war wirklich jenseits von
guten und bösen Diablo 2 Gegnernamen.
Kann man hier hoch vielleicht?
Oh, tatsächlich.
Nice.
Da lang. Aber hier kann man wirklich hoch.
Das ist cool.
Max, beeil dich.
Eine Falle.
Nicht auslösen, wenn's geht.
Nice.
Der Boden ist übersetzt. Okay, das heißt, hier gibt's
jetzt Bosskampf. Oder mal gucken,
wie stark das Ding ist.
Da ist er.
Moment, so Viecher haben wir doch unterwegs
schon massig gekillt.
Oh!
Amiri hat
einfach...
Oh, Gift.
Da hätte ich vielleicht doch nicht so noob-mäßig
rangehen sollen.
Gift verzögern.
Was habt ihr noch?
Ja, ja.
I'll survive.
I'll always survive.
Äh, wat?
Okay, zack.
Ähm...
Wir müssen Amiri
mal heilen.
Die hat
Konstitution minus 2. Gut.
Danach müssen wir mal rasten. Das passt schon.
Jetzt hab ich nur noch 12 Channels?
Was zum Teufel
ist mit dem Game nicht richtig?
What the fuck?
Was ist mit dem Game kaputt,
Alter? Das gibt's doch nicht.
Jetzt hab ich nur 12, 48, 58,
jetzt hab ich 12. Das ist komplett random
irgendwie. Das ist ziemlich verbuggt
an der Stelle.
Hab ich hier alles jetzt abgesahnt?
Ne, da ist noch Pilzerer. Pilzhorts.
Okay, Leute. Ähm...
Ich hab übelst Hunger.
Ich war fünf Stunden oder so am Start.
Mir reicht's
für heut. Gucken,
ob wir uns morgen wiedersehen.
Ich hab mir überlegt, ob wir morgen nicht
mal wieder einen Programmier-Stream machen.
Haben wir ja schon lange
nicht mehr gemacht. Wir müssen ja hier
das Meme-Tool mal endlich
ne Datenbank einbauen,
dass wir auch Settings speichern
können und neue Sachen hinzufügen.
können und sowas.
Vielleicht machen wir das morgen.
Gucken wir mal.
Ich werd jetzt erstmal safen.
Und ausmachen.
Und was futtern.
Leute, wir sehen uns morgen. Macht's gut.
Bis dann. See you.